BHAJAN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE -- WE HAVE RECEIVED
SOME BITTERSWEET NEWS -- A
REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT -- RAQUEL
THAT IN COURT TO SITTING TO MY
RIGHT IS RETIRING AND TODAY WILL
BE HER LAST DAY WITH THE SENATE.
SHE'S BEEN WITH THE CENTER FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND HAS BEEN ON
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE LEASE THE
THREE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
AND INSTITUTIONS.
SERVE THEM WITH DISTINCTION
THIRTEEN YEARS AND AND TOTAL --
IN WORKING ON RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL -- BUDGET ISSUE
SHE'S BEEN AN INTEGRAL PART OF
OUR TEAM.
HERE EVERY THURSDAY AT TEN
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER GERMAN OUR
STAFF SINGS YOUR PRAISES AND IF
CONVEYED. TO ME HOW MUCH THEY'VE
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU THIRTY
YEARS AND YOU WILL BE MESS --
THANK YOU RECOUNT. FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CENTER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WISH YOU A WONDERFUL.
NEXT CHAPTER IN YOUR LIFE AND
HAPPY TRAILS.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL.
JUMP TO PART A WHICH IS OUR
PRESENTATION THE GREENHOUSE GAS --
FUN.
MR BROWN GOOD MORNING THE ALLEY
WILL HAVE HAS AN OVERVIEW --
SORRY FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF RUST
BROWN WITH THE LA -- I'M GONNA
JUST GIVE A TRY TO GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSED CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
I'M GONNA KIND OF BREAK IT UP
INTO TWO DIFFERENT PARTS ONE
JUST A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
JUST THE BASIC STRUCTURE OF THE
PLAN INCLUDING REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES AND FUND BALANCES
IN KIND OF THE AMOUNT THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE FOR EXPENDITURES IN.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND THEN TALK
ABOUT JUST SOME OF THE SPECIFICS
OF THE PROPOSED EXPENDITURES SO
TO START OFF.
THE TOP LEVEL -- THE TABLE ON
PAGE FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA KINDA
GIVES YOU.
A MORE DETAILED PICTURE OF
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES AND
FINE BALANCES -- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASSUMING TWO
POINT SIX BILLION IN REVENUE IN
THE CURRENT YEAR AND TWO POINT
ONE BILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR --
AND IS PROPOSING A TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR -- SPENDING
PLAN AND THE BUDGET YEAR.
INCLUDING CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS AS WELL AS OTHER
EXPENDITURES INCLUDING
DISCRETIONARY EXPENDITURES.
AND THAT WOULD LEAVE ACCORDING
THEIR PROJECTIONS ARE LESS THAN
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FUND
BALANCE AT THE END OF THE YEAR
AT THE END OF THE BUDGET YEAR.
WE'VE PROJECTS THAT'S REVENUE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS OF
FLOWERS PRICES IN AUCTIONS
CONTINUE THE WAY THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN AROUND AT THE FLOOR PRICE.
REVENUE WILL BE ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION MORE THAN WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROJECTING
OVER THE TWO YEARS.
AND THEN AFTER YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE AMOUNT THAT GOES TO
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT WOULD LEAVE ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN THE
FUND BALANCE AT THE END OF THE
BUDGET YEAR.
THERE'S STILL QUITE A BIT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
AROUND REVENUE AND SO WE DO
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO BE
CAUTIOUS AND LEAVE SOME -- IN
THE FUND BALANCE AT THE END OF
THE BUDGET YEAR.
BUT EVEN UNDER UNDER OUR
PROJECTIONS EVEN IF THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE TO SPEND FOR
EXAMPLE A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS MORE WE STILL THINK THAT
WOULD LEAVE -- A HEALTHY RESERVE
IN THE FUND BALANCE.
THE SECOND ISSUE I WANT TO GET
TO IS JUST THE MULTI YOUR
OUTLOOK ON SPENDING JUST KIND OF
LOOKING AT WHAT REVENUES MIGHT
BE AGAIN A MARKET CONDITIONS
CONTINUE THE WAY THEY ARE OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS -- WE PROJECT
REVENUE WOULD BE ROUGHLY IN THE
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
RANGE AND SO THAT LEAVES FOR
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING --
SOMETHING CLOSE TO NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS -- FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE IN
FUTURE YEARS REVENUE AGAIN STAYS
THE WAY THAT HAS BEEN -- SO WE
JUST WANT TO KEEP THAT IN MIND
WHEN YOU'RE KIND OF THINKING
ABOUT LONG TERM SPENDING YOU
KNOW ROUGHLY NINE HUNDRED
MILLION -- GOING FORWARD AND
THINKING ABOUT.
WHEN YOU COMMIT TO KIND OF MULTI
YEAR SPENDING -- KIND OF KEEPING
THAT WILL TELL YOUR SPENDING
BELOW THAT AMOUNT -- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HAS ROUGHLY
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND MULTI
YEAR SPENDING ON IT SO THAT IS
LOWER THAN.
THE NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
AND THEN FINALLY THE JUST A KIND
OF VERY A TECHNICAL ISSUE AROUND
THE THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WHICH WOULD GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SOME AUTHORITY.
TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
ALLOCATIONS OF REVENUE COMES AND
BELOW WHAT'S EXPECTED WE THINK
THAT'S A VERY -- A REASONABLE
APPROACH GENERALLY TO KIND OF
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND REVENUE.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND AUTHORITIES HERE TO MAKE.
SOME OF THOSE REDUCTIONS OTHER
PROGRAMS WOULD BE LEFT HOLE ONE
HIGHLIGHT THAT FOR YOU AND JUST
MAKE SURE.
THAT THOSE -- KIND OF REDUCTIONS
pTHE LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZES SOME
OF THOSE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN
WHICH ONE SHOULD BE CAPITAL.
SO WITH THAT I'LL JUST MOVE ON
TO A BRIEF DISCUSSION OF THE
SPENDING PLAN ITSELF SO ON PAGE.
SIX OF YOUR HAND OF YOUR AGENDA
EXCUSE ME HAS A TABLE.
OF THE PROPOSED SPENDING PLAN
AND A COMPARISON TO WHAT THE
EXPENDITURES WERE LAST YEAR NOT
GONNA GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE --
ALL THE DIFFERENT PROPOSALS I
THINK JUST IN GENERAL IT'S
LARGELY CONTINUATION OF
PROVIDING FUNDS TO PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN FUNDED WITH THREE G.
R. F. IN THE PAST.
SOME OF THE AMOUNTS ARE A LITTLE
BIT LOWER THAT'S LARGELY --
REFLECTION OF THE LOWER EXPECTED
RESOURCES AND REVENUE THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THE BUDGET YEAR --
THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENT AMOUNTS
FOR DIFFERENT PROGRAMS I THINK
ONE JUST A HIGHLIGHT I THINK
YOU'LL BE HEARING THAT IN THE
NEXT PART OF YOUR AGENDA THE
ONLY REAL KIND OF NEW PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED AS THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
PROPOSAL -- AND SO I WON'T.
TALK ABOUT THAT IN DETAIL BUT
JUST WANTED TO FLAG THAT FOR YOU.
A COUPLE OF ISSUES TO CONSIDER
WHEN YOU'RE KIND OF LOOKING AT
THE PLAN ONE IS FOR A LOT OF THE
PROPOSALS.
BUT NOT A LOT OF DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT KIND OF WHAT
THE EXPECTED OUTCOMES ARE FOR A
LOT OF THE AREAS OF FUNDING --
IN SOME CASES EVEN JUST KIND OF
A NUMBER OF PROJECTS WOULD BE
FUNDED BUT THEN ALSO EXPECTED
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS OR
OTHER TYPES OF BENEFITS AND SO.
WE THINK OR RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GOT A REPORT
ON WHAT TO EXPECT SOME OF THOSE
OUTCOMES TO BE WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT.
SOMETIMES IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
BUT WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
YOU MAKING DECISIONS ON HOW TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING AS WELL AS
KEEPING THE ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT THEY EXPECT
GOING FORWARD.
ANOTHER ISSUE WE DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT SOME OF THE
PROGRAM SOME FOR SOME PROGRAMS
SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO THE PROGRAMS
MIGHT BE NEEDED IN THE BUDGET
YEAR UNDER THE PROPOSED.
ALLOCATIONS SO FOR EXAMPLE --
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECTS --
PROPOSAL CONSISTENT WITH AN
ACTION THAT WAS ADOPTED LAST
YEAR IS TO PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THOSE REBATES --
UNDER SOME A CARBS RECENT
PROJECTIONS THE DEMAND FOR THOSE
REBATES WILL BE SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER THAN THAT -- IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND SO THAT MIGHT
MEAN SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
PROGRAM WHAT ABOUT ME AND BE
SORT OF THE AMOUNT OF THE REBATE
OR WHO IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
REBATE.
AND SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO ASK THE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT ON
KIND OF WHAT TYPES OF
ADJUSTMENTS THEY EXPECT TO MAKE
IN ORDER TO KIND OF STAY WITHIN
THE PROPOSED BUDGET AMOUNT.
AND THEN FINALLY JUST MORE
GENERALLY -- WE JUST WE CONTINUE
TO RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOCATE FUNDING TO ITS HIGHEST
PRIORITIES.
WHICH YOU KNOW COULD BE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS OTHER PRIORITIES WE
KNOW ARE RELATED TO REDUCING
LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS CLIMATE
ADAPTATION SO THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THOSE HIGHEST PRIORITIES
ARE.
AND ONCE THOSE ARE IDENTIFIED TO
THINKING ABOUT WHICH PROGRAMS
ACHIEVE THOSE MOST EFFECTIVELY
ON THE GREENHOUSE GAS SIDE WE'VE.
BROUGHT A LOT OF COMMENTS IN THE
PAST AND HOW TO THINK ABOUT THAT
AND HOW SOME OF THE SPENDING
INTERACTS WITH OTHER REGULATORY
PROGRAM SO.
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO THINK
ABOUT THAT -- ONE OTHER THING WE
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IT AGAIN ON
THE GREENHOUSE GAS SIDE OF
THINGS -- THINKING ABOUT.
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES GLOBALLY AND
GIVEN THAT RELIC CALIFORNIA IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THINK ABOUT -- WHICH PROGRAMS
ARE LIKELY TO KIND OF PROMOTE
EMISSION REDUCTION AND AND OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL SO WHETHER
THAT BE -- LOADING INNOVATION OR
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT MAYBE
COULD BE.
ADOPTED ANOTHER TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WHETHER THAT'S YOU
KNOW DEMONSTRATING SOME
PARTICULAR PROGRAM THAT MAYBE
OTHER JURISDICTIONS ARE LIKELY
TO ADOPT.
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE DIFFICULT
THINGS TO ANALYZE BUT WE DO
THINK THEY'RE IMPORTANT TO KEEP
IN MIND WE'RE KIND OF
CONSIDERING THE OVERALL PACKAGE
OF DIFFERENT.
STRATEGIES SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
CAN YOU I'M YEAH WE'VE GOT MOST
OF US RECEIVE THIS ANNUAL REPORT
FROM THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD INTO
TALKING ABOUT THE APPROPRIATED
FUNDS AND IN THE ALLOCATED FUNDS
AND THEN THE SELECTED IN THE
WARD.
WERE DEFENSE IN THE IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTED FUNDS SO WHILE WE
MAY SIT HERE IN SUB TO AND SAY
WE WANT.
TO A LOT THIS MUCH MONEY.
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET SPEND IN
THE THE REPORT SUGGESTS THAT
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF MONEY
THAT.
I GUESS WE SAY IN THE PIPELINE
SO WELL WE WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THAT-THAT CONCERN AND WE MAY WANT TO
PUT IN LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS.
FINANCE TO PUT ON THE BRAKES.
JUST DISAPPEARS THE MEAN JUST ON
THE NATURAL THAT.
WE WOULD KNOW THE RESULTS OF
AUCTIONS IF WE OVER ANTICIPATED
OR OVER PROJECTED WELL BEFORE
ANYBODY'S WRITING CHECKS MY
WRONG ON THIS -- I MEAN I I
THINK FOR THE ALLOCATIONS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE THEN YEAH
THERE THERE IS OFTEN TIMES SORT
OF A DELAY IN.
GETTING THAT FINDING OUT THE
DOOR AND SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY NEW ONES TAKES
AWHILE TO GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR --
THE AUCTION RESULTS ARE
TYPICALLY AVAILABLE ABOUT A WEEK
AFTER THE AUCTION IS ACTUALLY
HELD AND SO YEAH I KNOW THEIR
APARTMENT A FINANCE REVIEWS
THOSE ESTIMATES ARE OFFICE
REVIEWS THOSE ESTIMATES AND
OTHER THERE IS A TIME I'M SURE
YOU AND AND MANY OTHERS REVIEW
THOSE ESTIMATES AND SO.
PART OF IT CAN BE KIND OF A
CONVERSATION I THINK BETWEEN
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THAT -- WHATEVER
LANGUAGE IS KIND OF IN THE BILL
DOESN'T.
NECESSARILY GIVE TOO MUCH
AUTHORITY OR IS IT OR MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS ALWAYS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES ARE I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
THERE'S A THE WORLD HAS A DESIRE
BUILT A DESIRE. TO BE MORE
AMBITIOUS AND ALL ALL COUNTRIES
IN ALL WAYS AND IF WE'RE
CAUTIOUS ON THE SPENDING OF
MONEY THAT WE HAVE AN AN AUCTION
BECAUSE WE'RE PROJECTING.
AGAIN I'VE.
I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE FOR EIGHT
YEARS AND EVERY TIME THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION MADE A
BUDGET [inaudible]
OUR PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FINANCE WAS
VERY VERY MUCH LOW BALLED THE
THE THE AUCTION I'VE.
I'VE WHAT ALL THE OPTIONS
PROJECTIONS TEND TO BE LOW BALL
I'D I'D.
I AGREE WITH YOUR ANALYSIS OF
THE EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
ADDITIONAL -- THERE THAT'S
AVAILABLE.
REQUIRED BY LAW IS IN AN
AMBITIOUS WAY THERE'S I'M TRYING
TO GET THAT RIGHT BALANCE OF
LET'S GET THIS MONEY OUT AND
WHETHER IT'S ANOTHER HUNDRED
MILLION IN THE YOU KNOW -- CLEAN
CAR PROGRAM CASSETTES OVER
PRESCRIBED EVERY YEAR EVERY YEAR
WE KNOW THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO BUY THOSE THOSE
THINGS OR WHATEVER PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE THAT WILL REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES.
WILL RECEIVE THE ACTUAL BENEFIT
IF THAT.
ASIAN MARKETS DONE SO.
DO YOU SEE THE THE STRUGGLE THAT
I'M HAVING WITH WITH TRYING TO
SAY BE CAUTIOUS BUT ALSO BE
AMBITIOUS.
ABSOLUTELY AND I'M NOT THAT'S
CLEARLY A STRUGGLE IN AND I
THINK WE DO THINK THAT THERE --
WILL LIKELY BEES -- SOME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT -- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD IF IT'S IF IT
WANTS TO GET MONEY OUT TO DOLE
OUT THE DOOR SOONER COULD
POTENTIALLY ALLOCATED THIS YEAR
WHILE STILL HAVE BEEN KIND OF
TAKING A CAUTIOUS APPROACH AS
WELL AND HAVING AN ADEQUATE FUND
BALANCE BUT IT'S YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO -- THERE'S NO MAGIC
ANSWER I DON'T THINK I'M KIND OF
HOW TO BALANCE THAT RISK OF OF
INSURING THAT THERE'S FISCAL
STABILITY BUT ALSO TRYING TO GET.
MONEY OUT THE DOOR AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND SO THAT THAT'S JUST
A MATTER OF OF RISK IN TRYING TO
EVALUATE THAT.
WHAT'S YOUR OPINION ON THE
CURRENT -- PRICE OF THE
ALLOWANCES BECAUSE I I SAW IN
THE REPORT THAT CAR PUT OUT.
THAT THEY WERE LOOKING AT A
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLAR FOR TIME AND
BUT HOW THE DAVE OF PHRASES.
THE CARD HE WORKED WITH THE
APPLICATION OF OF OF ALL THE
PROGRAMS COMES OUT TO BE.
ABOUT A SEVENTY FIVE DOLLAR PER
TON.
COSTS FOR WHETHER IT'S METHANE
REDUCTIONS ARE PRESCRIBED BURNS
WHATEVER WAS IN THE AUCTION IS
NORTH OF FIFTEEN DOLLARS -- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S A
DISCONNECTION THERE HOW DOES THE
LA -- REVIEW THAT.
I MEAN I I THINK OUR GENERAL
VIEW IS THAT YOU KNOW RELYING ON
SORT OF THE PRICE GIVEN THROUGH
ALLOWANCES IS -- LIGHT AND MANY
CASES THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO KIND OF ENCOURAGE THOSE
REDUCTIONS IN SO RIGHT NOW AS
YOU HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF THE
PRICE AND THE CAP AND TRADE
MARKET IS MUCH LOWER THAN SOME
OF THE ESTIMATED.
COST PER GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS -- THROUGH THE
SPENDING SIDE OF THINGS AND SO
WE WE DO THINK SORT OF RELYING
ON THE PRICE SIGNAL GIVEN
THROUGH THOSE ALLOWANCE PRICES
IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE WAY
GENERALLY TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
NOW WITH THAT SAID THAT THERE
ARE CERTAINLY OTHER AREAS AND
OTHER REASONS TO KIND OF SPEND
MONEY ON DIFFERENT THINGS AND
SOME OF THOSE. FOR EXAMPLE ARE
YOU EVEN -- WITH AID YOU KNOW
HIRE -- ALLOWANCE PRICE FOR
EXAMPLE THERE MIGHT NOT BE SORT
OF QUITE ENOUGH INNOVATION AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND IT DOESN'T
QUITE SEND THAT SIGNAL AND SO
THERE'S OTHER TYPES OF NO
COMMENTS REFER TO THESE AS
MARKET FAILURES WHERE YOU KNOW
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A A STATE
ROLLING KIND OF USING.
FUNDS TO PROMOTE THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS AND SO THAT'S ONE
CONSIDERATION WHEN THINKING
ABOUT SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
THEY TARGETED AT THOSE TYPES OF
OF BENEFITS AND I THINK ANOTHER --
ANOTHER ISSUE IS YOU KNOW A LOT
OF THESE PROGRAMS I THINK ARE.
AT LEAST PARTIALLY TARGETED
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION AND SO ON
THE GREENHOUSE GAS SIDE THEY
MIGHT NOT BE AS SORT OF COST
EFFECTIVE AS SOME OF THE OTHER
APPROACHES BUT THE GOAL FOR SOME
OF THEM IS TO ACHIEVE SOME OF
THESE OTHER BENEFITS AND SO
TRYING.
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE A
GOOD HANDLE ON UNDERSTANDING AND
INFORMATION ON THE DEGREE TO
WHICH IT IS ACHIEVING SOME OF
THOSE OTHER BENEFITS AS WELL AN
SORT OF TRYING TO EVALUATE THAT
AND WEIGH THAT AGAINST WHAT
MIGHT BE.
A DIFFERENCE IN COST COMPARED TO
SOME OTHER POLICIES WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO FOLLOW YOUR ADVICE
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
EXPENDITURE PLAN IS ONLY SPENT
ON NON COVERED ENTITIES VERSUS
COVERED ENTITIES IN THE EARLY
DAYS WE WERE.
WE WERE WE WERE.
AUCTIONING -- POLLUTION
ALLOWANCES AT A LOW PRICE WE ARE
GIVING OUT FREE ALLOWANCES ON
TOP OF IT FOR IN OUR AMBITION TO
SMOOTH THINGS OUT.
AND AND THEN WE WERE ACTUALLY
HELPING OUT COVERED ENTITIES WHO
ARE ALREADY PARTICIPATING AND
AND THE AUCTION WE DIDN'T
SEGREGATE THAT WE SHOULD BE
GIVING THESE.
THESE PROCEEDS THERE IF YOU HAVE
IF YOU HAVE AN OVER ALLOTMENT OF
FREE ALLOWANCES ARE OUT THERE
CURRENTLY AND IF YOU HAVE A
CRISIS IT'S FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
AND HOW WOULD. ONE THING HERE WE
HEAR HIMSELF TO WE WANT TO SPEND
THE MONEY I GET I GET THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE DO BUT IF WE WANT
TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR.
IF IT ISN'T IT BETTER TO GET
THAT SEVENTY FIVE DOLLAR PRICE
CLOSER TO WHAT THE WHAT THE
ALLOWANCE PRICES TO THAT THE
COVERED ENTITIES WOULD BE
CHOOSING. TO TO THE INVESTMENT
RATHER THAN TO BUY THE ALLOWANCE
OR GET THE FREE ALLOWANCE TO MY
NOT.
FOLLOWING YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT
NOW WE HAVE A REPORT THAT THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE SPENDING AGAIN
SOME OF ITS VERY HIGH SOME OF
IT'S SLOW BUT BUT THE BLENDED
RATE.
I MEAN I I THINK.
V. OUR VIEW IS IS.
I THINK -- CLEAR FOCUS SHOULD BE
ON MAKING SURE THAT THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM KIND OF IN THE
NUMBER OF ALLOWANCES THAT ARE
ISSUED AND DISTRIBUTED.
IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE THE
GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
LAID OUT AND WE THINK IT'S IT'S
THAT'S DONE -- IF THAT'S DONE
WELL THEN THE ALLOWANCE PRICES
WILL KIND OF PROVIDE THAT TYPE
OF SIGNAL THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOUR COVERED ENTITIES AND
BUSINESSES AND HOUSEHOLDS TO
MAKE THOSE REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW MAKING SURE
THAT THAT THAT KIND OF THAT
PROGRAM IS SET UP IN A WAY
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOALS IS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO HOW TO HOW
TO WRAP AROUND SOME OF THE THE
EXPENDITURES AND OTHER POLICIES
AROUND THAT -- IT IS KIND OF THE
NEXT IMPORTANT STEP AS WELL SHE
PASSES TO PRIORITIZE OUR FUNDING
PROPOSALS AND LET AND LOOK AT
THE OUTCOMES AND WE'VE ALWAYS.
TALK ABOUT THE BIGGEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK.
BUT IF WE IF WE KNEW THAT
COVERED ENTITIES WERE MAKING
INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE THE
POLLUTION RATHER THAN YOU KNOW
WITH THE LAST REPORT WE GOT FROM
THE AIRPORT WAS THAT PEOPLE ARE
DRIVING MORE MILES.
YOU KNOW THE POLLUTION IS
ACTUALLY GOING UP AND THEN WE
HAVE A FOREST FIRE INCIDENTS
WHICH WHICH AREN'T EVEN
CALCULATED IN OUR IN OUR
COVERAGE.
IT'S IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT ON A
GOOD DAY IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO PRIORITIZE
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE MARKET
RATE WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING OUT THERE THIS IS.
A SIXTY DOLLAR.
DISTANCE RIGHT IF IT WERE CLOSER
THAN IT WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
TASK FOR US TO SAY.
WE'RE GONNA PUTS MORE MONEY AND
RESEARCHER MORSE MONEY IN THESE
IN THESE OTHER AREAS.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO YOU
KNOW REALLY GET TO ZERO CARBON I
GUESS IS IT VERSUS JUST TRYING.
TO TREAD WATER.
FINANCE IF ANYTHING THERE.
THIS IS A GOOD OVERVIEW
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
IN LOOKING AT THE EXPENDITURE
PLAN IN THE VARIOUS CATEGORIES.
THERE'S NOTHING DEDICATED NERO
OCEANS AND I'M JUST WONDERING IF
THAT SON ANYBODY'S RADAR WE HAVE.
PROGRAMS RELATED TO OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION.
CARBON SEQUESTRATION PRACTICES --
I GUESS MAYBE IT'S MORE OF A
QUESTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
TARGETING SOME PRIORITIES BUT IT.
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION -- FOR LA --
GIVEN ANY CONSIDERATION.
TO BROADENING EXPENDITURE.
PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE OCEANS.
THANK YOU JULIANNE MOORE IS TO
ME WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
IN THE EXPENDITURE PLAN THERE IS
MONEY APPROPRIATED TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION AND THE BABY.
COSTA COUNTY CDC.
BAY CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT.
COMMISSION FOR COASTAL
ADAPTATION PURPOSES THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY IS HAS QUITE
A BIT OF FUNDING THROUGH -- PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT BUT AS FAR AS THE
CAP AND TRADE PROCEEDS -- SO AS
FAR AS THE OCEAN THE COASTLINE.
WE ARE FUNDING [inaudible]
RIGHT SO.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW
THAT WE ARE FOR THE SUM OF OUR
PROPOSITION FUNDING.
COASTAL CONSERVANCY IS IS ONE OF
THE RECIPIENTS -- THAT YOU
MENTION I JUST THINK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO HAVE A MORE HOLISTIC
APPROACH IN AGAIN BEST
INVESTMENTS TO ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVES.
OCEAN SHOULD BE PART OF IT.
THAT'S MORE OF A COMMENT THAN A
QUESTION THANKS [inaudible]
EARN.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING INDULGING
ME JUST AT THE HIGH HIGH LEVEL --
BEYOND ANY PARTICULAR CATEGORY
ONE TO SORT OF FOLLOW UP ON THE
CHAIRS.
POINT IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL
PURPOSE IN STRATEGY BEHIND THAT
THE PLAN BROUGHT FORWARD TO US
AND AT THE DRIVING PIECES I
DON'T THINK SHOULD BE COST
EFFECTIVENESS ON A DOLLAR PER
TON BASIS I THINK THAT'S THE THE
WRONG STRATEGY FOR THIS TYPE OF
CAPITAL -- WHERE?
THE CARBON PRICES REALLY DRIVING
THE COST EFFECTIVE REDUCTIONS
BUT THIS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND IS A PLACE TO ME
TO BE PATH BREAKING IN CREATIVE
SO.
JUST BOTH FROM THE F. AND FROM
FROM LA -- HOW DO YOU LOOK AT
THE SORT OF [inaudible]
INNOVATION.
IN EFFICACY OR IS IT LIKE THAT
THAT METRIC OF HOW MUCH ARE WE
ACTUALLY.
STIMULATING INNOVATION IN THIS
STATE SO WE CAN SORT OF BE
BIGGER THAN WE ARE MAYBE I JUST
TRY TO GET A SENSE OF THAT MAYBE
START WITH THE F. AND THEN COME
UP TO LA -- IS THAT IS THAT
METRIC A MEANINGFUL ONE TO YOU
ALL THESE AT THE END NONE
LOOKING FOR SORT OF THE THESIS
HERE AT LEAST OF WHAT IS DRIVING
YOUR STRATEGY.
RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR DOWNTURN --
THE ADMINISTRATION. FOR THE CAP
AND TRADE FUNDS AND WE WOULD
AGREE WE WANT TO LOOK AT A LOT
OF THE CO BENEFITS.
NOT JUST GHG EMISSION REDUCTION
BUT SOME OF THE OTHER BENEFITS
SOME OF THE POLLUTANT MATERIAL --
REDUCTIONS -- FUEL REDUCTION
WHICH DOES THAT DOESN'T DIRECTLY.
EIGHT TWO MAYBE.
GHG REDUCTIONS BUT IF THE
REFINERIES DON'T.
NEED TO PRODUCE AS MUCH IN AN IN
AN INDIRECT WAY IT WILL.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS WE ALSO ARE -- MEETING A
LOT OF THE FUNDING IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LOW
INCOME YOU LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT --
NOT CRITERIA BUT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VALUE. TO
HOW THE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED AND
IF I MAY I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT AT A HIGH LEVEL WHAT THE
ANNUAL REPORT.
WILL POINT OUT CORRECT THAT WAS
THAT WAS RELEASED EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
THAT NINE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN -- APPROPRIATED
IN FUNDING FOR PROJECTS THAT
FACILITATE THE GHG REDUCTIONS.
AND SUPPORT A VARIETY OF STATE
PRIORITIES.
SO THOSE INCLUDE LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION WILDFIRE
PREVENTION.
JOBS.
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCY.
ADMINISTERING AGENCIES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO CARRY OUT AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION TONS OF GHG EMISSIONS
REDUCTION.
AND THAT IS JUST THE G. H. T.
ASIDE FROM ALL OF THE OTHER CO
BENEFITS -- THE INVESTMENTS ARE
HELPING PRIORITY POPULATIONS
WHICH WE IDENTIFIED AS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. 57% OF THE
IMPLEMENTED FAN FUNDING HAS
BENEFITED THE PRIORITY
POPULATIONS WITH 36% OF THE
IMPLEMENTED FUNDING LOCATED
WITHIN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SO WE ARE BEGINNING TO TARGET.
A LOT OF THE INVENTOR WELL THE
INVESTMENTS HAVE MET AND
EXCEEDED.
THE INVESTMENTS MINIMUMS THAT
HAVE BEEN SET FORTH IN.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY AN SP.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE THE REPORT ALSO
INCLUDES STATISTICS.
FROM THE GROWING INFORMATION ON
THE KOBE AND IF IT'S THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT.
THE ANNUAL REPORT ALSO PROVIDES
OUTCOMES.
FROM THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED.
SO FOR EXAMPLE OUT OF THE
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN MILLION
APPROPRIATED FOR THE AGRICULTURE
REPLACEMENTS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX
POINT THREE MILLION HAS BEEN A
WAR WELL. THIRTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
WITH TEN THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF
GHG EMISSION REDUCTIONS ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION POUNDS OF
KNOX REDUCTIONS.
OVER NINETY NINE THOUSAND POUNDS
OF DIESEL PM TWO POINT FIVE
REDUCTIONS AND ALMOST A HUNDRED
GALLONS AND FUEL REDUCTION. 73%
OF THE FUNDS WERE IN
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND HOUSEHOLDS.
THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM.
OUT OF THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION ALLOCATED
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION IMPLEMENTED IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RESULTS IN SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF GHG
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. TWELVE
POINT THREE MILLION GALLONS IN
FUEL REDUCTION. NINE POINT SEVEN
MILLION POUNDS OF KNOX
REDUCTIONS.
AND ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND POUNDS OF DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER.
REDUCTIONS.
SO.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
EXACTLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
TABLES IN THERE AND THEY ALL
SHOW DIFFERENT -- THAT WE CAN
LOOK AT THINGS.
AND AND IT IS A MATTER OF
BALANCING.
OUT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT.
BENEFITS NOT JUST GHG BUT
BENEFITS TO THE COMMUNITIES
BENEFITS YOU KNOW RECOGNIZING
SOME OF THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE HIT HARDER.
AND WE WANT TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
THE THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUES AS WELL AND WE'RE USING
THIS AS A MECHANISM TO DO THAT.
TO THE TUNE OF 57%.
MISTER BROWN YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT.
YEAH I MEAN I I THINK.
IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
AND AND FROM OUR VIEW IS SORT OF
A VERY REASONABLE WAY TO KIND OF
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY
PRIORITIZING FUNDS AROUND YOU
KNOW TO ACHIEVE IN THE THE
BIGGEST IMPACT ON GREENHOUSE
GASES SORT OF THINKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW TO PROMOTE INNOVATION.
HERE TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT KIND
OF HOW TO HOW TO DO THAT.
I THINK THE CHALLENGES YOU KNOW
INNOVATION IS I THINK AN
INHERENTLY A VERY DIFFICULT
THING TO QUANTIFY.
AND TRYING TO THINK THROUGH WHAT
IS THE STATE'S ROLE IN KIND OF
THE PROMOTING THAT INNOVATION
PARTICULARLY AMONG SORT OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHETHER THAT BE
KIND OF EARLY.
STAGE RESEARCH OR SOMETHING KIND
OF FURTHER DOWN THE LINE MAYBE
PILOTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS
PROTOTYPES OR JUST KIND OF THE
NEAR DEPLOYMENT OF KIND OF NEWER
TECHNOLOGIES COMMERCIALLY -- I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE SORT OF
A GREAT ANSWER ON KIND OF WHERE
EXACTLY.
IN THAT KIND OF PIPELINE THE
THAT THE STATE CAN KIND OF BEST
SPEND ITS RESOURCES I KNOW YOU
KNOW -- YOUR SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH HAS RECENTLY DONE QUITE
A BIT OF WORK ON THIS -- WE
DEFINITELY THINK IT'S KIND OF
THE THE RIGHT TYPE OF QUESTION
TO BE KIND OF ASKING AND AND
THINKING ABOUT -- ON KIND OF HOW
TO USE THIS MONEY TO KIND OF
PROMOTE THAT TYPE OF INNOVATION
AND WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK LOOK.
INTO KINDA TRYING TO EVALUATE
THAT AS MUCH AS WE CAN BUT I DO
THINK IT'S KIND OF AN INHERENTLY
VERY DIFFICULT THING.
YOU MISSED RENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD JUST I WOULD ASK I
KNOW YOU'RE BOUNCING A LOT OF
PRIORITIES IN COMMUNITIES AND
INJUSTICES AND ALL THE ALL THE
THE VARIETY OF THINGS WE ASK YOU
DO AS A LEGISLATURE BOTH IN.
TRAILER LANGUAGE OVER TIME
REPORTING PROTOCOLS ETCETERA BUT
I WOULD LOVE THE CREATIVE
THINKING OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
TO HELP US SORT OF THINK THROUGH.
HOW DO WE PUNCH BEYOND OUR UP
ABOVE OUR WAIT HERE FROM
INNOVATION PERSPECTIVE HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY SHOW THAT WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING GAME CHANGING -- IN
ADVANCEMENTS IN OUR IN OUR
APPROACH TO GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS NOT JUST OF BUYING
DOWN THE LOWEST CONCEPT FOR
SPREADING IT OUT TO ALL THE
VARIOUS POLITICAL CONSTITUENCIES
THAT CARE ABOUT THIS MONEY LIKE.
DOING SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE
A LITTLE BOLDER AND A LITTLE
FARTHER REACHING.
IF YOU IF YOU CAN START TO THINK
ABOUT THAT THE FACT THAT
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT ISN'T
EVEN IN HERE AND WAS WAS TAKEN
DOWN AND I DON'T KNOW IF AGAIN
MAYBE THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
INTERVENTION POINT.
BUT UNDERLYING THAT I DON'T WANT
TO CONCEDE THAT INVESTING IN
INNOVATION IS IGNORING INJUSTICE.
THE GREATEST THING YOU CAN DO
FOR EQUITY IS BRING DOWN THE
COST OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND
DELIVER THEM THESE COMMUNITIES
WHO NEED THEM AND SO IT'S A
LONGER VIEW BUT ANYWAY -- JUST
SUBMITTED FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
ZUNI IN CENTER STERN WE SHOULD
REMIND OURSELVES THIS IS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SENATE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
TOGETHER WILL BE DEVELOPING OUR
EXPENDITURE PLAN FOR ON THE
DISCRETIONARY -- FUNDS THAT ARE
RESULTS FROM AGREED UPON --
NUMBER FOR A GREENHOUSE GASES
MISS MARS NESN AND I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT WHILE IT MIGHT
NOT BE CALLED OUT.
SPECIFICALLY IN SOME OF THESE --
HE SAYS.
THERE ARE DEMONSTRATION PILOTS --
DEMONSTRATION PROGRAMS I MEAN
AND PILOTS AND OTHER.
FORMS OF TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH AND
AND VERIFYING.
AND I CAN'T GET INTO THE DETAILS
I WOULD NEED I WOULD NEED THE
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE.
THAT DETAIL BUT I WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE DOES NEED TO BE
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE TECHNOLOGY
FIELD.
AND IT'S IT'S CUTTING EDGE ALL
THE TIME THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE GOING.
AND WITH THAT.
OVERVIEW LET'S TURN THE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THIS IS THE ACTUAL --
GREENHOUSE GAS [inaudible]
REDUCTION FUND [inaudible]
YOUR MATH.
PAGER SIX OF OUR OUTLINE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE HAS SOME ACQUIRE.
INTERESTING COMMENTS YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO BE A HIGHLIGHT.
US.
THE ISSUES ON AGRICULTURE IF IT
WORKS FOR THE CHAIR YES -- IN
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE A FEW OTHER
COMMENTS LATER ON FIVE ONE TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
GOVERNOR -- FOR A VAN SEEN OTHER
PROPOSALS AND I JUST GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE CONCERNS -- THAT I
HAVE IN A SPECIAL WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA.
AN UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO BE THE FOCUS
IS ON RURAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
WHETHER IT'S IN THE VALLEY ON
THE NORTH COAST OF THE NORTH ST.
MAKING SURE THAT.
RULE CLIFORNIA THE SAME
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE
THRIVE IS URBAN.
AND I THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE
THAT INSURING THAT.
SHE SHE REDUCTIONS IN WHATEVER
THAT DATA POINT IS.
NEEDS A GUIDE INVESTMENT.
THEY WERE I HAVE SOME CONCERN.
IS ON THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT REDUCTION
GOING FROM.
A HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL.
TO TWENTY FIVE I THINK
REDUCTIONS FROM DERRY GOING FROM --
NINETY NINE TO TWENTY FIVE AS
WELL AS THE INCENTIVES FOR FOOD
PROCESSORS [inaudible]
SO -- ACCORDING TO BOAST
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL AS
LA -- ANALYSIS.
PROVING THE GREATEST GIGI
REDUCTION FOR ALL FUNDED
PROGRAMS IN THE SECOND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE IS FOCUSING ON
THEORIES AND NOTHING.
SO THERE IS A DEAL THAT WAS
STRUCK ONE SP THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WAS ORIGINALLY PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE SENATOR LARA.
FOCUSING ON METHANE REDUCTION
FOR CALIFORNIA'S DAIRIES.
THERE IS DEEP CONCERN OF
CALIFORNIA'S JERRY COMMUNITY
ABOUT.
THE ADDITIONAL COST BURDEN THAT
THEY MAY HAVE.
AS WE'RE SEEN NO PLATE PRICES
ACROSS THIS NATION FLATTEN AND
OR BE REDUCED [inaudible]
AND THE GOVERNOR AT THE TIME.
ADVANCED.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
BE ABLE TO INVEST TO ASSIST
DAIRIES.
BE ABLE TO HIT THE NEW LAW THAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED.
ABOUT 8% OF OUR TOTAL JG PACKAGE
IN THE STATE A PERSON OF THE
MISSIONS ARE COMING FROM WHEN
YOU WERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW TIMES YOU
CAN EVER USE THAT WORD IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO -- THANK YOU -- SO.
IF ANYONE'S PLAYING BINGO -- SO
HERE'S WHAT I'LL SAY WE'VE HAD.
HUNDREDS OF DERRY FAMILIES.
MADE INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
KNOWING THAT THERE IS GOING TO
BE A FOCUS ON REDUCING REDUCING
METHANE.
EMISSIONS FROM IN YOUR A BILLION
DOLLARS IS CURRENTLY ON THE MOVE
RIGHT NOW ON REDUCING THEIR G.
SHE FOOT PRINT OUT OF THAT
BILLION DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION APPROXIMATE IS
COMING.
UP FROM THE STATE IN PUBLIC
GRANTS REMAINDERS GOING FROM A
IS COMING FROM HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE IN THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY.
AND NOW WE'RE AT THERE IS A
PROPOSAL TO BE A CUT WHAT IS.
IT.
PROVING TO BE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE REDUCTION OF GHGS IN
CALIFORNIA.
UNDER A USE THE EXAMPLE IN THE
NORTH COAST NOW.
RIGHT NOW -- THERE HAVE BEEN
MULTIPLE MEETINGS WITH DAIRY
OWNERS TO BE ABLE TO GET THEM
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
VIA SP. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
TWO YEARS AGO THERE THREE
APPLICATIONS WHEN IT COMES FOR
NEWER MANAGEMENT THIS YEAR THERE
ARE.
EIGHT JUST ON THE NORTH COAST.
MOSTLY SMALL FAMILY FARMERS
THREE HUNDRED HEADER CAL OR LESS.
NOW WHEN IT COMES TO DIGEST
RESEARCH TWELVE APPLICANTS THIS
YEAR FIVE OR SIX TO PREVIOUS.
I SAY ALL THIS IS IF WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT FOCUSING ON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO BE SERIOUS
ABOUT AGRICULTURE.
ON THE NORTH COAST WE HAVE JUST
TAKEN A HUGE HIT BY THE SEVERE
CUT IN THE DUNGEONS CRAB SEASON
THAT USED TO GO FROM NOVEMBER
ALL THE WAY TO JULY.
IN A COURT SETTLEMENT THAT IS
NOT GONNA BE CUT OFF TO APRIL.
AT LEAST ON THE NORTH COAST.
THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC DRIVERS
THAT RULE COASTAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF POVERTY.
WHAT'S LEFT IS A SMALL AMOUNT OF
TIMBER [inaudible]
VERY [inaudible]
IN MARIJUANA.
SO WHAT WE KNOWIS.
AT A LOSS FOR ECONOMIC DRIVERS.
WE ARE SEEN RECORD NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE FARM
CANNABIS FOR YEARS.
UNABLE TO ACHIEVE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROGRAM THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THE A PROP.
SIXTY FOUR NUMBER TWO WERE SEEN
A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
SEASON FOUR ROLE CALIFORNIANS IN
REGARDS TO CRAP. THREE WHEN IT
COMES THE DAIRY WE HAVE TOLD
EVERYONE YOU HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW.
WE PROVIDED THEM INCENTIVES TO
BE ALE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
INVESTING IN DOING THE RIGHT
THING REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND NOW WE'RE ABOUT TO
TAKE IT BACK.
IN EVERYTHING I HEAR FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND RIGHTFULLY
SO WE ARE ABOUT CREATING EQUITY
IN EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE.
SO FOR SERIOUS ABOUT GREEN
EQUITY WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE A HUGE
HIT PEROT CALIFORNIA IF WE'RE
GOING TO YANK THE CARPET.
UNDER FROM UNDERNEATH THESE
DAIRY FARMERS FOR DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
BUT YET CAN'T ACCOMPLISH WITH
INCENTIVE SO I'M IN INDEED THERE
AND I JUST WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE.
TO GET SOME TO SEE IF WE CAN
HAVE SOME DISCUSSION ESPECIALLY
KNOWING THAT IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO BE ABLE -- TO
REDUCE GHGS AND THE THIRD MOST
EFFECTIVE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRICE [inaudible]
FOR TEN MISS.
MORE -- ZOOMING I BELIEVE THAT
ONE OF THE CHARTS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT OUTCOMES THAT
SENATORS REFERRING TO IS THAT.
THE COST PER GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS IN DOLLARS PER METRIC
TON FOR THE DERRY DIGEST IS IS
THAT NINE DOLLARS -- AND THE THE
ALTERNATIVE NEWER MANAGEMENT IS
IT FORTY THREE DOLLARS WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK.
ESSENCE OF HIS.
QUESTION DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT
[inaudible]
RESPONSE.
THERE'S A LOT THERE.
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO GO OVER
ALL OF THE NUMBERS AND AND GET
SOME AMOUNT OF FRAMEWORK MOVING
FORWARD IF WE'RE GOING TO
BABYSIT.
AGAIN ON THE COST OF THE MOST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK -- BUT AGAIN
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING.
AND AS IS HAS DONE IN THE PAST
WE REVIEW ALL OF THE G. P. AS
FAR AS THE AUCTION PROCEEDS.
BEYOND WHAT MAY BE AVAILABLE
WILL BE DOING THAT THROUGH THE
MAY REVISE PROCESS -- AND
ACKNOWLEDGING YOUR POINT I WOULD
NEED TO GET WITH I WOULD NEED TO
HAVE THE CDFA.
HI I WAS A HOME OF THE TWO
PIECES BASED OFF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS.
FROM THE HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT.
THE DERRY DIGESTED PROGRAMS THE
STATE'S MOST EFFECTIVE REDUCTION
WHEN IT COMES A CO.
TWO AND THE THIRD MOST EFFECTIVE
CLIMATE PROGRAM OUT OF THE FORTY
EIGHT THEY'RE CURRENTLY BEING
FUNDED [inaudible]
I'M.
AND IT'S BASED OFF OF THE
FORMULA THAT AT THE CHURCH HE
SAID SO I'M JUST REACTING TO
WHAT IS CURRENTLY WITHIN THE
BUDGET THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING.
IN ALL I'M SAYING I PROMISE ALL
OF STOPPED AND I JUST WANNA TELL
YOU HOW GRATEFUL I AM FOR YOUR
WORK AND THIS IS NOT PERSONAL
WHEN IT COMES TO YOU SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE.
BUT AT ALL -- AND I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THE FRUSTRATION FOR BASING
OUR DECISIONS OFF OF DATA.
AND IT SHOULD BE NEAR THE TOP.
I THINK ANOTHER FOR ANOTHER
PIECE THAT WE LOOK AT AND IT'S
ALSO INCLUDE.
SOMEWHAT IN THE IN THE REPORT.
IS.
LEV USING SOME OF THE THE CAP
AND TRADE PROCEEDS. TO LEVERAGE
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES AS WELL SO
WHILE IT MAY LOOK LIKE IT'S A
REDUCTION OVERALL TO THE PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S WHY I NEED TO GET ALL
OF THE PIECES TOGETHER -- IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY A REDUCTION IT
MAY BE A REDUCTION IN GHG I MEAN.
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
BUT THERE ARE OTHER FUNDS THAT
ARE THAT ARE ALSO SUPPORTING.
THAT. EIGHT IF THAT IS THE CASE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR IT IN JUST
BEING HONEST ABOUT IT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S THE CASE --
AND IT'S THURSDAY BE IT ISN'T IN
EVERY CASE IT ISN'T ON EVERY.
PROGRAM THAT HAS SEEN SOME
REDUCTIONS BUT FOR EXAMPLE THE
SWEET PROGRAM.
DID I MEAN THEY FOUND OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES SO THEY ARE
FULLY FUNDED A SOUGHT APART FROM.
D. G. R. F..
SO AND THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THE
BENEFITS I THINK IN SOME OF OUR
PLANNING.
IS WE START THESE PROGRAMS WITH
THE IDEA THAT.
YOU KNOW WHEN IT ONCE IT GETS
ROLLING AND EVERYBODY ELSE SEES
THE BENEFITS THAN.
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE.
AND I AM PLEASE SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENOUGH
RESPOND THE SECOND MORNING
JUMPED PATRICK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
I'M NOT SURE WHICH
REPRESENTATIVES WE HAVE HERE
TODAY FROM THE DEPARTMENT -- BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION.
THAT OVER THE YEARS A NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS IN APPROPRIATIONS
HAVE BEEN MADE AS YOU WELL KNOW
FOR ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS.
GIVEN THE MULTI YEAR VALIDITY OF
THE DOLLARS AND THE OPERATIONAL
SORT OF CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH WORKING WITH.
DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY FROM
DIFFERENT YEARS AS THEY GET CO
MINGLED IS IS IN SOME CASES.
AN OPERATIONAL CHALLENGE FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO GET ALL OF THE
MONEY OUT THE DOOR PROJECTS ARE
STARTED PROJECTS SOMETIMES ARE
CANCELED UNEXPECTEDLY.
SO -- PART OF THIS DISCUSSION I
THINK IT WOULD BE -- USEFUL TO
KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT WHEN THERE
IS OVERLAP FOR EXAMPLE -- CDFA
RECEIVED A VERY LARGE POT OF
MONEY FOR DEAR DAIRY EFFORTS
LAST YEAR -- AND SO AS IT
RELATES TO HOW MUCH THEY CAN
MANAGE SORT OF A A CASH FLOW
BASIS IF YOU WILL IT I THINK IT
WARRANTS.
JUST TO BE FAIR ABOUT THAT THIS
THIS PROGRAM'S OVERSUBSCRIBED.
SO THERE ARE MORE APPLICATIONS.FOR THE MONEY THEN THERE IS
MONEY ALREADY IT'S AN
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM IN IN
THIS PROGRAM IS ONLY TWO YEARS
OLD.
SO -- IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO THINK.
A COMPLICATED MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE A
TURN ON A DIME IN EVEN GET THE
STRUCTURE IS IMPLEMENTED IN THE
SYSTEMS IMPLEMENTED TO BE AT A
REDUCED THEIR G. SHE'S. TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS.
THIS IS WHEN THE BILL WAS PASSED
SO.
AND THE FACTS ARE THE PROGRAM IS
WAY OVER SUBSCRIBED IN REGARDS
TO THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT
FOLKS ONE IMPLEMENT AND THE
DOLLARS -- THAT ARE AVAILABLE
AND THIS IS BASED OFF OF THE
NINETY NINE MILLION LAST YEAR.
SO -- I WOULD LOVE TO BE A HAVE
A FURTHER CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S OF
GREAT CONCERN.
MYSTERONS BROWN TO ME.
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD.
ALL RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M GONNA HOLD PUBLIC COMMENT
UNTIL AFTER WE GET.
TO THE NEXT ITEM LET'S MOVE ON
TO EACH OF CENTER CENTER STERN I
APOLOGIZE.
I THANK MISTER -- WHAT IT IS SEE
WHAT LA -- INDIO F..
THOUGHT ABOUT A DIFFERENT WAY TO
HANDLE.
THE WAY WE'RE FINDING SORT OF
OUR RESILIENCY WRIT LARGE.
AND SPECIFICALLY -- THE THE
RISKS WE'RE SEEING NOW -- AROUND
WILDFIRE LIABILITY TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS
ARE RELEGATED TO SORT OF TANSIT
AND THOSE ARE LONG TERM.
OPERATIONS OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND YOU KNOW ONE ITEM FOR
CONSIDERATION FOR THE FUTURE IS.
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN.
I'D SAY GENEROUS AND AND
APPROPRIATELY SO WITH OUR
SPENDING AROUND -- FIRED -- BOTH
THEIR RISK MITIGATION AS WELL AS
SOME SUPPRESSION EFFORTS BUT
ESPECIALLY ON THE MITIGATE ON ON
THE RISK MITIGATION SIDE.
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF
WE SENT A SIGNAL.
OUT TO THE MARKETS THAT
CALIFORNIA WAS COMMITTED ON A
LONG TERM BASIS THE PUTTING.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IF NOT
BILLIONS OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
INVESTED DIRECTLY AND RESILIENCY
IN REDUCING WILD.
RISK HOW THAT MIGHT MAKE OUR
STATES OF FISCAL ARRANGEMENT
ESPECIALLY ON THE UTILITY SIDE.
WHAT IT ACTUALLY MIGHT DO TO BUY
DOWN SOME OF THAT RISK FROM?
NOT FROM A RATE BASE BUT FROM IN
SOME WAYS.
THE ORIGINAL COST CAUSATION
WHICH IS OUR CARBON POLLUTION
RIGHT I MEAN THE ORIGINAL THE
THE THE THOSE PAYING HERE.
IF YOU LOOK ATTHE OUR PRIMARY
MISSIONS OF THE PETROLEUM SIDE
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
BASICALLY BOUNCE THE ENTIRE
BURDEN OF CLIMATE.
ON THE UTILITY SECTOR SORT OF
WITHIN THAT SILO BUT I THINK
THERE'S A SORT OF HEALTHY
ARGUMENT TO BE HAD -- FOR TRYING
TO FIND SOME OTHER WAY NOT
NECESSARILY DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE RATE PAYER APPROPRIATE TYPE
FUNDING THAT REALLY SHOULDN'T BE
IN THIS SPOT BUT IF YOU GO
BEYOND THE LINE.
ARE YOU GO BEYOND THAT SORT OF
BASIC HARDENING AND YOU SORT OF
START TO ZOOM OUT A LITTLE MORE
WHAT'S GOING TO ACTUALLY MAKE
THIS STATE SURVIVABLE.
IN THE NEXT DECADE IT'S GONNA
TAKE A VARIETY OF THINGS THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY IN SAY THE
NINE OH ONE MITIGATION --
WILDFIRE PLANS.
SO I SAID I WANTED TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON ON THAT THAT CONCEPT AND
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE TODAY.
BUT IS THAT.
IS THE IS THERE IS THERE
EFFICACY TO THIS STRATEGY IS
SORT OF THINKING ABOUT THIS IN A
LONGER TERM WAY RIGHT AS OPPOSED
TO AN ANNUAL OKAY THIS YEAR WE
WE CARE ABOUT FIRE OKAY NEXT
YEAR.
WE DON'T KNOW WE CARE ABOUT
CLIMATE RISK I MEAN I I DON'T
WANT TO JUST RELEGATED AGAIN TO
FIRE RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE
VULNERABLE BOTH ON SEALEVEL RISE
WERE VULNERABLE ON ON FLOODS
THERE'S A LOT OF COSTS.
THEY WERE FACING -- BETWEEN NOW
AND SAY ARE TWENTY THIRTY GOALS
SO JUST A A BRIEF THAT TAKE ON
THAT IF YOU HAVE ONE EITHER LA
OR DEAL WITH AND NOT.
IT WOULD HELP WAS WRITTEN THERE.
YOU CAN JUMP INTO THE AREA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
THE POINT THAT YOU'RE TAKING IS
VERY WELL RECEIVED AND WE OF
COURSE DO YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THESE.
EXPENDITURES IN A LONG TERM WAY
SO NO NOT NECESSARILY ANY
IMMEDIATE REACTIONS TO YOUR
COMMENT BUT YEAH I MEAN I THINK
IT'S A A BIG AND IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND I DON'T HAVE ANY SO.
I DON'T THINK GREAT ANSWERS AT
THIS POINT -- WELL I MEAN ONE
THOUGHT THAT COMES TO MIND IS --
YOU KNOW IT PART OF THE STRUGGLE
I THINK IT'S KIND OF THINKING
THROUGH AGAIN KINDA KNOW WHAT
THE THE ROLE OF SORTS STATE
FUNDING IS FOR SOME OF THESE
ACTIVITIES AND ALSO SORT OF
TRYING TO AND MAINTAIN SORT OF
INCENTIVES FOR OTHER ACTORS
PRIVATE PARTIES ARE OTHER ACTORS.
MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW ALL
THE ALL THE ACTORS THAT HAVE
SORT OF A AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE THE MAGNITUDE OF THAT
RISK GOING FORWARD CAN CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE INSURGENTS ARE
TRYING TO IN SOME CASES IT.
CERTAINLY WILL BE SORT OF THAT
YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY STATE ROLE
FOR THAT IN OTHER CASES YOU
MAYBE NOT THOSE ARE SORT OF
TRYING TO THINK THROUGH KIND OF
HOW THE STATE RESOURCES CAN BE
TARGETED. TO TO TO REDUCE THAT
RISK BUT ALSO SORT OF MAINTAIN
THOSE SIGNALS AND SO -- THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE LIKE I THINK TO
SOME HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS BUT
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE WILL
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT.
CLOSE ISSUE NUMBER ONE ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS HAS TO LEAVE SO
BEFORE WE GET TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO I WOULD LIKE TO GO BACK TO
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR -- OUR
FIRST FOR YOURSELF MISTER CORN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY HERE JONES REQUIRE
[inaudible]
MONEY.
OKAY CORE MISSTEP WHICH WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- LET'S SEE.
BOTH ONLY.
YEAH OF A MOTION ON PART B.
AGENDA ITEMS. 1-345-789-1114.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IS THERE A
MOTION.
THE CENTER JONES HAS A MOTION ON
PART B. ISSUES 1-345-789-1114
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
I CAN SKI.
HI JONES [inaudible]
MY CHOIR.
MINING NINE STERN.
GIVE A SECOND MOTION ON PART B.
OF OUR GENDER DISOBEDIENCE USED
TO SIX TEN TWELVE AND THIRTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN THERE'S A MOTION.
BY CENTER MINING THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CASKEY HI
JONES.
REQUIRE.
MONEY STERN HI.
NOW WITH US.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S CALL ISSUE
NUMBER TWO THIS IS THE WORK
FORCE -- DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAININGAPPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
AND THEIR EXPENDITURES.
MISTER CHAIR THIS IF I MAY --
I'VE GOT -- DISTRICT
RESPONSIBILITIES THIS AFTERNOON
SO I MAY NOT BE ABLE TO STAY FOR
THE ENTIRE PRESENTATION OF THIS --
BECAUSE I MAKE A MOTION -- NO I
THINK GIVEN THE FACT IF YOU YOU
HAVE TO LEAVE -- I KNOW WE HAVE
A STAFF RECOMMENDATION WILL
PROBABLY JUST HOLD THE MATTER
OPEN OKAY I LOVE IT THAT'S
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES
YOU HAVE OUTSIDE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
SENATOR WHY CASKEY OF MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY NAME IS TIM RAINY I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD.
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE ITEM.
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS WE NEED THE WORKERS TO DO
IT.
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS ARE TRANSFORMING THE
ECONOMY IN A TRANSFORMING
ECONOMY WE NEED TO TRANSFORM THE
WORK FORCE TO DO THIS.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT EQUITY --
INTO ACHIEVE ACCURATE EQUITY WE
QUALITY.
A CLEAN GREEN ECONOMY THAT LIFTS
ALL BOATS -- WON'T HAPPEN
ACCIDENTALLY THE CITY CALIFORNIA
MUST BE DELIVERED ABOUT THAT.
CALIFORNIA ALONE AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE -- WILL NOT.
IN CLIMATE CHANGE -- BUT WE ARE
A MODEL TO SHOW THE WAY -- AND I
THINK WE ARE SHOWING NOT JUST
THE COUNTRY THE WAY BUT BUT
INTERNATIONALLY CALIFORNIA IS IS
CHARTING THE COURSE TOWARD A
CLEAN GREEN ECONOMY.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF GREAT MODELS
OF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS CORE TO OUR
EQUITY CLIMATE IN JOBS WORK.
THEY'RE NOT HUGE PROJECTS OR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS --
COMPARED TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
BUT WE THINK THEY SHOW THE WAY
THE GREAT MODELS.
THE FIRST ONE IS CALLED HIERO
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS WE'RE IN
THE THIRD YEAR -- WITH EIGHT
PARTNERSHIPS AROUND THE STATE.
WE'RE WORKING IN TRANSIT
HEALTHCARE BUILDING MAINTENANCE
HOSPITALITY WATER WAREHOUSING
PORTS AND OTHERS WE TRAINED OVER
A THOUSAND WORKERS OVER THE
PERIOD OF TIME IN THIS
DEMONSTRATION GRANT.
IN ALL THE PROJECTS WORKERS ARE
AT THE TABLE WITH MANAGEMENT --
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO CO DESIGN
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS MAP
OCCUPATIONAL CHANGE DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
DUE TO THE INTRODUCTION OF
TECHNOLOGY IN GENERAL INDUSTRY
CHANGING IN TRANSITION.
IN ALL CASES ARE WE'RE
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORK FORCE
AGENCIES AND SCHOOLS AND THE
FOCUS IS ON EQUITY AND DIVERSITY
AND IMPROVING EQUITY AND AND AND
DIVERSITY.
AND MOVING PEOPLE UP -- AND
MOVIE NEW PEOPLE IN AT THE ENTRY
LEVEL.
THE SECOND ONE IS CALLED HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CAREERS.
WE STARTED THIS WORK WITH PROP
THIRTY NINE FUNDING A LITTLE
WHILE AGO THE CLEAN ENERGY JOBS
ACT. TO CREATE ACCESS TO STATE
APPROVED CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP THROUGH MULTI
CRAFT PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PARTNERSHIPS -- USING A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED MC THREE
CURRICULUM MULTI CRAFT CORE
CURRICULUM.
OVER THE LAST FORTY FIVE YEARS.
WE'VE INVESTED IN BUILDING
TWELVE PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE
STATE WE INTEND.
TO EXPAND THAT TO FOURTEEN ONE
IN EVERY EACH OF THE FOURTEEN
REGIONS AND I CAN TALK ABOUT HOW
WE DEFINE REGIONS IN THE STATE.
THEIR PARTNERSHIPS OF LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS --
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WORK FOR SPORTS SCHOOLS.
THAT WE SERVE.
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE AN AVERAGE 80%
COMPLETION RATE IN THOSE
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
SOME PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE
AMONG THOSE TWELVE HAVE HAVE A
90% NORTH OF 90% COMPLETION RATE
WHICH IS GREAT -- FROM A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PERSON
PERSPECTIVE -- THOSE ARE AN
INCREDIBLE NUMBERS ESPECIALLY
FOR THE POPULATIONS THAT WE'RE
SERVING.
THE WE HAVE AN AVERAGE 70%
PLACEMENT RATE WHICH IS ALSO
INCREDIBLY GOOD FOR THIS HE'S
POPULATIONS.
WITH AROUND HALF OF THOSE FOLKS
BEING PLACED.
AS APPRENTICES -- AS YOU KNOW.
TO BE A COMMON APPRENTICE IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO GET IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS PREPARING PEOPLE
GIVING THEM THE WHERE WITH ALL.
TO BE COMPETITIVE AND THEN
FINALLY LAND AS IN PRINTED SO AS
THESE GUYS THIS.
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT GOES WE'LL
SEE MORE AND MORE PEOPLE BECOME
THE PRINCES AS THE WORK BECOMES
AVAILABLE.
WITH THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU --
OUR INTENTION IS TO SCALE UP
EXISTING PROJECTS -- THE
DEMONSTRATION WORK AND THEY
TRANSFER THE MODEL STATEWIDE
INCLUDING TO OTHER SECTORS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN SCOPING PLAN.
AND IT'S THE IT'S THE SAME THREE
THREE PARTS.
NUMBER ONE THE HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS OUR
INTENTION IS TO EXPAND THE
CAPACITY IS A SAID TO FOURTEEN
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS IT'S TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR FOR
FIVE YEARS FROM THE G. G. R. F..
WE PLAN -- TO SERVE THREE
THOUSAND DIS ADVANTAGE WORKERS
THIS IS THE EQUITY WORK WE'RE
DOING -- THAT WILL BE PREPARED
FOR STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THOSE COSTS INCLUDE A LOT OF
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR THESE
POPULATIONS BECAUSE AGAIN
THEY'RE FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- INCLUDING
RECRUITMENT WORK COUNSELLING
MENTORING -- ALL KINDS OF
SUPPORT INCLUDING STATEMENTS
BECAUSE PEOPLE NEED MONEY IN
THEIR POCKET IN ORDER TO BE
GOING THROUGH TRAINING -- THE MC
THREE TRAINING ITSELF PLACEMENT
RETRENCHED RETENTION TRACKING
THE WHOLE NINE YARDS -- THE NEXT
ONE IS THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS -- BUILDING ON THAT --
THOSE THAT DEMONSTRATION WORK
WE'RE GONNA EXPAND FROM THE
CURRENT EIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHT
PROJECTS STATEWIDE -- AND CLIMB
IT IMPACTED INDUSTRIES.
WE PLAN TO SERVER -- TWO
THOUSAND DISADVANTAGE WORKERS.
AND TWENTY EIGHT HI RETURNING
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT WILL BE INVESTING IN DEEP
WORK THAT'LL BE SUSTAINED LONG
TERM.
AGAIN THE COSTS ARE -- BUILDING
THE PARTNERSHIPS AMONG WORKERS
AND MANAGEMENT LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT -- BRINGING COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATION SCHOOLS WORK
FORCE BOARDS TO HELP PEOPLE MOVE
IN AT THE FRONT END -- ENTRY
LEVEL JOBS -- IT INCLUDES DEEP
SECTOR ASSESSMENT IN EVERY CASE
PLANNING DEVELOPMENT ON THE
FRONT END -- WE DO THE SAME
RECRUITMENT COUNSELLING
MENTORING -- SUPPORTS LIKE
STIPENDS -- PLACEMENT RETENTION
TRACKING EVERYTHING TO PROVIDE
THOSE -- THOSE GENEROUS
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
SO THEY CAN SUCCEED BOTH IN THE
TRAINING BUT ALSO AS EMPLOYEES --
IN THESE GREAT MIDDLE CLASS JOBS.
THERE'S A THIRD BID WHICH IS NEW
FOR US.
THE OTHER TWO ARE TRYING TRUE WE
HAVE A GREAT DAY TO THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT IS GOOD WORK
IT'S EFFECTIVE.
WE WANT TO BUILD ON THAT THE
WORKER TRANSITION FIND IS A NEW
CONCEPT.
IN CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR FOR
QUITE A LONG TIME THERE'S A PRO
A NATIONAL PROGRAM CALLED --
TRADE ACT ASSISTANCE.
IT'S WHEN A COMPANY UP AND
LEAVES AND CAUSES THE MASS
CLOSURE AND IF THE COMPANY'S
GOING OFF SHORE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- STATE APPLIES FOR
THE FUNDS WILL PROVIDE REALLY
GREAT TRANSITION ASSISTANCE TO
THOSE WORKERS IT'S HARD MONEY TO
GET.
NOT EVERY EVENT QUALIFIES THE
INTENTION HERE IS TO HAVE A
TRANSITION FUND -- IN SECTORS
THAT A CLIMATE IMPACTED.
SO THAT WE CAN HELP WORKERS
TRANSITION.
THOSE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY BY
THAT CHANGE AND AGAIN IT'S IT'S
A IT'S A SUITE OF WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO HELP THOSE THOSE
WORKERS WHO COULD BE EXTENSION
OF COBRA.
AS THEY DON'T LOSE YOUR HEALTH
INSURANCE IT COULD BE -- EARLY
RETIREMENT -- ALL KINDS OF
INNOVATIVE THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE SO THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST
TAKING MONEY OUT OF COMMUNITY
PEOPLE STILL HAVE MONEY IN THEIR
POCKETS THEY CAN GO THROUGH
TRAINING -- AND HELPS TO SUPPORT
THAT THE THE WHOLE COMMUNITY
THROUGH A TRANSITION THAT'S THE
WORKER -- TRANSITION FUND --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
ELLIE OUT DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT
THE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL BEFORE US.
YEAH SO JUST DONE A COUPLE OF
NOTES SOME -- JUST HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE THINGS THAT ARE IN YOUR
AGENDA AS WELL -- THE THE
PROPOSAL HERE.
REALLY HAS KIND OF A FOCUS AS AS
WAS MENTIONED ON KIND OF CAREERS
AND UNLIKE A LOT OF THE OTHER --
FUNDING PROGRAMS FROM THE G. R.
OUT THAT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON KIND OF PROJECTS THAT
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SO I MEAN WE THINK THAT JUST
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION AS YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW TO PRIORITIZE
THIS.
MONEY TO THOSE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES.
WE DO THINK THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANNA
THINK ABOUT ASKING JUST SOME
MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
SOME OF THE PARTICULAR PROPOSALS
I THINK ON THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS A CERTIFICATE EXPANSION
OF EXISTING PROGRAMS -- IN
PARTICULAR -- YOU KNOW HOW THE
DEPARTMENT PLANS ON KIND OF
SCALE IN THOSE OUT THAT SO IN
SOME CASES A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION OF OF KIND OF AN
EXISTING -- PROGRAM AND SO HOW
THEY WILL SCALE IT UP AND I'LL
STOP HERE IF I THINK IT AND I
THINK IT'S A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM SKEWS ME I'M SORRY
BECAUSE THERE WERE IF IT WERE AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM ONE WOULD
THINK THAT THAT.
INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE OUT THERE
DOING SOME POTENTIALLY DOING
SOME GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
THIS IS A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM THAT IS.
BEFORE US IS A GUN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS FUN.
MY APOLOGIES MISS NO NO I JUST I
pTHAT SAID ANOTHER STEP REMOVED
ALTHOUGH WE'VE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
THEM AND AND TWO FORMER TRIED
AND TRUE.
BUT BUT THIS IS ANOTHER STEP
REMOVED.
YES YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS A
A PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
WHICH IS -- BEFORE OBVIOUSLY SO --
I THINK ON THE WORKER TRANSITION
PILOT PROGRAM -- WHICH WAS THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY --
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS -- THIS
IS UNLIKE THE OTHER ONES IS A
NEW PROGRAM -- FOR THE FIRST
COUPLE YEARS OUR OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT -- THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WOULD FIND
KIND OF A MESS A STUDY AND
ASSESSMENT OF POTENTIAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND SO ONE IMPORTANT QUESTION IS.
WE THINK IS IS WHETHER OR NOT
SORT OF THE THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO COMMIT TO FIVE YEARS
FONT OF FUNDING FOR THIS OR
WHETHER OR NOT IT MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ALLOCATING.
MONEY FOR THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS AND MAYBE EVEN A
POTENTIALLY A LOWER AMOUNT
DEPENDING ON THE COST OF JUST
THAT STUDY MEN COME BACK ONCE
THE RESULTS OF THAT STUDY AN
ASSESSMENT AND EVALUATE -- WHAT
THE ON GOING NEEDS FOR SUCH A
PILOT MIGHT BE -- AND SELL OUT A
WITH MY COMMENTS AT THAT. NINE I
KNOW THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT.
MAY BE THREE NINE EIGHT WHICH
INCLUDED LANGUAGE ABOUT.
REIGNING DOESN'T BECOME LIVE
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OR AT LEAST FOR THE
AUCTIONS THE PROCEEDS OF THE MEN.
SO ARE IS THE CAP IS A
SUBCOMMITTEE MISDIRECTED IF
THEY'RE STINGY ABOUT SPENDING
MONEY THAT HAS A DIRECT NEXUS
BETWEEN GREENHOUSE GASES AT
LEAST WHAT WE'RE STILL IN AN A.
B. -- THIRTY TWO ARENA I MEAN I
WOULD UNDERSTAND IF IF THIS IF
THIS PROPOSAL WAS COMING BEFORE
US NEXT YEAR WELL WE KNEW TWO
OPTIONS WERE CLEARLY GOING TO BE
IN.
THERE AB THREE NINE EIGHT N.
THREE OUT AND TWO OPTIONS GOING
TO BE IN A AB THREE THIRTY TWO
THEN YOU KNOW WE CAN DO THE MATH
ON THAT.
I MEAN I THINK THAT THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF UNCERTAINTY
AROUND KIND OF AROUND THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE I MEAN IT'S
DEFINITELY -- WORTH CONSIDERING
AND KIND OF CONSIDERING THAT
POTENTIAL LEGAL RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH SPENDING ON THINGS THAT
DON'T HAVE THAT CLEAR DIRECT
GREENHOUSE GAS.
TIE -- THERE'S A VARIETY OF OF
CONSIDERATIONS AROUND KINDA YOU
KNOW THE ALLOWANCES FUTURE
ALLOWANCES THAT ARE SOLD IN WHAT
RESTRICTIONS MIGHT BE ON THOSE A
LOT THOSE KIND OF POST TWENTY
TWENTY ALLOWANCES THAT ALREADY
PART OF THE OPTIONS BUT
CERTAINLY SORT OF THINKING ABOUT.
WHATEVER LEGAL RESTRICTIONS
MIGHT BE ON THESE FUNDS IS IS IS
ONE IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION ARE
WE START WE STILL SUIT.
THAT LED LITIGATION NEVER GOT
DISMISSED WHEN WE PASSED THREE
NINE EIGHT DID IT.
WE SORT OF I THINK WE'RE STILL
BEING SUED FOR THE USE OF FUNDS
THAT HAVE THE NEXUS.
I DON'T REMEMBER I REMEMBER THAT
CASE BEING DISMISSED ON THE WHAT
THE STATUS OF IT IS.
BUT I'M I'M I I GUESS I IT WELL
IT WOULD MAYBE DEPEND ON HE
PARTICULAR CASE I MEAN I KNOW
THAT THE CASE AROUND KIND OF
WHETHER OR NOT CAPTAIN TRADE
REFLECTS A YOU KNOW REFLECTS A
TAX OR SOME OTHER CHARGE THAT
WAS.
RESOLVED -- I I'M NOT FAMILIAR
TO MAYBE ANOTHER CASE OUT THERE
AROUND TO A PARTICULAR TYPE OF%
SPENDING THAT I'D HAVE TO KNOW
THE DETAILS.
FINANCE -- THE THE ONE STEP
REMOVED THESE ARE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO
EXISTING ONE KNEW THAT ARE
REMOVED FROM THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM CAN YOU HELP ME WITH THE
NEXUS BETWEEN GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS.
A PRE.
AB THREE NINE EIGHT ERA AND
WHICH IS BEFORE US.
SURE SENATOR DANIEL BRANDON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE PROPOSAL
IS CONSISTENT WITH A B. THREE
NINETY EIGHT AND VERY TIMELY
GIVEN THE NEED FOR THESE TYPES
OF JOBS IN THE CHANGING ECONOMY --
AND IT BEGINS TO ADDRESS THE
NEED FOR THE INCREASED JOB
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT -- TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY TO TRANSITION INTO.
THE REDUCED EMISSIONS COMIC
THAT'S TRUE BUT THREE NINE EIGHT
DOESN'T ONLY.
THE AB THIRTY TWO ENDS IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY AB
THREE NINE EIGHT STARTS IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE I'M
HERE IN MRCH OF NINETEEN OF
TWENTY NINETEEN SO YOU'RE ASKING.
THIS COMMITTEE TO USE FUNDS FROM
AUCTIONS AND SOME OF THEM MAY
HAVE BEEN LAST YEAR'S AUCTIONS
OR TWENTY SIXTEEN MONEY WHICH
CLEARLY HAS TO SHOW A NEXUS.
AND YOU'RE POINTING TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND SAYING BUT IT
WILL BE LEGAL DURING THAT TIME.
THAT'S THE QUESTION NOT THAT IT
IS I GET DID IT FALL I FART READ
THREE NINE EIGHT AND I GET THAT
IF I WAS SITTING HERE A YEAR
FROM NOW THIS WOULD BE AN EASIER
QUESTION.
BUT WE HAVE LOTS OF COMPETING.
PROJECTS HERE IN AT LEAST I WANT
TO MEET THE MINIMUM LEVEL LEGAL
THRESHOLD THAT THERE'S A NEXUS.
SO I UNDERSTAND IT HIS THREE
NINE FIVE I'M ASKING YOU VISITED
A B..
THIRTY TWO I THINK THE ANSWER IS
NO.
I MEAN IF IF IT WAS AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM A
PROBABLY WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER.
BUT IT'S A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE DILEMMA WE HAVE.
OKAY JUST MAKE A QUICK COMMENT.
THE THE PRECONSTRUCTION TRAINING
PROGRAMS ARE DYINGIN ALIGNMENT
CLOSE ALIGNMENT WITH THE LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS AND THE
JOINT APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
COMMITTEES THEMSELVES SO WHILE
WE'RE DOING PRE APPRENTICESHIP
WORK.
THE CHANCES OF OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS HE'S PARTICIPANTS TO
LAND IN A PARTNERSHIP SLOTS IS
VERY VERY HIGH IN FACT WE'VE HAD
GREAT -- THE EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT SO AS WE GET MORE WORK --
THAT IS PULLING CARBON IN THE
ATMOSPHERE THERE'S A DEMAND FOR
NEW APPRENTICES AND WE'RE
FILLING THAT DEMAND IN CAHOOTS
WITH MIDNIGHT I PRESUME THAT
THAT'S TRUE THE QUESTION IS IS
THAT WE HAVE A LIMITED USE OF
THE FUNDS THERE BE BETTER.
THAT RAN THE BANK RIGHT NOW IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS WE GOT MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT THE LIMITED
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE THAT THAT MAY
BE TRUE AND THEY MAY GO OUT AND
WORK ON ANAEROBIC DIGESTERS ARE
HEALTHY SOILS OR WHAT.
IT'S ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS IS
GIVE US GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS IN SOME CO BENEFITS
RIGHT BUT TODAY.
THEY DON'T.
CENTER MONEY YOUR QUESTION
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
YES I WILL TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
JUST PICKING UP ON WHAT YOU
SUGGESTED.
THE DILEMMA IS YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO GET INTO THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
PRE APPRENTICE TRAINING SO IT'S
KIND OF A CATCH TWENTY TWO WE
WANT TO HAVE THE POSITIVE
IMPACTS IN TERMS OF THE WORK
THAT'S DESIGNED.
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA.
MEET THAT GOAL IF WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
PREPARED TO MOVE INTO THE
APPRENTICE PROGRAM.
SO. ONE COULD ARGUE THERE IS A
NEXUS BUT IT'S NOT AN IMMEDIATE.
COST BENEFIT OF THE DOLLAR BEING
SPENT IS WHAT I HEAR YOU
SUGGESTING OR IT COULD BE A
DIFFERENT PROPOSAL.
THAT THAT THE FUNDS FOR THIS
YEAR'S FUNDING ON THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WOULD
COME FROM SOME OTHER SOURCE WITH
THE IDEA THAT THE COMMITTEE THAT
THAT HOPE WE SAT.
NEXT YEAR IN THE FOLLOWING YEARS
THEY WERE COME FROM GREENHOUSE
GASES WHEN WE WERE UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF THREE NINE EIGHT
JUICE I CAN'T.
MAMA COMMA SENATOR IF YOU DON'T
MIND.
IT AND I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE
THAT THE NEXUS QUESTION.
BUT JUST TO CLARIFY THE WORK
THAT WE'RE INVESTING IN.
ANOTHER PROJECT TO CURRENT I
RETURNING PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
HAVE IS IN TRANSIT IN SEVERAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES AROUND --
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY
BUILDING TO OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES.
IT WAS JUST TALKING TO THE HEAD
OF AC TRANSIT THE OTHER DAY MY
KERSH.
THEY ARE BRINGING IN AS REQUIRED
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES BUSES.
AND THE MAINTENANCE WORKERS --
ON THOSE BUSES IN THE MECHANICS
AND THE OPERATORS ALL HAVE TO BE
RETRAINED FOR ZERO EMISSION
BUSES.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THIS WORK FORCE
TO DO THAT AND WE CO INVEST WITH
THESE TRANSIT AGENCIES TO TOUGH
TO TRAIN THESE WORKERS.
THEY WERE GONNA HAVE FLEETS
THERE SITTING IDLE -- SO THERE'S
IT'S NOT JUST THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP IN THE
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR WORKING WITH
OTHER SECTORS THAT ARE THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO PULLING KARMA
ATMOSPHERE AND 5% OF THE FUNDS
THAT WE RAISE FROM EACH OPTION
THE GREENHOUSE GAS SINCE GASES.
HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED AS ALONG
WITH THE HIGH SEED RAIL AND
WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO IF
THEY WANT TO GET THE MONEY OUT
OF THAT POT.
THAT'S THEIR BUSINESS WE'VE
WE'VE ALLOCATED THAT MONEY
THEY'RE ASKING FOR THE
DISCRETIONARY POT TO BRING A NEW
PROGRAM. FOR SOMETHING THAT
CHALLENGES THE NEXUS AND THE
CHILD AND THAT'S THAT'S MY ROLE
HERE AND THAT'S THE ROLE THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WE WE SPEND MONEY BUT WE
SPEND IT.
IS WORLD LEGALLY ALLOWED TO SO.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
REJECT WITHOUT PREJUDICE WHAT
I'M PROPOSING IS THAT WE JUST
HOLD IT OPEN.
AS WELL AS ISSUE NUMBER ONE HERE
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS IS AN
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THESE ARE OUR CAP AND TRADE --
EXPENDITURE PLAN IN THAT WORK.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
PLEASE PROCEED.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL YODER
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT. TWENTY OF THE
THIRTY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-IN CALIFORNIA ARE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO ON BEHALF OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THIS
CAP AND TRADE ALLOCATION IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET HAVE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO REPLACE AG.
MACHINES AND FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM THOSE ARE
THE TWO PROGRAMS WE THINK WILL
HELP CLEAN NEAR THE MOST IN THE
IN THE SOONEST IN THE VALLEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SNACKS THAT IS ALL BE
ONA BEEHIVE OF THE ALLMAN LANCE
CALL FOR GRAIN FEED ASSORTMENT
OF AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES.
I LOVE THE GREEN WITH THE AIR
DISTRICTS WE SUPPORT THE FARMER
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD BE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT.
THAT CENTER MCGUIRE TALKS OF
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT.
SECOND THING IS A DERRY JUDGE
JESTER PROGRAM WE ALSO.
BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD BE
INCREASED -- AS IT IS FULLY
SUBSCRIBED IN AGAIN AND
ADDITIONALLY.
THEN THIS THIS WON'T COST ANY
MONEY A WASTE DIVERSION SECTION
WE WOULD LIKE -- TO AND
ENCOURAGE THAT OR FOR ORGANICS --
WASTE.
THAT BE OPENED UP TO ALL
TECHNOLOGIES RIGHT NOW CAL
RECYCLES FOCUSED THERE'S ON TO
PRIMARILY TO TUT TECHNOLOGIES
YET TO MEET THE GOALS.
THAT THE STATE HAS IDENTIFIED
FOR ORGANICS WILL REQUIRE ALL
TECHNOLOGIES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE WILL BE TRAILER THAT THERE
NEED TO BE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE BALL
REQUIRE THAT THEY EVALUATE ALL
TECHNOLOGIES BASED ON THEIR BAR
MIDDLE FOOT PRINT AND GIGI
FOOTPRINT.
AND THEN FIND ALL THE
APPROPRIATE ONES AS AS REQUIRED
THANK YOU.
THIS FORUM THAT OTHERS IN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL BE -- TAKING THE LA OWES
ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE AUCTION
PROCEEDS ARE GOING TO BE SO WILL
BE HIGHER THAN WHAT WE WE WILL
REPORT OUT AN EXPENDITURE PAM
BASED ON WHAT THE LA THOSE
NUMBERS ARE -- AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY.
IF SOMETHING'S ALREADY BEES BEEN
SAID YOU DON'T NEED TO REPEAT
THE SAME THING JUST LET US KNOW
THAT YOU AGREE WITH WHAT'S BEEN
SAID PLEASE NECKS GOOD MORNING
CARA ROSS ON BEHALF OF SUCH
STOCKTON MAYOR MICHAEL TUBS ON
THE ON THE TRANSFORMATIONAL
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WE'D
LIKE TO SEE.
THE FULL HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM
I THINK IT'S A STRONG ONE AND
WE'VE DONE GOOD THINGS AND WE
THINK MORE COULD BE DONE.
THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERG WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PARTNERSHIP IN TRAINING PROPOSAL
WE'VE SEEN.
SUCCESS STORIES IN OUR OWN UNION
THROUGH -- OUR ALLIED HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND JANITORS AND
WERE.
REALLY HAPPY THAT YOU'RE
CHOOSING NOT TO REJECT AND SO IF
YOU WILL KEEP IT UP AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO HELP.
YOU WORK OUT ANY KINGS AND MAKE
THIS WORK BECAUSE WE SEE IT
HELPED GET MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RYAN KENNEY CLEAN
ENERGY I JUST A COUPLE THINGS ON
BOTH -- LOW KNOCKS VEHICLES AND
BIO FUELS -- WE DO BELIEVE --
FUNDING SHOULD BE A REFLECTIVE
OF THE ALLEY A REPORT THAT
SHOWED THAT -- TRANSPORTATION
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS HAVE
INCREASED AND THAT DOES HAVE
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN -- THE
LEAST COST EFFECTIVE BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU LOOKING FOR
IMMEDIATE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS WITH CO BENEFITS SUCH
AS NAS REDUCTIONS.
THAT -- INVESTMENT SHOULD BE
MADE FOR LOW KNOCKS VEHICLES.
WITH A HEALTHY INCREMENTAL --
VALVES FOR AMOUNT TO COVER THE
THE COST -- ALSO FOR BIOFUELS --
WE DO BELIEVE PRODUCTION IN ST
PRODUCTION -- ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
TAKE PLACE AND THAT A SIZABLE
AMOUNT SHOULD BE I THE ALLOCATED
FOR BOB I'LL FEEL PRIME
PRODUCTION THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JOE CY YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES COALITION FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY RYAN
KENNY.
AND CLEAN ENERGY ALSO -- I'D
LIKE TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR CAL RECYCLES
ORGANICS DIVERSION PROGRAM. TO
ONE HUNDRED MILLION -- WE
BELIEVE THE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED THAT REDUCE SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE PRODUCE POLLUTANTS
WE ALSO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ALLOCATE 10220% OF THE S. B. --
NINE OH ONE FORCED TO FUNDING TO
BIO ENERGY FACILITIES THAT CAN
PUT FORD'S FOREST BIOMASS TO
BENEFICIAL USE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LAURA
MEDINA AND I WORK FOR BUILDING
SCHOOLS PARTNERSHIP FOR
NONPROFIT COLLABORATION BETWEEN
RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES IN THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY AS WELL AS
SEIU U. S. W. W..
AND WE SERVICE -- PROPERTY
SERVICE WORKERS WHO SERVICE
BUILDINGS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE RECEIVED
FUNDING FROM.
THE H. R. T. P. AND WE'RE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
CLIMENT EQUITY IN JOBS BECAUSE
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE.
TO BROKER CONVERSATIONS WITHIN
THE JANITORIAL AS INDUSTRY FOR
THE FIRST TIME TO TALK ABOUT THE
JANITORIAL WORKERS AS KEY
PLAYERS.
IN THE SUSTAINABILITY PROCESS
SEES OF COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO TALK TO JANITORIAL
CONTRACTORS THEIR CLIENTS FOR
THE PROPERTY OWNERS AND MANAGERS
OF THOSE BUILDINGS TO BE ABLE.
TO TALK ABOUT -- UPSCALING
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
INDUSTRY FOR MANY YEARS AND TO
TALK ABOUT ALSO OTHER
CERTIFICATIONS APPRENTICESHIPS
AND PROGRAMS THAT'LL HELP IN THE
CAR OUR CLIMATE AND EQUITY.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ONE OF
OUR WORKERS WHO HAS BENEFITED
FROM THE H. R. TWO P. PROGRAM.
THAT WE RECENTLY EXPANDED HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
MORNING MY NAME IS THAT WE KEEP
THEM ON THE NOVEL AND I
MENTIONED IT TO THE SACRAMENTAL
I'M.
I WORK IN THE INDUSTRY FOR MORE
THROUGH THE YEARS.
I WORE FOR ABLE TO MENACE
COMPANY.
AND FOUR HUNDRED CAPITOL MORNING
AND NIGHT AND KYLIE PA BEFORE OF
THESE.
AND I'M IN I AM A MEMBER OF YES
YEAH YOU AND I I PARTICIPATE.
AND NOT THE GREEN AND WAS SO
THEN AND OKAY SOME PROGRAM AND
THAT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
SAYS THE NEW DVD AND WORK.
ALSO I THINK A ENGLISH CLASSES
AND I SUPPORT THE THING IS AT
THE END.
BECAUSE I RECEIVED A OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MY JOB.
SO THE RETRAINING AND I HOPE ALL
THE MEMBERS OF MY UNION ALSO HIM
THAT THESE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MAX.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRENDAN
TELLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION -- AS YOU
KNOW AIR DISTRICTS HAVE A
CENTRAL ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING AB
SIX SEVENTEEN A AMBITIOUS AND
IMPORTANT.
NEW PROGRAM TO GET SIGNIFICANT
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES -- IT
WILL INCREASE AT PUBLIC HEALTH --
WE WANTED -- TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE FACT THAT --
COMING WITH THAT OF COURSE ARE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS -- THEIR
DISTRICTS ARE -- HAVE REQUIRED --
TO PURCHASE MONITORING EQUIPMENT.
DEVELOP EMISSIONS REDUCTION
PLANS -- ENGAGED TO EXTENSIVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AT JUST TO
NAME A FEW AND OF COURSE WE HAVE
TO HAVE STAFF TO DO ALL OF THAT
AS WELL -- WE APPRECIATE THE
FIFTY MILLION THAT WAS IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET.
AS WELL AS THE PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET --
WHAT WE ARE FINDING IN OUR
NINETEEN MONTHS OF IMPLEMENTING
THE PROGRAM IS THAT -- OUR
EXPERIENCE IS SHOWING THAT THE
COSTS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
SO THEY'RE EVEN HIGHER THAN THE
SEVENTY FIVE IN ONGOING COSTS OR
EVEN.
SEVENTY FIVE HIGHER THAN THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION THAT WAS --
THAT WE REQUESTED LAST YEAR --
WE TO THAT END WE'RE REQUESTING
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION -- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE RECOMMENDATION
ABOUT DEVELOPING A LONG TERM
FUNDING PLAN.
BECAUSE THE LACK OF A LONG TERM
FUNDING PLAN INSURED FUNDING IS
MAKING IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
FOR DISTRICTS TO HIRE STAFF AND
HAVE THE PROPER RESOURCES IN
PLACE -- TO CONTINUE TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM -- ADDITIONALLY WE
SUPPORT INCREASING AB SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE FIND
THAT THAT -- IT THE INCENTIVES
ARE THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS WAY --
AND COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
ADDITIONALLY -- TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE FARMER
PROGRAM THAT WAS DISCUSSED
EARLIER I WILL GO INTO THAT AND
THEN ALSO -- TWENTY MILLION FOR
WOOD STOVE CHANGE OUT SO THE
WOOD SMOKE REDUCTION PROGRAM BUT
WE DID APPRECIATE THE TWENTY
MILLION THAT WAS IN.
THE SENATE VERSION OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WIND UP WITH THERE
WAS THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
IN THE FINAL BUDGET AND WE
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT BUT
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE TWENTY
MILLION.
THAT WAS IN THE SENATE BUDGET
LAST YEAR AND YOU KNOW THAT'S A
VERY CALL AGAIN IN A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS ON THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS PLAN.
A STRATEGY EXCUSE ME -- HAS SOME --
TARGETS AND WE KNOW THAT IN
ORDER TO GET IN RELATED TO WHAT
STOVE CHANGE JOBS AND TO EVEN
BEGIN TO START TO GET.
TO REACHING THOSE TARGETS WE'VE
GOT TO START FINDING THAT
PROGRAM.
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY THANK.
SHE TO LOCAL AIR BOARDS A
CONTRIBUTION I REMEMBER DURING
THE HEARINGS WHEN WE WE HELP WE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY LISTEN
TO THE PROPONENTS OF WHERE THE
AUTHORS OF SIX SEVENTEEN AND THE
OBJECTIONS THAT YOU RAISED OVER
THE COST.
AND OVER THE DETAILS THAT WERE.
IRONIC HERE WE ARE TODAY THAT
YOU'RE IN CHARGE OF HAVING TO
IMPLEMENT THING YOU SAY WERE.
MALE RATHER WELL THEY WERE WHAT
THEY ARE THANK YOU HAVE NEXT
PERSON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
YEAH WAS INDEED A MANDATE AND
WEAK.
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING IT AND THEN
I'M WORKING HARD ON IT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING A STEVE WALK FOR
A COUPLE DIFFERENT CALMEST MAKE
BUT FOR SOME HAVE THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT.
WE DO WANT EXTEND OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE WORKFORCE EVELOPMENT --
FUNDING FOR THE PRECIOUS
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW SO FAR WE HAVE
A SMALL FLEET OF ZERO EMISSION
FUEL CELL BUSES WITH BUILDING
THAT TRAINING.
KIND OF IN HOUSE BUT AS WE
EXPAND THERE'S GONNA BE A GREAT
DEMAND FOR THE TRAINING RESOURCE.
AND SO WE DO WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT POINT --
THEN ALSO ON BEHIND THIS FIRST
ITEM I'LL BE AT THE CENTER FOR
TRANSPORTATION ENVIRONMENT.
WE CAN ENCOURAGE.
A GREATER ALLOCATION THE AIRPORT
PARTICULARLY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATORS -- IN PARTICULAR YOU
KNOW THE CAR BEEN THERE LONG
TERM PLAN IDENTIFIES THE NEED --
FOR LIKE A FUEL CELL BUS PILOT
PROGRAM BECAUSE THERE ARE
CERTAIN HURDLES FOR FOR FUEL
CELL VEHICLES PARTICULARLY THE
FEELINGS -- SECTOR THAT NEEDS TO
BE WORKED OUT FOR THE ECONOMY
SKILLS TO BRING THE PRICES DOWN.
SO WE ARE ASKING -- FOR AN
APPLICATION FOR THAT TO START A
A FUEL CELL PILOT PROGRAM -- AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD SO THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
RABBANI AS CALIFORNIA'S AGAINST
WASTE.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF FUNDING
FOR CAL COVER CYCLE AND HEALTHY
SOILS AS WELL -- AT THE COLLAPSE
OF INTERNATIONAL RECYCLING
MARKETS HAS PUT IN A CALIFORNIA
IN THE UNIQUE POSITION TO BE
ABLE TO AND BASS AND IT'S
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE PROGRAM'S MANAGEMENT HAVE A
CYCLE HAVE PROVEN O BE
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL AND HAVE
RANKED AMONGST THE HIGHEST IN
TERMS OF DOLLARS SPENT.
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION THEY
HAVE ALSO -- RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT BASEMENT
MANUFACTURING FOR RECOVERY AND
ORGANICS VERSION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THESE EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC INVESTMENT THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES WILL NEED TO
MAINTAIN EXISTING RECYCLING
PROGRAMS AND IMPLEMENT NEW
PROGRAMS. FOR GREEN AND FOOD
WASTE THANK YOU.
YEAH ACCORDING TO THE COST PER --
PER GREENHOUSE GAS DOLLARS PER
METRIC TON YOU'RE AT FIVE BUCKS
FOR A PANIC WAY SO.
IT'S HARD TO FIND A BETTER DEAL
THAN THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NECKS.
G. V. AIRS FOR BRIAN GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AND THE WESTERN UNITED
DAIRYMAN -- WE SUPPORT THE FULL
FUNDING OF THE METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAM AND ADMINISTERED THROUGH
CDFA.
AND WE WANT THAT SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THEY BURY INDUSTRY CAN
MEET ITS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION MANDATE.
THANK YOU.
SAM OF HELL WITH THE BLUE GREEN
ALLIANCE WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S PROPOSAL -- THIS IS A
WAY TO LEAD ON EQUITY IN AKRON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
CLIMATE SECTOR BOTH HERE AND
NATIONALLY THESE SORTS OF
PROGRAMS ARE.
PIVOTAL TO MOVING INTO AN ACTIVE
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT
BRINGS UP DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AT THE SAME TIME AND
WE'RE NOT.
SEEING THAT I'M REALLY ANYWHERE
ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL LIKE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS -- AND MORE PRACTICALLY
AS WE START TO DEVELOP
DISADVANTAGE WORKER REQUIREMENTS
ON THE FUNDING STREAMS THAT ARE
HEADING OUT INTO. THREE G. G. R.
F. THESE SORTS OF PROGRAMS TO
HELP US LEVERAGE THE
DISADVANTAGE WORKERS INTO THOSE
PROGRAMS.
THANKS THANK YOU NECKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SEVENTY MORAL ON
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION -- IN
SUPPORT OF A MULTI YEAR
ALLOCATION OF G. R. F. REVENUE
TO THE LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
FIND WE BELIEVE A STABLE
INCENTIVE FUNDING IS VITAL TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ZERO AND NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS.
AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE OUR
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE FOR CLEANER FREE
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU.
THANKS I'M SURE MEMBERS AS ARE
THE OTHER HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WELL I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ALSO
THE ADMINISTRATION PREFERRING
TOGETHER GREAT PROPOSAL WITH
COST WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
IT IS TRUE WE ARE PARTNERS WITH
THEM ON MANY OF THESE PROJECTS
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS -- BE
ADJUSTED SOMEWHAT BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS BUT WERE
GENERALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DIRECTION THEY'RE GOING.
ESPECIALLY WITH LABOR MANAGER
BEING THE ACTUAL -- BASES OF A
LOT OF THESE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
WILL LEAD TO GOOD QUALITY UNION
JOBS THANK YOU FOR HOLDING IT
OPEN [inaudible]
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAREMARK'S IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HERE TO
SUPPORT A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS --
ALL VALUABLE -- IN THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLEMENT COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM BUT WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
DRAW ATTENTION TO THE POINTS
MADE BY CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE AND BY THE CHAIR ALSO
REALLY.
THE BIGGEST BANG FOR YOUR BUCK
IN THE ALLOCATION IS INVESTMENT%
IN ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION --
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE UNDER A
A REQUIREMENT INITIATED BY US BE
A THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
DIFFER ADDITIONAL ORGANIC
MATERIAL OUT OF OUR LANDFILLS
THE CRITICALLY NEED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MARKETS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL.
AND WE ASK FOR INCREASED
INVESTMENT OF A HUNDRED MILLION
THANK YOU.
NEXT MORNING TURN MEMBERS PAUL
MASON PACIFIC FOR A STRESSED I
WANNA DRAW ATTENTION TO
SOMETHING REALLY INSIGHTFUL THE
CHAIR SAID DURING THE OPENING
REMARKS.
AND THAT'S THE INVESTMENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE CAP SECTORS ARE
GOING TO BRING US BETTER VALUE
IN TERMS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS THAN INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE.
ARE AROUND ACTIVITIES ARE
ALREADY UNDER THE CAP BUT THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT ALSO SOMETHING
THAT I THINK HAD CENTER STERN
MAY HAVE MENTIONED WAS THAT IN
TERMS OF OTHER PRIORITIES WE
SHOULD BE ADVANCING HERE.
ADAPTATION IN PREPARING FOR THE
CLIMB WE'RE GOING TO BE LIVING
IN THE FUTURE SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY.
THOSE TWO THINGS TOGETHER REALLY
DRIVE YOU TOWARDS INCREASING
INVESTMENTS IN THAT FOR WORKING
LAMBS WHICH LARGELY TOOK A HIT
IN THIS YEAR'S GREENHOUSE GAS --
BUDGET IN THE JANUARY PROPOSAL
BECAUSE THAT'S GONNA BOTH FOR
PARIS FOR CLIMATE THE PIRATE
LIVING IN THE FUTURE AS WELL AS
THE MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND SOME
OF THOSE UNDER THE CAP.
ALONG THOSE LINES WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO CAL FIRE WE
THINK THAT SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE
USED FOR A COMBINATION OF FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION THE
WAY HAS BEEN IN THE PAST AT THE
DEPARTMENT'S DISCRETION.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO
ELEVEN SILAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE PACIFIC FOR
STRESS.
AS WELL JUST BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO A LETTER THAT WAS --
CIRCULATED TO COMMITTEE IN
REGARDS TO RESTRAIN PROPOSE YOUR
DRAFT CUTS TO NATURAL WORKING
LANDS PROGRAMS YOU KNOW IT'S
OFTEN SAID THAT THE BUDGET IS A
STATEMENT OF OUR VALUES IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE THINK IT IS
REALLY CRITICAL THAT A CLOSER
LOOK IS PAID TO THAT.%
AND IT WOULD ALSO JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SENATOR MUNNINGS
COMMON INTO IN REGARDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF LEARNING FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION THERE IS ONE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM.
IN THAT TABLE THAT WAS FUNDED AT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR
THAT'S NOW OPEN IT AT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GIVEN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN REGARDS TO SOME
OF THE POTENTIAL DESTRUCTION IT
COULD HAPPEN FROM SEA LEVEL RISE
WE THINK.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THAT AND WE DO
UNDERSTAND THE PROP SIXTY
DOLLARS WILL GO TO THAT -- BUT
IT'S AN INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE YESTERDAY INNOCENTLY
BUDGETS OF THREE THE ELLIE --
MENTIONED SOME NEW YOU USGS DATA
THAT SHOW THAT A PINCH TENSELY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN REAL ESTATE IS AT
RISK -- BY TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO SIX POINT
5% OF THE STATE'S GDP I'M SOME
SOME PRETTY BIG NUMBERS AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON
THE ISSUE.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE JORDAN AND
WITH THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY -- WE
WORK WITH LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DISADVANTAGE UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THE CIRCUS ALL ABOUT
THESE -- THESE COMMUNITIES AND
FIGHTING FOR INVESTMENT IN AND
OUT AN ADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND I'VE HAD TO DEAL
DISPROPORTIONATELY WITH AIR
QUALITY -- ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION AND HIGH ENERGY
BURDENS -- SO WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE TRANSFER OF
CLIMBING COMMUNITIES WE BELIEVE
THIS IS A CRUCIAL TOOL FOR
ADDRESSING NEEDS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES -- AND WE SUPPORT
ASKING A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
FOR THAT PROGRAM -- AND
SPECIFICALLY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THE DISADVANTAGE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS ARE ABLE TO
COMPETE FOR IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS -- IN THIS PROGRAM -- WE
ALSO URGE YOU TO CONSIDER AND
INCLUDE A PERCENTAGE OF FUNDS BE
DIRECTLY AND SPECIFICALLY.
TARGETED TOWARDS THIS BANDS ON
THE CORPORATE COMMUNITIES.
IN EASTERN TELL OF ALLEY FOR
EXAMPLE THEY RECEIVED PLANNING
GRANTS AND THE PROPOSED --
SEVERAL DIFFERENT PROJECTS
INCLUDING RIDE CHER --
WEATHERIZATION PROJECTS EVER
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ELECTRIC
BUSES -- BUT THESE COMMUNITY
VISIONS CAN'T EVEN YOU REALIZE
UNLESS THIS MANAGED ON A
CORPORATE COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPLICITLY MADE ELIGIBLE FOR TCC
GRANTS AND ARE GIVEN -- DIRECTED
FUNDING UP WHICH WE THINK IS
APPROPRIATE GIVEN EXTENSIVE
HISTORIC ON INVESTMENT -- THE
OTHER PROGRAM WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THE METHANE
REDUCTION IN SPECIFICALLY BURIED
I JESTER -- HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS -- THAT HAVE BEEN
SPENT SUBSIDIZING LARGE
INDUSTRIAL DAIRY OPERATIONS
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER SPENT ON
PROJECTS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
BENEFITTING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- INVESTMENTS AND I
JUST ENCOURAGE BIG DERRY'S ONLY
GET BIGGER -- WITHOUT A CLEAR
KIND OF DATA ABOUT THIS HOLISTIC
IMPACTS IMPACTS OF THE ADJUSTER
TECHNOLOGY -- INCREASING
CONTAMINATION GROUND WATER AND
AIR QUALITY -- WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATOR RECKON REFRAIN FROM
INVESTING ANY JR F. DOLLARS
UNDER DIGESTERS -- WE RAISE
RAISED SEVERAL CONCERNS RELATED
TO THAT I JUST -- PROGRAM -- AND
THOSE QUESTIONS STILL REMAIN
UNANSWERED. FOR EXAMPLE SEVERAL
DIGESTIVE PROGRAMS CLAIM THEY
BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- WHICH COMMUNITIES
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT -- HOW
THESE BENEFITS ACTUALLY VERIFIED --
ARE JERRY CLUSTERS IN INDUCING
INCREASED CONCENTRATION OF THERE
ISN'T HOUSE AND WHAT ARE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THAT
TREND -- HAVE WE SEEN EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS FROM INVESTMENTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE.
OUR INVESTMENTS ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING THE CREATION OF
METHANE RATHER THAN IDENTIFYING
MORE ECOLOGICAL WAYS OF
APPROACHING AND MANAGING ANIMAL
AGRICULTURE -- ARE THEY JUST
THERE'S EVEN EFFECTIVE FOR SMALL
SCALE -- DERES -- YOU MENTIONED
THREE HUNDRED CAL DERRY'S MR WHY
ARE DERRY'S COST EFFECTIVE. FOR
THOSE ARE OUR DIGESTERS CASA FOR
EFFECTIVE FOR THOSE AREAS OR IS
IT REALLY JUST LARGE DAIRIES --
OVER THE LONG RUN ARE THEY
FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE SO --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU NECKS.
WELL GOOD MORNING MR TERM MEMBER
THREE COMMA STRAIGHTEN OUT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
ECHOING THE COMMENTS ABOUT
INVESTING IN NATURAL RESOURCE
PROGRAMS FOR NOT JUST MITIGATION
BUT ADAPTATION.
I DO WANT TO FOCUS ON PROGRAMS
THAT I KNOW THE BEST WHICH IS
THE URBAN GREENING URBAN
FORESTRY AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
I MEAN WE HAVE SEEN THE IMPACTS
ON THE LANDSCAPE FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE THROUGH WILDFIRES WE'VE
GOT THE WORST FIRES IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
BUT WE KNOW AS I THINK SOME
MEMBER I MAY HAVE MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT THE THE FLOODING
AND HE ARE COMMENT.
AND MOST OF THE POPLE THAT LIVE
IN THE STATE LIVE IN OUR HEARTS
GAPED URBANIZED AREAS THAT ARE
NOT PREPARED FOR HEAT OR
FLOODING.
IN THESE TWO PROGRAMS URBAN
FORESTRY URBAN GREENING OUR
INTERVENTIONS THAT.
OUR WORK EXTREMELY URGENT IN MY
OPINION AND YOU KNOW AND THERE'S
A BOND THAT'S CIRCULATING IN
THIS BODY RIGHT NOW TO ADDRESS
ADAPTATION FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
THERE'S A SENSE OF URGENCY THERE
BUT THAT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS
TO GET OUT THE DOOR IF THE
VOTERS APPROVE IT.
SO JUST URGE THE LEGISLATURE
LOOK AT THESE TEACHER OF FUNDS --
FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
PARTICULARLY WHERE ALL THE
PEOPLE LIVE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
HI STEPHANIE TIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
LANCE SARAH -- WE'VE SHARED A
LETTER ON SEVERAL DIFFERENT YEAR
PROGRAMS WITH ALL OF YOU SO
WE'LL GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM I
JUST WANNA MAKE A FEW POINTS
HERE TODAY -- FIRST ON SIX
SEVENTEEN I THINK THE YOU KNOW
THE BOTTOM LINE IS OUR
COMMUNITIES REALLY NEED --
EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND THEY
NEED IT NOW AND THEY NEEDED
URGENTLY -- SO WE YOU KNOW WE WE
DO NEED -- CARBON TO STEP IN AND
PROVIDE STRONG STEVE MY GUIDANCE
AND OVERSIGHT AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL -- AND WE KNOW THAT THE
RESOURCES AND STAFFING FOR THAT.
ON ON THE WORK FORCE ISSUE I'M
NOT GONNA ARGUE ON THE NEXUS
REQUIREMENT BUT ANOTHER YOU KNOW
BOTTOM LINE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
IS THAT WE REALLY DO NEED ACCESS --
YOU KNOW TO THESE CAREER
PATHWAYS AND THAT THESE PROGRAMS
DO ACTUALLY PROVIDE THAT
CONNECTION -- FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW COMMUNION
VERS SPECIALLY -- RESIDENTS WITH
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT TO
ACTUALLY -- HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
YOU KNOW GOOD UNION JOBS.
ON THIRD -- STRONGLY AGREE WITH
AND SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUE JULIA --
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL JUSTICE.
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IS POINTS --
ON TCC AND TERRY DI JESTERS AND
LASTLY IT REALLY APPRECIATE --%
THE CHAIR IN THE ALLEY -- AND
YOU ALL FREEZING -- A BIGGER
BIGGER PICTURE DISCUSSION ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHERE THIS MONEY COMES
FROM I THINK IF WE REALLY WANT
TO GET MORE SERIOUS ABOUT
REDUCING.
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS --
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WE NEED
TO RAISE THE PRICE OF CARBON.
THANKS MAX.
THANK YOU WANT ME DONE WITHOUT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA FIRST OFF --
GONNA.
YOU KNOW SHARE OUR OUR SENTIMENT
ALIGN OUR OUR COMMENTS.
WITH PACIFIC WORKS TRUST -- THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY -- POINTS
THAT RELATED TO HOW
DISAPPOINTING WE DISAPPOINTED WE
ARE AND THE ALLOCATIONS FOR OR
PROPOSED ALLOCATIONS FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES SECTOR.
WE KNOW THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS IN THE LONG TERM WE NEED
TO START INVESTING NOW IN IN IN
NATURAL RESOURCES.
THAT MEANS WETLANDS THAT MEANS --
HEALTHY SOILS THAT MEANS --
URBAN FORESTRY AND FOREST HEALTH.
BUT WE WON'T GET THERE IF WE
DON'T START INVESTING NOW --
INTO CENTERED MUNNINGS POINT --
OCEANS NEEDS TO BE PART OF THAT --
SOLUTIONS AS WELL WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MONEY BE DIRECTED TO THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL TO BE
ABLE TO START STRATEGIZING ON
HOW WE GET. TO THAT POINT USING
OUR OCEANS AS A WAY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE REQUEST OR
CARBON THANK YOU.
NEXT I AM ONLY SERVER --
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND WE
JUST LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
AS WELL HER COLLEAGUES FROM
NATURE CONSERVANCY OF PACIFIC
FOREST AUSTIN AUDUBON.
THANK YOU NECKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JONATHAN MATS
FROM THE SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL
NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP I'M HERE
WITH MY PARTNER -- MARTY A ROCK
SHOW FROM CALIFORNIA RELIEF WE
BOTH ARE IN THE COALITION
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOR ALL --
ANDS WERE CROSS SECTORAL A
COALITION CONSISTING OF PARTNERS
FROM HOUSING TRANSIT ACTIVE
RANSPORTATION ON THE NATURAL
RESOURCES -- WE WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE -- THE THE COMMITTEE
IN THE LEGISLATURE -- IN ITS
INVESTMENT PLAN TO UP -- THE
ALLOCATIONS TO LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM TO SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON THAT
PROGRAM -- ABOUT THAT WILL SERVE
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS
UNDER THE CURRENT ALLOCATION --
BUT WITHIN AN ADDITIONAL --
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STILL ON THE
WAIT LIST -- AND IT'S A PROGRAM --
HUNT A 100% OF THE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN AT A DISADVANTAGE
COMMUNITIES -- WITH IT BUT I
THINK IT'S A KEY PROGRAM THAT
THAT BOTH CAN BRING -- THE
EMISSIONS DOWN AS WELL AS
PROVIDING A SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS
TO TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES AS
WELL AS A A FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE TO THE CLEAN DATE
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY FOR PEDAL ASSIST
ELECTRIC BIKES -- WHICH CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE M. T. --
GOOD TEEN PHYSICAL ACTIVITY --
IN -- IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES --
AND BRIDGE THE GAP TO TRANSIT AS
WELL -- 46% OF CAR TRIPS -- HAVE
BEEN REPLACED ACCORDING TO A
SURVEY OF SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
OPTICAL ASSIST -- BIKE -- USERS
AND PASSED OVER.
YES SO THE URBAN GREEN AND URBAN
OF FORESTRY PROGRAM ARE CRITICAL
TO IMPROVING THE WHOLE THING
LIVE ABILITY IN METROPOLITAN
AREAS WHERE THE MAJORITY OF CAL
CALIFORNIANS LIVE.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT ONLY THE
PRIMARY CARBON SEQUESTRATION.
MECHANISM BUT THEY ALSO PROVIDE
MULTIPLE COAL BENEFITS TO URBAN
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS REDUCING THE
URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT -- HELP
MANAGE -- FLOODING -- IMPROVE
AIR AND WATER QUALITY AND
PROVIDE HABITATS FOR WILDLIFE.
SO FOR THESE REASONS MY
COLLEAGUE AND I HAVE OUTLINED WE
URGE YOU TO INVEST IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND HELP -- CREATES A
STABLE COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU IN NEXT.
ALLEN ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CAP COAL ALSO NOTE THAT THE
BAY AREA HAS TWO SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES -- IN THE FIRST YEAR
WEST OAKLAND IN RICHMOND SAN
PABLO THE WORK WE'VE DONE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES WE FEEL IS A
IS A OUTSTANDING MODEL FOR WHAT
THE SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM WAS
THAT WAS DESIGNED TO DO.
BUT WE ALSO NOTE THAT TO GET THE
REDUCTIONS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND TO DO THE WORK NECESSARY TO
MULTI YEAR EFFORT -- IN BOTH OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND AND ASK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
THE COMMENTS FROM -- THE LA OWES
OFFICE ABOUT ESTABLISHING A SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION AS A AS
A ON GOING APPROPRIATION FOR THE
AIR DISTRICTS WE ALSO NOTED NOTE
THAT MANY OF THE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST ARE GOING TO
NEED TO COME FROM TRANSPORTATION --
MOBILE SOURCE EMISSIONS AND THE
FREIGHT SECTOR IN AND DIESEL
EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND SO WE
SUPPORT -- INCREASING THE THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS FOR A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN IS -- NOTED BY KEPCO
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MATTEO CROWN BEHALF
OF THE MOUNDS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY IN SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE PACIFIC FORCE
TRUST ME OTHER GROUPS THAT.
HAVE.
HOPE TO THE NEED FOR INCREASED
MATCH RESOURCE INVESTMENT ON I
THINK SOMETHING I WAS DISCUSSING
COMMITTED TODAY ON CO BENEFITS --
PEOPLE DISCUSSED ADAPTATION OUR
RESILIENCE AND ALSO -- THE SHEER
AMOUNT OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION BENEFITS FROM THESE
NATURAL RESOURCE INVESTMENT SO --
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ASK -- TO
SUPPORT NATURIST PROGRAMS AND
HOPE THE COMMITTEE MOVES THAT
DIRECTION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STEVEN
SIMON FROM THE WORKER EDUCATION
RESOURCE CENTER -- WHERE LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP?
ESTABLISHED BY THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND SEIU LOCAL SEVEN TO
ONE I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
APPROPRIATE G. G. R. F. FUNDING
TO THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD -- SO THE THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S HYBRID
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP FUNDING HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL TO HELPING US
GET OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS OFF THE
GROUND -- THE WAIT CD C. W. D.
B. DESIGNS IS FUNDING STREAMS
ALLOWS SMALL ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS. TO FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
MOST URGENT MATTERS OF
ORGANIZATION DEVELOPMENT --
PLANNING RELATIONSHIP BUILDING
THINGS THAT FUNDERS DON'T
GENERALLY LIKE TO FUND BUT ARE.
CRITICAL TO SUCCESS TO SUCCESS
AND THIS IS MEANT THAT WITHIN
JUST MONTHS OF LAUNCHING ARE
PREPARING LOS ANGELES FOR COUNTY
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM -- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PLACE CLOSE TO SIXTY
PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE HIGH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT -- IN FULL TIME JOBS
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
THESE ARE NUMBERS THAT ARE KIND
OF UNHEARD OF IN THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WORK WELL WORLD
WE'RE TIME A CONNECTING
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS WITH.
HIGHBURY STANDPOINT TO PERMANENT
FULL TIME MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH
A PENSION AND A CAREER PATHWAY.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY PEOPLE AT A
TIME IN A SINGLE EMPLOYER WE
THINK THAT SCALABLE IN LA COUNTY
THERE'S TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
ENTRY LEVEL JOBS HIRED PER YEAR
THAT COULD BE YOU KNOW UTILIZING
THIS MODEL -- AND WE'RE TIME OF
FOLKS ON PROBATION PAROLE.
GENERAL RELIEF VETERANS CAL
WORKS PEOPLE FROM SOME OF THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE NOW
HAVE PERMANENT MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
AS A RESULT OF THIS FUNDING --
AND SO I'M JUST HERE TO URGE YOU
GUYS YOU ALL TO SUPPORT -- YOU
KNOW BRINGING THIS MODEL THOUGH
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MODEL
TO THE TRANSITION TO THE A LOW
CARBON ECONOMY -- YOU KNOW
REPRESENTS A REAL OPPORTUNITY
CONNECT -- THOSE PEOPLE FROM
COMMUNITIES HER MOST IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE TO THE JOBS THAT
ARE DRESSED IN THE CRISIS THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
MAX THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TO EMAIL AND ASK YOU
BOBBY HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION I'M HERE TODAY JOINING
A COALITION.
AUTO MAKERS -- ZERO EMISSION
TRUCK AND BUS PROVIDERS
MANUFACTURERS AND ET
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDERS --
SUPPORTING THE CONTINUE FUNDING
FOR LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS.
WITH USAGI DERIVE FUNDS -- YOU
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT SIX
YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA HAD ALMOST
ZERO ZERO MISSION VEHICLES ON
THE ROAD AND TODAY SIX YEARS
LATER THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND EMISSION VEHICLES
ON THE ROAD AND THAT IS DUE IN
NO SMALL PART TO CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES.
BUT MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENT THAT YOU'RE MAKING
USING THESE DOLLARS.
FOOD HAS TWO THINGS WE WOULD SAY
WHEN YOU DO YOUR ASSESSMENT ON
WHAT IS THE RIGHT DOLLAR AMOUNT
FOR LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS LOOK AT THAT NEED.
CALIFORNIA SET OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF A GOAL BY TWO EIGHT
FIVE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AS BY
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL -- IS THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT OF FOR A LOCATED
IN THIS -- THIS YEAR GETTING US
ON THAT TRAJECTORY AND THE
SECOND THING IS IS THAT WE WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM EVERYBODY
ABOUT WE NEED LONG TERM STABLE
FUNDING FOR THESE.
PROGRAMS AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO AT
LEAST GO THREE YEARS OUT WITH
THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JIM PARTRIDGE ON
BEHALF OF THE PROPOSITION THIRTY
NINE CLEAN ENERGY JOBS ACTS
CITIZENS OVERSIGHT BOARD.
WE'LL SUBMIT OUR ANNUAL REPORTS
LEGISLATURE TOMORROW CONTAINING
A RECOMMENDATION TO SUPPORT THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
DIGITAL LOOK AT THAT REPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TREES WRECKAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I WANT TO SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
IT'S A CRITICAL SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO MAINTAIN HEALTHY
AFFORDABLE HOMES HOMES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THROUGH
WEATHERIZATION AND SOLAR
INSTALLATION.
ALL OF THE DOUBLE L. A. W. P.
SUBPROGRAMS ARE FULLY SUBSCRIBER
THOUSANDS OF HOMES ON THE WAIT
LIST WITHOUT SUBSTANTIAL FINDING
THIS BUDGET CYCLE TWO OF THE LA
W. PEAS MOST SUCCESSFUL.
SUBPROGRAMS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
RE OPEN FOR TWELVE TO TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS THIS IS SERIOUS
REPERCUSSIONS ON THE LOCAL.
WORK FORCE LA W. P. HAS A BROAD
RANGE OF SUPPORT FROM OWNERS
RENTERS BUSINESSES ADVOCATES IN
COMMUNITIES AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM
RECEIVES FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
WE ARE JUST COMMITTED A SPARTAN
ALLOCATION OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
AT THE US SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET FOR THIS HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL IN CRITICAL PROGRAM
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPASS
COALITION.
WE WANT TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IN THE CHAIR WE ARE.
HAPPY TO SEE A INCREASE IN
ALLOCATION BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ROCKY RUSSIAN WITH COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR.
THE MOVEMENT OF GOODS IN
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS 4405% OF OUR
KNOCKS EMISSIONS.
TRUCKS AND BUSES 37% OF OUR GHG
EMISSIONS.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
TRAVEL SIXTY MILLION MILES PER
DAY OUR ROADS AND HIGHWAYS.
THESE POLLUTANTS ARE PREVENTING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS RATE
BREEDING HEALTHY AIR AND ON THAT
POINT CALLS FOR CLEAN AIR
SUPPORT TO MULTI YEAR
APPROPRIATION. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN TRUCK BUS IN
OFF ROAD VEHICLE EQUIPMENT
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM.
THIS WOULD UNDERSCORE OUR
COMMITMENT TO INCENTIVIZE YOU
ADVANCES IN CLEAN MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORT AS WELL AS
OUR COMMITMENTS TO OUR CLEAN AIR
AND CLIMATE GOALS.
CALLS FOR CLEAN AIR IS ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- FOR AGRICULTURE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS -- IN
JANUARY.
CAR WAS IN FRESNO AND APPROVED A
PLAN TO FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY TO ACHIEVE FEDERAL ERA AT
AIR QUALITY ATTAINMENT.
IT WASN'T MANT TO BE AN
ASPIRATIONAL PLAN.
AND THE FUNDING -- THAT THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS LAID OUT AND IN
PARTICULAR FOR DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT -- IS FAR FROM
ADEQUATE AND WE WOULD HOPE THAT
THE SENATE WOULD -- RECTIFY THAT
PROBLEM AS WELL I WOULD DO IT
WOULD JUST LIKE TO INCORPORATE
MIKE -- OUR COMMENTS WITH SOME
OF THE COMMENTS MADE ON S. B. --
AB SIX ONE SEVEN IMPLEMENTATION.
CRITICAL -- CRITICAL PROGRAM.
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
BUT YOUR MEMBERS BRIAN SHOW BUT
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
I'M CONTINUING THE THEME OF
FARMS AND ADAPTATION -- SMALL
AND MID SCALE FARMS ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE MOST AT RISK OF THE
NEXT DROUGHT.
AND OTHER CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS --
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR A FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SWEET
PROGRAM TO HELP THEM -- REMAIN
RESILIENT TO THE NEXT ROUND AND
FINANCE THEIR TRANSITION TO
CLEANER AND MORE EFFICIENT
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS. THREE
QUARTERS OF THOSE GRANTS HAVE
GONE TO THE FARMS OF FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES OR LESS AND THE
PROGRAM'S BEEN CONSISTENTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED BY TWO TO THREE
TIMES OVER SIX ROUNDS.
I DID WANT TO CORRECT --
SOMETHING THAT WAS SAID EARLIER
ABOUT THE PROGRAM THE PROGRAM
DID RECEIVE TWENTY MILLION LAST
YEAR FROM POP SIXTY EIGHT BUT
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE SPENT ON
THIS YEAR AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAVE.
HAS NO MONEY FOR THE PROGRAM SO
UNLESS WE GET YOU DRAFT THE
PROGRAM WILL DISCONTINUE.
I'M AN ALASKAN ADAPTATION WE'RE
ALSO SEEKING TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR FUNDING FOR KIND OF
ADAPTATION TOOLS -- THIS IS
DECISION SUPPORT AND PLANNING
TOOLS FOR FARMERS RANCHERS
MAKING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KODI BLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED BIO FUELS ALLIANCE AND
I TO ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH THE
PREVIOUS -- SPEAKER FROM A CLEAN
ENERGY AND JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT
IN ST BIOFUELS PRODUCTION NOT
ONLY PROVIDES A SOURCE OF GHG
REDUCTIONS BUT ALSO A SOURCE OF
A LIVING WAGE JOBS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDING RCM
HAVE A SEAT ON OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES WE WANNA LANA COMMENTS
OF CALIFORNIA TO CANCEL A SO WE
WANT TO EMPHASIZE.
THAT WE NEED MORE FUNDING TO FOR
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET
OUR AS THE THIRTY THREE GOALS
WE'RE GONNA NEED A NET COST OF
TWO TO THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN FIFTY TO A HUNDRED NEW
EXPANDED RECYCLING ORGANIC WASTE
FACILITIES.
HELLO KELLY ROBBINS HERE.
KAYLA ROBINSON HERE ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE AND WE JUST LIKE
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS I'M WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY SEA AND ARE.
THEY GIVE NECKS.
DANIEL TORE IS WITH THE FLAVORS
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES -- WE
PREPARE PEOPLE RETURNING HOME
FROM INCARCERATION ARM FOR
CAREERS IN UNION CONSTRUCTION --
I'M HERE TO SAY THAT.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND THEIR ASK OF THE FUNDS
TO CONTINUE THIS WORK IN A
COUPLE THINGS I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT.
AS SOMEBODY THAT'S A GRADUATE OF
THE PROGRAM BUT NOW AN
INSTRUCTOR -- INSTRUCTING PEOPLE.
TO BECOME UNION MEMBERS.
THE CURRICULUM IS ONLY POSSIBLE
TO PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS IN OUR
AREAS.
THOSE COUNCILS WE KNOW THAT
CONSTRUCTION AND GREEN BUILDING
IS SO INTERTWINED IT'S NOT EVEN
CALL GREEN CONSTRUCTION ANYMORE
IS CALLED CONSTRUCTION.
THAT'S HOW EMBEDDED ARM BEING
AWARE OF THIS GREENHOUSE
EMISSIONS STUFF IS.
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS ONLY POSSIBLE
IS DRIVEN BY LABOR DEMAND SO THE
THE BUILDING TRADES ONLY GIVE
THESE PARTNERSHIPS IF THAT
DEMAND IS THERE.
SO TO JUST SPEAK TO THE POINT OF
US BEING A STEP REMOVED -- FROM
AN ACTUAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
I KNOW FIRST HAND.
THAT THE BUILDING TRADES ARE
FULLY ONBOARD WITH WHAT'S GOING
ON FROM AS FAR AS MC THREE
CURRICULUM.
THERE'S EVEN CONTENT A CHAPTER
IN THE CURRICULUM THAT I'VE I
TEACH.
THAT'S ON SPECIFIC GREEN
CONSTRUCTION TRYING SO WE'RE
PREPARING PEOPLE FOR THIS WORK --
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO REALLY
BUILD ON THE MOMENTUM THAT TIM
AND HIS TEAM IS BUILT ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD.
NOW AND TO NOT SUPPORT THAT WORK
WITH IT WHAT WOULD REALLY STIFLE
THE MOMENTUM THAT'S HAPPENING
THAT'S GOING TO KEEP GOING FOR
YEARS TO COME THANK YOU AND KILL
NECKS.
A GOOD MORNING WILL BEAR GOOD
AFTERNOON WILL BEAR WITH
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION A LOT
OF WHAT I WANT TO COVER IT'S
BEEN STATED SO THIS KIND OF TEXT
WRITTEN QUICKLY.
ON THE LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WE DO AGREE THAT THAT
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT AS MORE OF A
CONTINUOUS PREPARATION MULTI
YEAR FUNDING.
SOURCE -- WITHIN THAT THE HEAVY
DUTY TRUCK AND OFFERED CATEGORY.
TICK -- TOOK A HIT THIS YEAR WE
THINK THAT SHOULD BE MADE UPAND
AND MEET THE DEMAND.
OF ESPECIALLY IN IN TERMS OF THE
NEED FOR ZERO MISSION TRUCKS AND
BUSES. TO HELP ME -- CLEANER
CLIMATE NEEDS.
ON THE C. V. R. P. WE WE AGREE
WITH COMMENTS THAT THE TWO ARE
MILLION -- FOR THAT PROGRAM IS A
FLAT LINE IT'S NOT GOING TO KEEP
PACE WITH THE DEMAND FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THAT WE KNOW
WE NEED -- ON THE SIX ONE EIGHTY
SIX ONE SEVEN PROGRAM AGAIN WE
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR AN ONGOING
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THAT.
MAKING UP THE SHORTFALL THAT'S
BEEN -- PROPOSE THIS IN THIS
BUDGET AND REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT OUR LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IN
OUR STATE AGENCIES ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED TO CARRY THAT
OUT AS A PRO PROGRAM EXPANDS.
ON THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
WE DO SUPPORT THE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION ASK -- FOR AND THE
TRANSFORMERS CLIMATE OF
COMMUNITIES GRANTS.
IN AGAIN WITHIN THAT LAST.
AT THE END OF THE LIST --
SUPPORT THE INCREASE FUNDING --
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
SEEK A GRANT FUNDING THROUGH
THAT AGENCY AND THEN FINALLY --
AGREE WITH KEPCO ON THE NEED FOR
INVESTMENT IN THE WOOD STOVE
TRADER PROGRAM TO BOTH.
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH FROM
LOCALIZE POLLUTION SOURCES AND
METER CLIMB AND IT'S OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
HI MY NAME IS KENNY ADDISON AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE U. H.
W. WESTERN EMPLOYER IN EDUCATION
FUN.
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL THAT'S AN
ISSUE.
ON OUR PROGRAM WE WERE ONE OF
THE ORIGINAL EIGHT UP PROGRAMS
FOR THE HIGH ROAD TO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS OUR PARTNER OUR
PROGRAM WAS FOCUSED ON
HEALTHCARE CAREER SO WE WORK
WITH OUR MEMBERS OF THE
HOSPITALS.
THAT WORK IN THE HOSPITALS OUR
FOCUS THEN DRILL DOWN TO THE
ENTRY LEVEL NON CLINICAL STAFF
WHICH ARE USUALLY SOME OF THE
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS THAT WERE
SPEAKING OF TODAY.
THEY HAD BEEN TRAINED -- WE
TRAINED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
WORKERS DURING OUR TIME.
AND THEY WERE TRAINED -- THEIR
CUSTOMIZED TRAINING INCLUDED
REDUCED -- IN.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CONSERVING ENERGY RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING THROUGHOUT THEIR
DEPARTMENTS AT KAISER FACILITIES.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS WAS A
<c.cyan>REAT EXERCISE AND MERGING</c>
EVERYONE IS DOING SO WELL.
IN LINE HERE -- MY NAME IS KATIE
PATTERSON I'M WITH AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU -- YOU KNOW FOR THE LA
AS REPORT AND ALSO THE
CONSIDERATION OF USING THAT
HIGHER -- AMOUNT BECAUSE THEM
OUR ESTIMATION FOR FUNDING
ALLOCATION -- WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS -- IN APPRECIATION FOR THE
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING THERE -- WE WE LOOK AT
THAT PROGRAM WE UNDERSTAND WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT.
I'M WHAT YOU'VE HEARD HERE TODAY
FROM A A NUMBER OF SOURCES OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW
COMPOSTING AT THAT TRUCK THAT
THIS IS A SYSTEM IN AS A SENATOR
MCGUIRE MENTIONED EARLIER IT IS
A VERY COMPLEX ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENT.
AND I THINK THAT THESE PROGRAMS
CAN ALL BALANCE EACH OTHER OUT
YOU KNOW FOR THE HEALTHY SOILS
COMPONENT BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE A
PLACE YOU KNOW TO PUT.
THOSE COMPOSTABLE NO GOODS THAT
NEED TO BE APPLIED ON THE
LANDSCAPE IT WILL HELP US FOR
RESILIENCY NO -- FOR WATER AND
AND SOIL HEALTH AND WILL HELP
PREPARE US YOU KNOW IN LIGHT OF
THESE THESE CLIMATE CHANGES THAT
WE WILL BE FACING THANK YOU.
NEXT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
UNTIL WITH SHOT YOUR ENTRY HERE
DOING TRIPLE DUTY BUT I'LL TRY
TO BE VERY BRIEF.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSISTORS STATION WE SUPPORT
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN ZERO
EMISSION BUSES AND TRUCKS WITH
THINGS I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS
THAT FROM A FLEET PLANNING AND
PROCUREMENT PERSPECTIVE.
HAVING LONG TERM CERTAINTY ABOUT
FINDING IS IMPORTANT FOR
ALLOWING -- AGENCIES IN IN MY
CONTACTS TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
INVESTMENTS IN ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY TO ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT
STRATEGIES FOR CREATING THAT
TYPE OF LONG TERM CERTAINTY --
FOR THESE INVESTMENTS NUMBER
HALF OF US STOP WASTING ONE IS
THAT WE SUPPORT INVESTMENTS IN
HEALTHY SOILS AND THEN FINALLY
ON BEHALF OF STOP WASTE.
SWANNANOA NATIONAL A STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL IN THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL --
THEY'RE ALL HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE INVESTMENTS IN COLOR CYCLE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS ECHO THE
COMMENTS FOR MANY OF MY NATURAL
WORKING LANCE COLLEAGUES ON THE
NEED FOR INVESTMENT AND NATURAL
WORKING LANCE.
I THINK THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THAT WAS HELD HERE IN
CENTER NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER ON TUESDAY MORNING REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THESE
LANDS FOR SEQUESTRATION HELP IN
MEETING OUR COMMON GOALS.
BUT ALSO IN INVESTING IN
RESILIENCE AS WE SEE THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE REALLY TAKING
EFFECT LAST COUPLE YEARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NECKS.
GOOD MORNING CHAN MEMBERS JAMIE
GO ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RELIEF AS WELL AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND JUST
WANTED TO ECHO A LOT OF THE SAME
COMMENTS MADE BY THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND TNC.
AN AUDUBON ON THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND
SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
LETTER THAT WENT AROUND
REQUESTING FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THESE PURPOSES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
TAX.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELL CREAMERS
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION I WANTED TO AND URGE
AN INCREASE IN THE FUNDING FOR
THE AG DIESEL ENGINE REPLACEMENT
TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN.
THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE -- AS OF DECEMBER OVER
SIX HUNDRED PROJECTS ALREADY
HAVE EXECUTED CONTRACTS AND THEY
IT'S OVERSUBSCRIBED THERE'S MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS FOR THAT
PROGRAM -- ADDITIONALLY.
THAT PROGRAM WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL IN MEETING THE PM TWO
POINT FIVE SET FOR THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY -- BY PROVIDING
INCENTIVES SO THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTIVE
OF THE OF AN INCREASE IN THE
JURY METHANE -- REDUCTION
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU NECKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA CASKEY
MEMBERS AN ALLEY -- SPEAKERS MY
NAME IS VERONICA PARDO NAMA HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNCIL
NORTHERN DISTRICT.
HERE TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT.
AT A MINIMUM ONE HUNDRED MILLION
TO COVER CYCLE IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR SIGNIFICANT.
AS BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
GOALS AND DIVERT ORGANICS FROM
CALIFORNIA LANDFILLS. TO ACHIEVE
THIS IMPORTANT METHANE REDUCTION
EFFORT IS EXPECTED TO COST
BILLIONS AND NEARLY -- I NEED OF
NEARLY TRIPLING OUR CURRENT
ORGANIC MANAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
CARIS CYCLES PROGRAM AS I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD HAS BEEN
CONTINUOUSLY OVERSUBSCRIBED AND
OFFER SUBSTANTIAL GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION BENEFITS.
IN ADDITION TO ORGANIC WASTE
MANAGEMENT THIS PROGRAM ALSO NOW
SUPPORTS EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERY TO
ENSURE FOOD GETS TO PEOPLE NEED.
LONG BEFORE IT IS COMPOSTED OR
ANAEROBICALLY DIGESTED.
THROWING AN URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
AN INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE
POWER CYCLE PROGRAM.
ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT THE MOBILE
SOURCE EMISSION FUNDING FOR
HEAVY DUTY -- DUTY VEHICLES AND
OFFER AN APPOINTMENT AND LOW
CARBON FUEL PRODUCTION.
AND OF COURSE TO ENCOURAGE
MARKETS FOR ORGANIC COMMODITIES
PRODUCED THROUGH ORGANICS
MANAGEMENT WE REALLY NEED TO
CLOSE THE LOOP ON ORGANIC WASTE
AND SUPPORT THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
AFTERNOON NOW GOOD AFTERNOON
TRICIA CALENDAR I CANCELED
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FIRST OFF THANK YOU TWO CENTER
MCGUIRE FOR SO WELL ARTICULATING
MANY OF THE CONCERNS IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND SOME OF THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT -- ALSO WANT --
TO REFLECT BACK TO SUPPORTING
THE TUNER FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST OF THE AIR DISTRICTSFOR
THE MOBILE AT DIESEL AND STATION
I ADD DIESEL ENGINE REPLACEMENTS --
THAT MUCH OF THAT FUNDING GOES
INTO DISADVANTAGE IN POOR
COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND IS REALLY MAKING
A DIFFERENCE WITH RESPECT TO AIR
QUALITY AND HEALTH.
AND ALSO SUPPORTING THE REQUESTS
FOR NINETY NINE MILLION WHICH IS
REFLECTIVE OF THE TWO PREVIOUS
YEARS.
FOR THE DERRY METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAMS THERE ARE COUPLE
BENEFITS THAT GO ALONG WITH THAT
THERE'S GHG REDUCTIONS BUT
THERE'S ALSO WATER QUALITY
BENEFITS.
WITH RESPECT TO TERRY DI JESTERS
YOU MIND LAGOONS -- SO WITH THAT
COMES WATER QUALITY BENEFITS AND
ALSO OTHER AIR BENEFITS WITH
RESPECT AMMONIA AND KNOCKS
REDUCTIONS SO THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON KORABL SOME
BEHALF OF CAL START I'D REALLY
LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS --
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
CALLIE T. C. REGARDING C. V. R.
P. AND THEIR COMMENTS ON FUNDING
FOR THAT.
AND IT ALSO REALLY LIKE TO ALIGN
MYSELF.
WITH THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION ABOUT CLEAN TRUCKS
AND BUSES PARTICULARLY THE NEED
FOR LONG TERM FUNDING.
A LOT OF THE BUSINESSES ARE THE
CLEAN VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS ARE
MAKING INVESTMENT DECISIONS ON
FIVE TO SEVEN YEAR CYCLES -- SO
PROVIDING LONGER TERM CERTAINTY
OR MULTI YEAR FUNDING REALLY IT
REINFORCES THEIR ABILITY TO DO
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN OUR IN
D. SO WE CAN GET THESE NEXT
GENERATION CLEAN VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES ON THE ROAD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MADDIE MUNSON ON BEHALF
OF THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO START BY
ALIGNING MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES INTHE AG INDUSTRY IN
SUPPORT OF THE ACT DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT FINDING -- ALSO I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOR HIS CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
DAIRY METHANE PROGRAM IN JUST
UNDER SCORE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THAT PROGRAM.
I'M IN IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE THAT
FUNDING ACTUALLY DOES FIND AN
EQUAL NUMBER OF IT PROJECTS THE
ALL TOO ALTERNATIVE -- ANYWHERE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS IN DERRY
DIGEST YOUR PROJECTS AS IN
PROJECTS GO TOWARDS A SMALLER
DAIRIES AND THEY DIE JUST --
PROJECTS TEND TO FAVOR THE
LARGER DAIRIES THE DYE DRESSERS
DO YOU SEE MORE -- HIGHER
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE BUT BOTH
PROJECTS ARE IMPORTANT -- AND
WE'D ALSO JUST LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE THE CO BENEFITS THAT
THOSE PROJECTS RECEIVE ALSO.
THE INDUSTRY STRONGLY BELIEVES
THAT IF THE FUNDING ISN'T
RESTORED TO THE NINETY NINE
MILLION THAT HAS BEEN THAT WE
WILL NOT SEE THE 40% METHANE
REDUCTION THAT THE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS PLAN IS
CALLING FOR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BINS FOR A MERGER WITH
THE WHITE MAN GROUP HERE ON
BEHALF OF B. Y. D..
ID IS A MANUFACTURER BASED IN
THE LANCASTER AREA AND
HEADQUARTERED IN LOS ANGELES.
HAS HIRED HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE IN
CHURCH LOCATED CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND PROGRAMS WITH
THEIR FOREIGN STRONG SUPPORT OF
INCREASING THE ALLOCATION FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES -- THOSE
VEHICLES HAVE TRANSITIONED FROM
ZERO EMISSION BUSES AND THE
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER INTO.
SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
CONTINUE WITH.
INVESTING IN THESE TECHNOLOGIES
INVESTING IN THAT FOR PROGRESS
SO THAT WE CAN ZERO OUT.
NOT ONLY OUR BUS SECTOR OF OUR
FREIGHT SECTOR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NECKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LAUREN MILITATE
CHECK ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
PISTACHIO GROWERS CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL NBC FARMERS.
AFRICAN AMERICAN FARMERS WESTERN
AND PROCESSORS -- CALIFORNIA
RICE COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
DAIRIES INK -- CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS VARIOUS
OTHER AG AGENCIES -- AND TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS ON BOTH THE DIESEL
ENGINE AND THE DERRY DIE JESTER
AND METHANE -- REDUCTION
PROGRAMS FIRST WE'D LIKE TO
LINER AT REQUEST FOR TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE ACT DIESEL
REPLACEMENT ENGINE WITH THE AIR
DISTRICTS -- THE PROGRAMS OF THE
DISTRICTS ARE DOING THE FARMER
PROGRAM AND OTHERS ARE HIGHLY
VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL THEY'RE
DOING GREAT WORK IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
THEY IT'S VERY OVERSUBSCRIBED
AND SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN
SAID BUT WAS DISCUSSED IN HERE
IS THAT BESIDES THE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THERE'S ALSO THE
BENEFITS OF GETTING RID OF
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS IN THESE
VERY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SO THESE PROGRAMS NEED TO
CONTINUE AS WELL AS ACHIEVING
OUR GOALS.
UNDER CARBS STATE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN -- AS THE
DERRY DIE JESTERS WE ALSO WANT
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH OTHER --
OF ACT GROUPS TO RESTORE THAT
FUNDING TO NINETY NINE MILLION
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
PROGRAM FOR BOTH ALTERNATIVE IN
YOUR MANAGEMENT.
AND DERRY DIE JESTERS -- THANK
YOU CENTER REQUIRE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ON THAT -- AS BINS
MENTIONED THERE ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS TO THESE
DERRY DIE JESTERS SO I WOULD
COUNTER ANY CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED -- BY OTHERS -- THERE'S
WATER QUALITY BENEFITS
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
CRITERIA POLLUTANT REDUCTIONS --
AND THESE ARE ALL VERY IMPORTANT
AND THEY ARE IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN NON
ATTAINMENT ZONES -- ALSO I'D I
WOULD COUNTER ANYONE WHO SAYS
THAT THE DERRY DIE JUSTER
PROGRAM IS TRYING IS HELPING
PEOPLE GROW THEIR DAIRIES THERE
HAS BEEN CONSOLIDATION IN THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY BUT THAT'S FOR A
WHOLE HOST OF FACTORS MILK
PRICES -- REGULATORY COSTS OTHER
COSTS LIKE THAT SO IT'S IT'S NOT
THAT DAIRY DIE JESTERS OUR
SPRING THAT THERE'S BEEN JUST
CONSOLIDATION IN THE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE OF COST.
LIKE THERE HAVE BEEN IN A LOT OF
OTHER INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- MANUAL WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WOULD SIMPLY
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MY AD
COLLEAGUES.
KENNARD SUPPORTING AN INCREASE
IN THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
CAN YOU MERYL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN THEIR
CULTURE NETWORK WHERE A
COALITION OF THE STATE'S LEADING
SUSTAINABLE AND ORGANIC
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATIONS WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF FORMER MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS.
SO I'LL LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
WHAT MISERY SAID ON HEALTHY
SOILS AND SWEEP AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CAL RECYCLE
WASTE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
I WANT TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS
ON THE JERRY METHANE FRONT -- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF A BUDGET LINE
ITEM FOR THE ALTERNATIVE NOR
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THIS IS THE AMP IS A VERY
POPULAR PROGRAM WITH THE DAIRY
PRODUCERS THAT WE WORK WITH --
MOST ARIES ONLY ABOUT 20% OF THE
STATE'S JERRY'S CAN ACTUALLY DO
A DYING JESTER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T PRODUCE ENOUGH NOR -- TO
JUSTIFY IT NOR DO THEY HAVE THE
CAPITAL TO DO IT I JUST -- SO
THEY MUST DO SOMETHING ELSE IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THEIR METHANE
ISSUES AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING IT --
BUT THE WAY THE AMP FUNDING HAS
HAPPENED IS A CHUNK OF MONEY IS
GIVEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE AND THEY
DISPERSE THE FUNDS TO DIE
GESTURES.
AND FOR AMP AMP IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED ABOUT 20% OF THE
DAIRY METHANE FUNDS HAVE GONE TO
AMP AND AS A CONSEQUENCE WE HAVE
MANY JERRY IS -- THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET INTO THE ALTERMAN OR
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM BECAUSE THERE
SIMPLY ISN'T A FUNDS.
SO -- AMPAS REACH THIRTEEN
COUNTY IS WITH OVER FIFTY
PROJECTS SO FAR -- COMPARED TO
JUST SIX COUNTIES FOR THE DERRY
DIGEST HER PROGRAM -- DIE
JESTERS WORK AGAIN IF YOU CAN
INVEST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
HAVE A MATURE THAT WILL FEED
THEM FOR THE LONG TERM.
OF THE DEER IS THAT WE WORK WITH --
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T USE THAT
PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE A FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND IF
A BUDGET LINE ITEM TO ENDS THE
COMPETITION BETWEEN THE TWO
PROGRAMS THANKS.
AND WITH THAT LAST COMMENT ON
MANURE MANAGEMENT.
WE'LL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING I
DIDN'T REALIZE -- ONE OF THE
ITEMS THAT HAPPENED HASN'T BEEN
BROUGHT UP -- WHEN WE'RE HAVING
OUR DISCUSSION OF CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD BE THE --
THE MANUFACTURERS SALES TAX
EXEMPTION -- BACK FILL OF FORTY
FOUR MILLION IN FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS VAN THE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE COST OF FORTY
EIGHT MILLION FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS FIND AND THE S.
R. A. FEEDBACK -- BACK FEEL
WHICH IS NOW EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF THESE --
FUNDS TO COME OFF THE TOP BEFORE
WE GET TO OUR DISCRETIONARY --
FUNDING AND AND I HAVE SPOKEN
OUT ON THOSE ISSUES.
BEFORE WE WILL BE TAKING THEM
INTO CONSIDERATION SO I JUST.
DIDN'T WANT ANYBODY OUT THERE
SINCE I DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT IT THAT I HAD FORGOTTEN
THAT I HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THAT BUT WITH THAT I'M GOING TO
CLOSE PART.
A AND OPEN UP PART B. AND THIS
WILL BE -- OUR ENERGY RESOURCE
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
BOTH PC.
THE RESTRICTIONS OKAY SO LET'S
BRING UP THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION I APOLOGIZE. TO GO.
TO YEAH.
WE WERE OUT ON THE ROAD ONLY SO
THIS TO DISCUSSION ITEMS TO
DISCUSS ON YOUR AVAILABLE THANKS
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
WE'VE DONE THIS IS AN ISSUE.
FIND OUR OUTLINE THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER [inaudible] SIX EIGHTEEN
OKAY.
THE VOTE ONLY.
RIGHT.
SO IF WE GO THIS IS BUILDING
WHAT.
DID ALL THESE TOGETHER
[inaudible]
GOT. TO THREE THINNING
ADMINISTRATIVE CORE.
WHAT A CONCEPT?
HI THIS IS EIGHT POSITIONS.
LIMITED TERM THREE POSITIONS AND
ONE POINT. FIVE ROUGHLY --
DOLLARS PLEASE A GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS MY
NAME IS BERNARD AS A VETO I AM
THE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
WE HAVE SEVERAL SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS HERE TO PRESENT OUR
REQUEST AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
LET ME BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN STRENGTHENING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CORE.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST A
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND THREE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS CHAIRMAN
AT AS YOU HAVE NOTED.
THIS IS A A HIGHLIGHT.
THE STAFF.
COMMENTS THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE CPC HAVE EXPANDED OVER THE
YEARS AS A RESULT OF THE
MANDATES PROGRAMS AND GOALS.
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF HAVE NOT.
GROWN IN HARMONY WITH THE
EXPANSION THEREFORE WE ARE
REQUESTING THIS AUGMENTATION TO
PROVIDE THE CPUC WITH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S SUBCOMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS AND HAVE PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST.
WE WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS I MEAN THE APPY TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS ON THIS
PROPOSAL.
OKAY -- CONCERNS I GUESS YOU
KNOW WHAT THE QUESTIONS IS THE
THE AUDITORS -- SUGGESTS THAT
YOUR PUBLIC RECORDS.
HAVE BEEN.
NUMEROUS EVENTS X..
SOME MIGHT SAY HAVE EXPLODED
OVER THE LAST -- RECENT YEARS
BUT WE DIDN'T GET THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT WERE USED T GETTING
ON ON HOW MUCH THAT.
IS PROCESSED AND WHAT'S THE
BACKLOG IN AND WHY THE THE P.
WISE THAT YOU WOULD NEED I THINK
THAT'S THE THE CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE IT'S NOT THAT.
BAD ON THE NATURAL I WOULD THINK
THAT YES YOU WOULD BE YOU HAVE
MORE PUBLIC RECORDS.
SOME PEOPLE TO FULL TIME JOB BUT
WE JUST DIDN'T GET THE DETAILS.
THAT WOULD NORMALLY GET.
ITS CHAIRMAN WILL BE HAPPY TO
SUPPLY THAT IN WRITTEN FORM.
OKAY LOOK AT IT THE SUGGESTION
IS GONNA HOLD THE MATTER OPEN SO
WE CAN GET THAT THIS WEEK AS THE
BUDGET GETS DEVELOPED -- THIS IS
A QUESTIONS OF THE MEMBERS THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN [inaudible]
MATTER.
AND WITH THAT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN I'LL HAVE
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON ALL THE
YOU SEE.
OLD OPEN MATTERS.
AT THE END OF THIS IS.
IF I COUNT RIGHT [inaudible]
YOU HAVE. TO MANY.
FOLKS UNDER S. B..
EIGHT FIVE NINE AND A HALF UNDER
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND A
B. TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN AND TWO
AND A HALF PEOPLE IN THEIR AB.
THIRTY THREE IN AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS YOUR
EXTENDED ENERGY THE VISION
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE ENERGY.
POLICY STATUTE [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
WELCOME THANK YOU -- SCHOLAR I'M
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF ENERGY
DIVISION.
AND YES AND THE OTHER TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGETS THE
P. C. WAS AUTHORIZED TO HIRE A
MADHOUSE LIMITED TERM -- STAFF
TO SUPPORT FIVE STATUTES -- AND
RELATED TO BIO MASS BY METHANE
IN ENERGY STORAGE.
IN THIS BUDGET REQUESTS WERE
PROPOSING TO EXTEND. FIVE OF THE
SIX OF THOSE POSITIONS FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS.
WE HAD TO SPLIT THAT THE
PROGRAMS RESULTING FROM THE
STATUES ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
ONGOING WORK.
BUT RATHER THAN PROPOSING THAT
ANY OF THESE POSITIONS BE MADE
PERMANENT AT THIS TIME -- WE'RE
REQUESTING THE ADDITIONAL
LIMITED TERM FUNDING -- WELL
THESE REALLY EARLY STAGE
PROGRAMS MATURE UNTIL WE HAVE A
SENSE OF WHAT THE STEADY STATE
WORKLOAD IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE
AND HOW MUCH OF THAT WORK IS
OBSERVABLE.
FINALLY WERE ALSO REQUESTING
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
PROCUREMENT OF MODELING IN G. I.
S. SOFTWARE. TO HELP TRACK THE
BIOMASS PROGRAM RESULTS AND
INSURE THAT THE PROGRAM.
IS EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING HIGH
HAZARD ZONE -- FUELS AS REQUIRED
BY THE STATUTE WHEN THE STAFF
REPORT DRAWS OUT -- THE WILLIAMS
LEGISLATION TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN THAT IS SET TO EXPIRE
IT'S THE DRESSES SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS -- YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THE FOR THREE YEARS
WHICH GOES PAST THE LIVES OF THE
BILL GO SIX MONTHS PASSED SO
IT'S SORT OF DO WE GO SIX MUCH
SHORTER SIX MONTHS PAST ITS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO YEAH IT'S
THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND THIS IS THROUGH.
THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY TWO SO YES CORRECT OKAY
[inaudible]
ELIA.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY WE'LL GET A HOLD THAT
MATTER OPENED AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THIS IS THE
INCREASED OVERSIGHT OF NATURAL
GAS POLICY IN RELIABILITY.
I AM GOING TO HAVE TO STEP OUT
FOR JUST A MOMENT SO.
LET'S SEE I WILL TURN TO THE TWO
SENATOR MCGUIRE THIS IS GOING TO
BE. ONE PERMANENT POSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
TURNED OVER THE PCI AND THE ITEM
NUMBER -- TWENTY GOOD AFTERNOON
MY INNER DISMISSED -- MY NAME IS
DOROTHY DUDA AND I AM -- PROGRAM
MANAGER AND ENERGY DIVISION --
THE PC IS REQUESTING ONE
PERMANENT PROGRAM AND PROJECT
SUPERVISOR TO MANAGE INCREASING
GAS RELIABILITY AND POLICY WORK.
ENERGY DIVISION HAS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY OVERALL IN THE
PAST FIVE YEARS IN RESPONSE TO
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF NEW STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
MIDDLE MANAGEMENT SUPERVISORY
STAFF HAS NOT INCREASED AT THE
SAME PACE AS THE EXPERT ANALYSTS
STUFF.
CONSEQUENTLY WE NOW HAVE ONLY
NINETEEN SUPERVISORS MANAGING
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY STAFF WHICH
TRANSLATES TO EIGHT STAFF PURSUE
PROVIDES SIR.
AS COMPARED TO HISTORIC LEVELS
OF FIVE TO SIX HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WHEN WE OPEN
UP THE COMMITTEE SENATOR STERN.
THANK CHAIR -- I JUST WANT.
TO COMMEND THE PC FOR STEP IT UP
AND PUT SOME FORWARD HERE --
WOULD DESPERATELY NEED
[inaudible]
INCREASE CAPACITY.
I KNOW YOU'RE ONLY ASKING FOR
FOR FOR ONE POSITION -- I DID
DID WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE THAT COORDINATION
ACROSS.
THE SORT OF FAIRIES -- SECTORS
LIKE YOU'RE LOOKING AT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY DEMAND RESPONSE AND
THAT INCREASED COORDINATION BUT
SAY SAY THEY WERE. TWO POSITIONS
ARE THREE POSITIONS -- YOU KNOW.
TEN ELEVEN FOLKS WORKING IN THE
PC OVERSEEING THE ENTIRE NATURAL
GAS SECTOR IS IS QUITE A LOT TO
ASK FOR SPACE WHEN WE HAVE.
PIPELINES RUPTURING AND YOU KNOW
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR IMPACTS ON
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS
SO IS THIS GOING.
TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO DO THAT SORT OF
LARGER MARKET OVERSIGHT FUNCTION
OR IS THIS MORE ABOUT -- THE THE
POLICY.
THEY DO THIS SORT OF AROUND
EFFICIENCY IN THE MAN RESPONSE
LIKE I HOW HOW BROAD IS THE
PURVIEW HERE I GUESS OF THIS
ENHANCED CAPACITY.
WELL T ANSWER THE QUESTION YOU
YOU YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT THERE
THERE IS A STAFF OF ELEVEN ABOUT.
FIVE OR SIX OF THE FOLKS ARE
HANDLING -- GAS COSTS AND RATES
ISSUES AND THE REMAINDER ARE
WORKING ON BIO METHANE GAS
STORAGE AND RELIABILITY TOPICS
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE CORE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
SO WE HAVE SOME -- OTHER --
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS GOING
THROUGH TO INCREASE THE BIO
METHANE SO THE STAFF MAY
ACTUALLY BE GROWING DEPENDING ON
THE OUTCOME OF THE OTHER BCP'S --
AND SO WE ARE CONSTANTLY LOOKING
AT HOW WELL HOW TO GROUP OUR OUR
STAFF OVERALL IN THE DIVISION SO
SO EVEN IF WE GET THIS POSITION
WE MIGHT STILL HAVE TO RETHINK.
MOVING A GROUP OR TO TO HAVE
BETTER COORDINATION WITH --
DEPENDING ON THE TOPIC OF THE
POLICY.
IT WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU ALL ON THAT AND FOLLOW UP
THERE BECAUSE WE WANT TO REALLY
ROBUST.
ARCHITECTURE THE PC ON THIS
FRONT IT'S A IT'S A HUGE ISSUE
AND YOU KNOW IT COULD BE A MAJOR
COST GOING FOR IF WE DON'T.
GET ON TOP OF SOME OF THESE
ISSUES NOW SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
ADDED ASSETS IN THE SYSTEMCOST
BEING PANCAKES ON RATEPAYERS IN
THE ELECTRIC RATES FROM THE GAS
SIDE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION IS
AND WILL BE FOLLOWING UP.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
IN ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP FOR ANY
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
ON THE PROGRAM AND PROJECT
SUPERVISOR.
I SEE NO PUBLIC COMMENT WE LIKE
TO BE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
FINAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
IS THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE.
THE THE MOTION BY SINISTER.
JAMES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- CASKEY
JONES WIRE HI BONNIE.
STERN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN TO ALLOW
THE CHAIR TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON
AND WHEN HE RETURNS THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FAVORITES ARE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWENTY ONE
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE SAFETY
ADVOCATE.
AND THEY'RE SUCH A TOR.
THIRTY WE WELCOME YOU COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M CHRIS PARKS DIRECTOR OF THE
PC'S OFFICE OF THAT SAFETY
ADVOCATE.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS OSA A BRIEF
BACKGROUND OF OSA AT THE END OF
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
SP SIXTY TWO THE US TO CREATING
P. UC CODE. THREE OH NINE DIED
H. ESTABLISHING AND DIRECTLY NO
ESSAY TO AMONG OTHER THINGS AND
RECOMMEND IMPROVEMENTS TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES SAFETY MANAGEMENT CITY
COLTRANE INFRASTRUCTURE.
RECOMMEND IMPROVEMENTS TO THE C.
PIECE PHOEBE UC'S OWN SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SAFETY CULTURE AND
ITS OVERSIGHT OF UTILITIES AND
THEN ADVOCATE AS A PARTY IN
PROCEEDINGS TO ASSIST THE
COMMISSION IN ITS.
EFFORTS TO HOLD PUBLIC UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR SAFE
OPERATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR SAY
RECOMMENDED ADVOCATED AND
PROMOTED SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS OVER A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF UTILITY PROGRAMS
INCLUDING ELECTRIC FIRE.
GAS PIPELINE TO GAS STORAGE -- I
JOINED THE OSA APPROXIMATELY TWO
YEARS AGO WITH A SENIOR ENGINEER
HAS ESTABLISHED IN -- THE FIRST
PERMANENT STAFF OF OSA.
AS OF MONDAY NEXT WEEK WE WILL
NOW BE UP TO A TOTAL OF FOUR
SENIOR ENGINEERS AND THREE
SENIOR ANALYST APPROXIMATELY
THIRD STAFF ARE LOCATED IN EACH
OF THE PC'S.
SACRAMENTO LA AND SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICES.
YOU SEE THREE OH NINE DIED EIGHT
INCLUDES A SON CLASSIC CLAUSE OF
JANUARY FIRST.
TWO TWENTY TWENTY THE THE END OF
THE CHER AND LESS -- SO THAT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REQUESTS OF TESTS
AND SAID BE REMOVED TO PROVIDE
CLARITY FOR CURRENT STAFF AND
PROTECT HIS.
PROSPECTIVE STAFF AS A WAS A
PLAY AND SING CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD IN ITS WORK TO FILL THE
LEGISLATURE'S VISION WHEN IT
ESTABLISHED A LET'S SAY -- I'M
IN THE MIDDLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WORK WITH ACCURACY
PLAYED ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON THIS ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE SINISTER.
VERY BRIEFLY -- THE
RECOMMENDATION TODAY IS --
REJECTION WITHOUT PREJUDICE BUT
I I WAS SORT OF WANT TO
REITERATE.
THAT THAT WITHOUT PREJUDICE
POINT POINT IS -- IS DOUBLY
EMPHASIZED BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA SEE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR WORKING
WITH -- THAT MY CENTER TO THE
NORTH WHO WENT THROUGH THE SAN
BRUNO EXPLOSION IN US DOWN ONLY
SO CANYON THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING TO
BE AN INTERPRETER IMPLIED TODAY
THAT WE'RE NOT.
LIKE IS.
KEENLY -- INVESTED IN THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO I JUST
WANTED TO TO REITERATE EMPHASIZE
THAT -- VERY SUPPORTER OF THE
OSA AND WE'RE HOPING ACTUALLY
BEEF IT UP FURTHER -- AS WE GO
FORWARD -- TO AVOID FUTURE SUCH
INCIDENTS OF THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR.
MRS CENTER WOULD LIKE YOU TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS PLEASE ESCORTED FROM
THE FINANCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- MATH MASUDA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- WILL FINANCE
AGREES THAT GOING THROUGH THE
POLICY BILL PROCESS WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THE SAME GOAL OF
REMOVING THE SUNSET DATE WE
BELIEVE THAT -- THE TRAILER REAL
PROCESS IS THE MORE APPROPRIATE
MECHANISM BECAUSE SPECIFIC
POSITIONS ARE PROPOSED -- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- FOR THE
OFFICE OF SAFETY ADVOCATE NOTES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A GREAT
CLOSER ANYTHING ON THE FROM THE
LA ON THIS ISSUE. NINE INNING BE
FROM THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO GET THAT OPEN UP ISSUE
TWENTY ONE ON THE OFFICE OF THE
SAFETY ADVOCATE.
ADVOCATES TO THE PUBLIC ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
LAST CALL WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BETTER BRING IT BACK. TO
COMMITTEE.
LOOK I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE AND
THIS ONE IS THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BE A I JUST HAD A PROPOSAL IN
GREAT RESPECT -- WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCING
MINISTRATIONS COMING FROM AND I
KNOW THIS IS GOING TO BE --
INITIAL DISCUSSION IN THE MONTHS
TO COME AND YOU WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO PC OF FURTHER WORK
IN A SPECIFIC AREA.
AT THIS TIME -- THERE IS GOING
TO NEED TO BE A MOTION TO BE A
PROJECT PROPOSAL WITHOUT
PREJUDICE TO ANY MEMBERS --
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
A MOTION PLEASE SOME OF WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR STERN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I KELSEY JONES REQUIRE HI
MORNING.
IT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE TO BE ABLE TO REJECT
APPROVALS WITHOUT PREJUDICE AND
WE'LL HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION WHEN KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN AT THIS POINT.
ALLOW THE CHAIR TO ADD ON THERE
IS THE COMMITTEE WERE NOW MOVING
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY TWO FOCUSING
ON WILDFIRE PREVENTION IN THE
COVERING AND SP -- NINE OH ONE
WONDERING IF THE PC HAS BROUGHT
LUNCH AT ALL -- IS WE ARE
GETTING A ONE O'CLOCK SO.
MY CAR [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
CONSIDER IN THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME WORKING COMMITTEE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THOMAS LEE PALMER AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
INCREASINGLY DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES THAT THREATEN THE
LIVES AND PROPERTY OF ITS
CITIZENS.
SB NINE ONE IT'S AN EXPANSE OF
WATER FAR BUILT THAT PRESENTS A
COMPREHENSIVE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RECOVERY PACKAGE
AIMED AT STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO BOTH
MEDICAID AND RECOVER FROM
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
TEMPERAMENT AS BEING ON A ONE
THE PROVISIONS RELATED TO ITS
AUTHORITY.
THE CPC REQUEST SIX POINT SIX
MILLION AND THAT'S B. C. P. FOR
A TOTAL OF THIRTY FOUR PERMANENT
POSITIONS.
AS BEING ON A ONE ESTABLISHES
SEVERAL NEW REQUIREMENTS THAT
WILL RESULT IN MULTIPLE
OVERLAPPING AND CONTINUING
PROCEEDINGS.
THESE PROCEEDINGS WHICH ARE AN
APPLE WHICH OUR ANNUAL
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE THE
DEVELOPMENT AND APPROVAL OF
UTILITY WATER MITIGATION PLANS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
EVALUATION OF THE UTILITY
SUCCESS IN IMPLEMENTING THEIR
PLANS.
EVALUATION OF UTILITY COSTS
RELATED TO IMPLEMENTATION OF
WALT FOR MEDICATION MEASURES.
PENALTY ENFORCEMENT PROCEEDINGS
FOLLOWING PLAN ADOPTION.
RECOVERY OF COSTS BECAUSE BY THE
WILD FIRES AND FINANCIAL
REGULATION INCLUDING REVIEW OF
THE UTILITIES ABILITY TO ABSORB
COSTS AND ISSUANCE OF FINANCING
ORDERS ONE COSTS ARE SCRUTINIZED --
I'M AVAILABLE FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE LIKE TO
RECEIVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE THEN
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AN ALLEY -- TO BE
ABLE TO COME IN AS WELL IF THEY
HAVE ANYTHING SINISTER.
FAMOUS SHIRT JUST TRYING TO GET
A GENERAL SENSE OF I I REALLY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS
ON INCREASED THROUGHPUT AND SORT
OF THE SPEED OF OF THE RESPONSE
TIME I KNOW THAT'S BEEN SORT OF
AN ONGOING ISSUE RIGHT IN TERMS
OF DEALING THE CLAIMS PROCESS
AND GET INTO.
THE KENNEDYS ROOT CAUSE ANALYSES
AND ALWAYS SO.
HIS SENSE JUST.
HOW MUCH?
FASTER ARE WE GOING TO BE IN
SORT OF ADDRESSING THIS STUFF I
KNOW THAT SORT OF A IT'S A HARD
THING TO QUANTIFY BUT IF YOU
SORT OF THOUGHT THEY GIVE SOME
METRICS INTERNALLY WE'RE SAYING.
THIS IS THE THROUGH PUT WE THINK
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS
THIS PUMP.
IT COMPARED TO SORT OF WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH SAY IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS OR SO --
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER WHAT I CAN SPEAK TO ON
THE SAFETY ENFORCEMENT SIDE --
WE HAVE 3% TO STAFF THEY'RE
DEDICATED WILDFIRES FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE HAVE TO
TAP AND OTHER RESOURCES
PRIMARILY OUR ELECTRIC SAFETY
AND RELIABILITY BRANCH AND HAVE
THAT STAFF COVER DOWN ON WILD
FIRE INSPECTIONS INVESTIGATIONS
TO INCLUDE THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN FIRES -- IT JUST IN THE
SAFETY AROUND AND RIGHT NOW I
HAVE NINETEEN OUT OF THIRTY
SEVEN STAFF.
DEDICATED TO SOMETHING WILD FIRE.
THE OTHER STAFF THAT WERE NOT
DESIGNED OR HIRED TO BE DOING
THOSE FUNCTIONS.
WITH THIS B. C. P. COMES THE
CREATION OF THE WATER FAR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH -- SOLE
PURPOSE IT WILL BE TO REVIEW THE
PLANS AND FORCE THE PLANS
CONDUCT THE AUDITS AND CONDUCT
THE INVESTIGATIONS SO WHILE I
CAN'T GIVE AN EXACT TIME OFF
FASTER WOULD GO.
THE BIG CHANGE WITH THIS P. C.
P. IS THERE BE A DEDICATED WORK
FORCE SUGGEST TO THE WILD FIRES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION BUT ONE SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM TWENTY TO TIME.
IS A VERY QUICKLY -- ALLOW FOR
MITIGATION PLAN SO.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE STACKED UP IN
THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT?
SO YOU KNOW YOU'RE SAYING I NEED
TO GET TO GET THROUGH AN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS CORRECT.
YES OKAY WHAT WE HAVE SET UP AND
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE HERE IN THE
FUTURE IN CANDIDATES IS GOING TO
BE ENOUGH.
GOOD.
SO WE ARE THE CURRENT NUMBERS
ARE BASED OFF OF THE ANTICIPATED
WORKLOAD WAS BECAUSE TO BE
HONEST WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE
WERE OFF OUR PLANS WERE GONNA
LOOK LIKE ONCE UTILITY SUBMITTED.
SO THEY WERE SUBMITTED ON
FEBRUARY SIX WE HAVE NINETY DAYS
TO REVIEW AND APPROVE THOSE
PLANS -- THAT'S BOTH YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING FROM S. T. D. TO
LEGAL TO A JAY AND IT ALSO
INCLUDES A GOING TO CAL FIRE FOR
THEIR REVIEW AS WELL.
SO JUST THE PLANS BY THEMSELVES
AS AN EXTREMELY FAST TURN AROUND
THAT IS CONSUMING A LOT OF STAFF
CALORIES TO GET THOSE PLANTS
THROUGH.
THAT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE YEAR TO
YEAR IS JUST GOING TO KEEP ON
COMING EACH AND EVERY YEAR.
SO WITH THAT ANTICIPATED
WORKLOAD BEYOND ONCE THE PLANTS
ARE ACTUALLY APPROVED AND NOW
HAVE TO BE ENFORCED -- THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT GAP.
MY LAST QUESTION AND TURNED BACK
TO THE CHAIR IS JUST.
WHEN YOU SAY ENFORCER YOU'LL
ACTUALLY TAKING IT TALKING ABOUT
SITE VISITS AS WELL -- IN MAKING
SURE WHAT WAS PROMISED IS BEING
CALLED THROUGH PARTS.
YES SEVEN COMBINATION MY PRESS
BEEN ON A ONE WHICH IS A THIRD
PARTY EVALUATOR THAT GOES OUT.
WHICH IS OVERSEEN BY THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION FIFTY
ENFORCEMENT OF ITSELF WOULD DO --
ONSITE INSPECTIONS AND AUDITS OF
THOSE PLANS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS THE THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY ORDER HOW IS
THAT GOING TO AFFECT.
THIS PROCESS.
THE NIGHT A ONE PROCESS.
I DON'T SEE IT AFFECTING THE
NINE ON PROCESS AND THE SENSE OF
THE PLANS BEING APPROVED.
SO IN TERMS OF THAT YOU KNOW IS
LAID OUT THAT WE HAVE NINETY
DAYS TO DO IT AND IT'S THE TOP
PRIORITY OF THE COMMISSION RIGHT
NOW -- AS WELL AS CAL FIRE AS A
WORKING WITH -- YOU KNOW HAND IN
HAND ON IT.
SO I I DON'T SEE IT HAVING THAT
BE A FACT [inaudible]
RIGHT IN.
CAN YOU SPEAK FOR A MINUTE ON
THE INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT ON
PUBLIC LANDS SOME WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT WE WANT TO HAVE AN AND
M. O. U. WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE L. M. SO THAT
WE CAN.
WE CAN DO SOME WORK AND AND
OTHER.
COUNTY AGENCIES IN RENO WITH.
THE ON THE PUBLIC LANDS CENTER
WE ONLY HAVE 3% AND IN THAT AT
THE FORCE BUT THERE'S OTHER
PUBLIC LANDS THAT ARE --
AVAILABLE IF THERE'S AGREEMENTS.
OR WILL THERE BE AGREEMENTS I
GUESS THAT'S THE QUESTION.
SO IN TERMS OF OUR AUTHORITY --
AND REGULATING THE I'LL USE --
REGARDLESS OF WHAT LAND THERE ON
WE WE REGULATE THEM WHETHER IT'S
STATE RESOURCES FOR IT TO BE
ALLOWED -- IF A P. JEANNIE LINE
GOES THROUGH YOU'LL BE A LAMB
AND THE O. S. R. A. LANDS AS
WELL THE REGULATION STILL STANDS
OUR STORY STILL THERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OUR OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THIS IS THE THAT'LL LAST OF
THE MATTERS UNDER THE P. U. C.
S. ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO SO
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING.
THIS WILL BE THE PUBLIC HEARING
ON THE MATTER IS THAT HE DID NOT
TAKE A VOTE THAT.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN ISSUE
NUMBER NINETEEN AND AND ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO PLEASE SOMEONE TELL
US WHAT THE NTURE CONSERVANCY
FOR ITEM TWENTY TWO WERE JUST IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE SIX
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
THIRTY FOR POSITIONS THANK YOU.
WHAT THAT WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING -- AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE ON
ITEMS NUMBER. NINE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY I KELSEY HI JONES.
THECLOSER ROLE THE VOTERS FOUR
ZERO THE MATTERS -- THE BUDGET
REQUEST IS APPROVED AND LET'S
OPEN ROLE IN ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE I KELSEY.
HERE HI.
THAT MATTERS -- APPROVED FOR
ZERO WILL CLOSE THE MATTER AND
MOVE ON TO OUR ISSUE NUMBER --
TWENTY THREE THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE [inaudible]
WE HAVE -- MATTERS WITH THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE ONE IS --
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAM TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN WHITE HOUSE KIA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINDA CEREZO AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER ENERGY FOR THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
L. FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE OFFICE
OF REPAIR OF THE KIDS.
ARE WITH ME HERE TODAY IS CHLOE
LUKENS SHE'S THE PROGRAM MANAGER
OVER ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES.
BUT WE ARE REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS TO WORK ON ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK FOCUSES ON
TWO MAIN AREAS.
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING AND
TRANSMISSION PLANNING AND
PERMITTING.
WITH RESPECT TO A MEETING NEW
AND ONGOING WORKLOAD ON
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING WE REQUEST
ONE ENGINEER POSITION.
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING HAS
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED WITH THE
STATE'S GOAL OF INCREASING THE
USE OF RESOURCES THAT CAN
CONNECT DIRECTLY TO THE
UTILITIES DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS
SUCH AS STORAGE.
SOLAR.
AND ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
NEW PROCESSES HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO ALLOW FOR
VISIBILITY INTO THE UTILITIES
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS.
AND BROADER PARTICIPATION AND
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING.
HE DID THIS OFFER IS IDENTIFYING
WHERE BEST TO INTERCONNECT ON
THE SYSTEMS.
WHILE ENSURING SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF COMMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT THE DISTRIBUTION
PLANNING.
IS AN ANNUAL AN ON GOING PROCESS
THAT ENTAILS REVIEW AND
ASSESSMENT OF COMPLEX TECHNICAL
DATA WHICH WE MUST ANALYZE IN
ORDER TO ENSURE A REPAIR
INTERESTS ARE CONSIDERED. FOR
EXAMPLE EVERY YEAR EACH UTILITY
WILL FILE A REPORT THAT PROVIDES
AN ASSESSMENT OF THEIR SYSTEMS
CAPACITY.
THEY WILL ALSO PROVIDE FORECASTS
OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND ON THEIR
SYSTEMS AND IDENTIFY AREAS THAT
REQUIRE UPGRADES OR OTHER
CHANGES.
UTILITIES ALSO FAR REPORTS THAT
IDENTIFY SYSTEM UPGRADES AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION NEEDS.
THAT COULD BE DEFERRED WITH
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
WE REVIEW ALL THIS INFORMATION
FOR ACCURACY AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE UTILITIES PLANTS
AFFECTIVELY ENSURE RELIABILITY.
AS WELL AS OUR COST EFFECTIVE.
THE ENGINEERING POSITION WILL
ENABLE US TO ADDRESS THIS NEW
WORKLOAD.
I'D LIKE TO SWITCH OVER THE
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE --
WE ALSO ARE REQUESTING ONE
ENGINEERING POSITION AND ONE
ATTORNEY POSITION -- THEY WOULD
FOCUS ON THE INCREASING NUMBER
OF TRANSMISSION PLANNING
ACTIVITIES AND PERMITTING
APPLICATIONS.
ARE ADVOCACY AND TRANSMISSION
ISSUES CAN LOWER COST OF REPAIRS
BY HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AND THE LAST TWO YEARS THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF PROPOSALS FOR NEW
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
UPGRADES.
THESE PROPOSALS ARE INTENDED TO
ADDRESS RELIABILITY AND SYSTEM
CONGESTION ISSUES WHICH ARISE
FROM THE STATE'S INCREASING
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS INCLUDING --
THE ABILITY TO EXPORT EXCESS
ENERGY TO OTHER STATES.
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE ENDEAVORS HAVE
UTILITIES TYPICALLY REQUEST
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN COST RECOVERY FROM REPAIRS.
LOOK AT THE GATES OFFICE IS
OFTEN THE ONLY PARTY ASIDE FROM
THE UTILITY PARTICIPATING IN
THESE PROCEEDINGS.
OUR PARTICIPATION IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE CONDUCT COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSES INSURE THAT THE
PROJECTS ARE NEEDED.
THAT THE COSTS ARE REASONABLE
AND WHERE POSSIBLE WE IDENTIFY
MORE COST EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES.
THE STAFF COMMENTS CORRECTLY
NOTE THAT THIS IS ONGOING AND
INCREASING WORK. FOURTEEN NEW
APPLICATIONS FOR TRANSMISSION
UPGRADES OR NEW CONSTRUCTION ARE
EXPECTED TO BE FILED BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR.
THIS IS ON TOP OF THE
APPLICATIONS FILED LAST YEAR
THAT ARE STILL BEING LITIGATED
OUT THE CPUC.
IN ADDITION THE UTILITIES WILL
FOLLOW ADVICE LETTERS FOR
SMALLER TRANSMISSION PROJECTS
WHICH WAS ALSO ANALYZE.
OUR REQUEST FOR THESE THREE
POSITIONS ON INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
ALLOW US TO ADDRESS THIS
INCREASED WORKLOAD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE I GUESS MAYBE CAN
YOU CLARIFY THAT.
I'M PRESUMING IF THE I. O. YOU
PASS FOR SUBMITS AN ADVICE
LETTER THAT'S LESS ANALYSIS FOR
AN ENGINEER -- FOR AN ATTORNEY
TO DO VERSUS A FULL.
BLOWN HEARING -- THAT THEY HAVE
IS THAT IF MY MISSING THE POINT
HERE IN SOME CASES THAT IT THAT
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN TRUE BUT
RECENTLY WE HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
LARGER PROJECTS THROUGH THE
ADVICE LETTER PROCESS WHICH
REQUIRES MORE COMPLEX ANALYSIS.
THAT IS NOT WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THIS PROJECT SHOULD BE SUBMITTED
THROUGH THE ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS AND WE HAVE PROTESTED
USING THAT PROCEDURE VEHICLE
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
NO CONCERNS [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS ON THIS WILL GET A
HOLD IT OPEN -- AND WE'LL
CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSIONS LET'S
GO TO A S. B. NINE A ONE THE
FOURTEEN POSITION SHE WON FOR
THE S. B. NINE A ONE BEFORE I
BEGIN. TO INTRODUCE THIS REQUEST
I WANT TO INTRODUCE THAT SKINNER
HE'S A SUPERVISOR OVER SAFETY
SECTION.
IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WE PUT
WE REQUEST FOURTEEN NEW
POSITIONS TO HELP IMPLEMENT THE
WILD FIRE SAFETY AND WELFARE
COST RECOVERY PROVISIONS OF SB.
NINE OH ONE THIS BILL INSTITUTED
SIGNIFICANT NEW AND ONGOING
REQUIREMENTS UPON THE SIX
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY ELECTRIC
UTILITIES.
THE NEW REQUIREMENTS ARE IN TWO
MAIN AREAS.
WILDFIRE RISK MITIGATION AND
WHILE FOR COST RECOVERY IN
SECURITIZATION.
EACH OF THESE EFFORTS HAVE
STATUTORY STATUTORILY MANDATED
TIME LINES AND FREQUENCY THAT
REQUIRE US TO INCREASE OUR
STAFFING SO THAT WE CAN.
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF REPAIRS TO
OBTAIN THE LOWEST POSSIBLE RATE.
FOR SERVICE CONSISTENT WITH
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY.
TURNING FIRST TO THE WILD FIRE
RISK MITIGATION.
WE HAVE REQUESTED FIVE NEW
POSITIONS TO REPRESENT
RATEPAYERS.
OF FOCUS ON WELFARE MITIGATION
PLAN PROCEEDINGS.
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
WILL BE PARTS PARTICIPATING IN A
MINIMUM OF TWELVE NEW
PROCEEDINGS EVERY YEAR.
A NEW POSITIONS WE REQUEST WILL
PROVIDE US WITH THE RESOURCES
THE THOROUGHLY AND COMPLETELY
EVALUATE THE PLANS TO ENSURE
THAT REPAIR INTERESTS ARE
PROTECTED.
TURNING NOW TO THE WORKS OF ART
THERE.
WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT FIRE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO COME IN AND
FORCE MANAGEMENT PEOPLE AND
TEMPER PEOPLE THOSE EXPERTS THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW A FIRE IS
MANAGE.
I'M A LAWYER.
I ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW I MEAN I'M
I KNOW ON THE CHAIR THIS
COMMITTEE I ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND I READ THE REPORT
WHAT WILL YOUR FIVE PEOPLE DO.
WHAT WOULD YOU WHAT ONE OF FIRE
MITIGATION HOW WITH THE PEEL
AWAY KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
THE OTHER THAN LEARNING AS YOU
GO?
THIS IS [inaudible]
WHAT WHAT [inaudible]
BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
COME IN WITH THE TECHNICAL
ANSWERS.
ANY ISSUE ARE YOU GONNA SAY
THAT'S TOO MUCH MONEY FOR THE
REPAIRS TO PAY OR WE DON'T WANT
TO PAY THAT.
VERSES JUST WHETHER IT DOES THE
THE MEDICATION OR NOT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WIFI POSITIONS I MEAN.
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT WE I I GET
NICE I'LL SAY I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
IT RIGHT WHATEVER IT IS I WOULD
LOOK AT THE SCIENCE THAT THEY
COULD COME UP WITH.
HOW DO YOU ENVISION THOSE WITH
THOSE PEOPLE WOULD DO AND JUST
THE MEDICATION THE OTHER PART?
I GET A PAT ON THE MEDICATION
WHICH IS A TECHNICAL
[inaudible]
FORESTRY SCIENCE.
WHAT IS A REPAIR ADVOCATE?
AND IT'S TOO MUCH THE SICKEST
MARKET MY QUESTION I DON'T LIKE
TO PAY THAT BILL.
OKAY WELL I THINK THE PEOPLE GET
IT NOT LIKE IT IT'S DOES IT WORK
OR DOES IT NOT WORK.
THE TRAINING.
NOW.
WHO THESE PEOPLE BE?
THE QUESTION IS WE'RE GONNA HOLD
IT I'M JUST THROWING IT OUT
THERE IF YOU.
DON'T FEEL COMPELLED TO ANSWER
IT NO WHAT WE REVIEW IN THESE
PROCEEDINGS IN MATTERS OF SAFETY
CHAIRMAN IS WE LOOK AT THE
ADEQUACY OF THE UTILITY FILING
ARE THEY TAKING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THESE EXPERTS.
IN FORESTRY AND WILD FIRE WE
HAVE OUR OWN SAFETY PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXPERTS IN A VARIETY OF
SAFETY TOPICS ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT THESE ARE INTENDED TO
INCREASE.
IS EXACTLY IN THE AREAS OF FIRE
SAFETY COVERED CONDUCTOR WEATHER
MONITORING FORECASTING -- A
VARIETY OF TOPICS AND ISSUES
THAT REALLY EXACTLY TO
PREVENTING CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES.
WE RECENTLY REVIEWED THE
UTILITIES FILINGS IN THEIR
TWENTY NINETEEN WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
AND ONE OF THE CONSISTENT THEMES
THAT WE IDENTIFIED AND WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING WITH THE OTHER
PARTY SAID THAT TO DATE.
WE ARE THE ONLY PARTY THAT IS
HOLISTICALLY INCONSISTENTLY
EXAMINED THE ADEQUACY OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
AT THE PROGRAMMATIC LEVEL -- SO
FOR EXAMPLE DO THE UTILITIES
ACTUALLY KNOW HOW MUCH RISK WILL
BE REDUCED ARE THEY ACTUALLY
PUTTING THESE PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS.
IN THE HIGH THREAT FIRE AREAS
IDENTIFIED BY CAL FIRE ARE THEY
GOING OUTSIDE OF THOSE AREAS IF
THEY ARE GOING OUTSIDE OF THOSE
AREAS WHY.
SO IT'S NOT AT THIS POINT IT'S
NOT LOOKING AT THE MONEY THERE'S
ALWAYS OF COURSE ARE YOU DOING
IT EFFICIENTLY BUT THIS IS ARE
YOU DOING IT IN THE RIGHT AREAS.
THAT WILL ADEQUATELY REDUCE RISK.
LEO DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT THIS
ON THE NOVELTY OF THE STAFF
REPORT TALKS ABOUT THE NOVELTY
OF THIS.
NEW.
ARENA WE'RE GETTING ON WITH THE
PLO.
I'M A WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR COMMENTS I MEAN I I
THINK YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WAS
SORT OF THE NEW ACTIVITIES THERE
WILL LIKELY NEED TO BE SOME KIND
OF YOU KNOW NEW EXPERTISE THAT
KIND OF GES INTO.
A SIGN IN THE RIGHT POSITIONS ON
RIGHT PEOPLE TO THAT THAT
ACTIVITY.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED OKAY.
I'M GONNA GET TO THE SECOND AREA
OF OUR OUR SAFETY BCP -- AND
THAT IS THE FOCUS ON WELFARE
COSTS AND SECURITIZATION.
OF WHERE WE ARE ASKING FOR FIVE
POSITIONS AS WELL -- WE ARE
REQUESTING THESE POSITIONS TO
CONDUCT FINANCIAL ECONOMIC AND
POLICY ANALYSIS OF THE
REASONABLENESS OF THE UTILITY
COSTS REQUEST.
IN REVIEWING P. GENIES WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN WE'VE IDENTIFIED
EXTENSIVE OVERLAP WITH THE
PROPOSALS PRESENTED IMPEACHING
NEEDS TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL RATE
CASE APPLICATION.
NOT ONLY FROM A PROGRAMMATIC
LEVEL AND A PROJECT BASIS BUT
ALSO FROM A COST BASIS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
SCRUTINIZE THE UTILITIES
PROPOSALS TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
COSTS ARE REASONABLE.
AND THAT THEY ARE NOT SEEKING
COST RECOVERY FOR THE SAME
PROGRAMS IN DIFFERENT
PROCEEDINGS.
THE NEW POSITIONS ALSO WILL
PERFORM TH ANALYSIS ASSOCIATED
WITH REPAIR PROTECTION FINANCING.
FINALLY WE HAVE REQUESTED FOR
ATTORNEY POSITIONS TO PROVIDE
LEGAL SUPPORT IN PREPARING
DISCOVERY.
OF LEGAL BRIEFS AND DEALING WITH
THE NECESSARY LEGAL MATTERS TO
SUPPORT OUR OUR POLICY TECHNICAL
EFFORT.
SO LET'S SAY ONE OF THE FOUR
TOURNEY'S DETERMINES THAT THEY
BELIEVE THAT THE THERE -- OVER
SECURED.
THERE'S THEY'RE THEY'RE ASKING
FOR SOME FUNDS TO TO TO DO SOME
WORK AND IT'S A HUNDRED DOLLARS
OF WORK TO DO AND THEY'VE GOT AN
ASSET WORTH A THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THEY WANT TO SECURE THE
PAYMENT OF THAT [inaudible]
SO WHAT [inaudible]
WHAT?
IT'S A SECURE IT'S ONLY SECURED
TO THE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
WHAT DIFFERENCE WOULD IT MAKE
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE?
IT WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE. TO
THE NEXT PERSON WANTS TO SECURE
BECAUSE THEY BE IN SECOND
POSITION THEY WOULD HAVE NOT
HAVE PRIORITY RIGHT BUT AS FAR
AS THE AS AS HOW TO GUARANTEEING
THE REPAYMENT.
OF OF THAT THE MONEY THAT THEY
HAVE.
WHY IT WHY WOULD THE WAY WITH
THE P. YOU SEE NOT BE ABLE TO
FIGURE THAT OUT AND AND A NICE
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW WHAT WOULD WHAT
DO YOU ENVISION THE PA OF?
DOING JUST A KIND OF FIND THAT
THIS IS OVER SECURED.
PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS.
UNDERNEATH SP NINE OH ONE IF
SECURITIZATION OCCURS AND THAT
VALUE IS NOT THE RIGHT VALUE IN
THE CASE THAT YOU PRESENTED.
IT'S A HUNDRED DOLLARS WE KNOW
IT'S A THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S NOT
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC.
IF IT WAS BEFORE AT A THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THEY WANT TO COME IN
FOR ANOTHER.
FIVE HUNDRED WELL THAT BECOMES
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE IF THE EXTRA
FIVE HUNDRED IS MONEY THAT.
IN THE CASE OF UTILITY
WRONGDOING SHAREHOLDERS COULD'VE
ABSORBED AS IS CONTEMPLATED FOR
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES.
ONCE THAT BECOMES SECURED SP
NINE A ONE MEANS THAT EVEN IF WE
INVESTIGATE AND FIND OUT THAT
THE SHAREHOLDERS COULD HAVE AND
SHOULD HAVE PROPERLY BORN THOSE
COSTS.
IT IS NOW PERMANENTLY ASSIGNED
TO RATE PAYERS INTEL THAT
SECURITIZATION HAS BEEN PAID OFF
IN TEN TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD.
SO THAT'S PART OF WHAT OUR
EXAMINATION WOULD BE IS IN THE
CASE OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FIRES HAVE THE UTILITIES BORN
WITH A PROPERLY CANNIBAL MEETING
THE REQUIREMENTS OF S. B. NINE A
ONE AND FOR ANY WILD FIRES THAT
OCCUR BETWEEN.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE WITHOUT AUTHORITY
EXPIRES AGAIN HOW THE RIGHT
AMOUNTS LEVELS BEEN ACHIEVED
BECAUSE THE IS ONCE THE
SECURITIZATION BONDS ARE ISSUED.
WE CANNOT GO BACK AND CHANGE
THEM BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT S. B.
NINE A ONE REQUIRES IS THEIR NON
ALL TROUBLED NON REVOCABLE.
BUT THE REPAIRS WILL ONLY BE ON
THE HOOD HOOK TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S A DEFAULT.
RIGHT YOU NEED TO HAVE TO THE
FALL RIGHT JUST BECAUSE YOU
SECURITIZED IF THE I. O. U.
CONTINUES TO PAY.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT.
THE SECURITIZATION IN ESSENCE
REMOVES FROM THE UTILITIES
CALCULATION THAT DEBT BECAUSE IT
IS ASSIGNED TO RATE PAYERS --
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RECEIVE YOUR
FUNDING ON THE CAMPBELL THE D.
W. R. BONDS ARE STILL SHOWING UP
ON THE PART OF OUR RESOURCES
BONDS FROM THE TWO THOUSAND
BANKRUPTCIES ARE STILL SHOWING
UP AS A LINE ITEM ON UTILITY
BILLS [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE
OFFICE WE HAVE TWO MATTERS ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE ON THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION PROGRAM
ISSUE NUMBER. TWENTY FOUR ON THE
WHEEL WHILE FIRE PREVENTION.
AND RECOVERY WERE.
GOING TO HOLD BOTH BATTERS OPEN.
HI IZABELLA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR WE THANK YOU.
CLOSE TO PUBLIC.
HEARING THANK THE PO A AND MOVE
THE PART C. OF OUR HEARING TODAY
THIS IS.
THE PART WHEN A FORCE AND FIRE
PROTECTION WILDFIRE PREVENTION
RECOVERY [inaudible]
THE LOU OF BILLS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE REPORTER GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN -- TOM
PORTER CAL FIRE -- DIRECTOR.
AND REGARDING -- WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RECOVERY A B. C.
P. YOUR PART SEE ITEM ONE OUR
ISSUE.
ONE CAL FIRE IS REQUESTING --
TEN MILLION DOLLARS GREENHOUSE
GAS FUNDING -- AND TWENTY FOUR
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT -- THE
THE NEW PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE
UNDER S. B. NINE OH ONE THE S.
B..
TWELVE SIXTY AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN AND A B..
TWENTY NINE ELEVEN THE THE A
MEETS THE EYE OF THE REQUESTS OF
CAL FIRE.
AND DUE TO THE LENGTH OF TODAY'S.
HEARING THAT YOU HAD SO FAR --
RATHER THAN -- TRY TO IDENTIFY
ALL OF ALL OF YOUR QUESTIONS IN
MY WRIST OF MY OPENING.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT -- I
ANSWER SPECIFIC QUESTIONS FROM
YOU AND AND YOUR MEMBERS.
ON THE COMMITTEE -- IN TOTAL.
THE CAL FIRE REQUEST EMPHASIZES --
I CONTINUED -- FIREPROOF HEY I
CONTINUED CAPABILITY AND OUR
FIRE PREVENTION SERVICES WITH
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NEEDED
THROUGH THIS REQUEST.
TO FULFILL THE ASPECTS OF THE
FIRE PREVENTION -- THAT WILL BE
NEEDED -- AND MAINTAINED UNDER
THESE PROVISIONS -- AND THOSE
ELEMENTS OF REDUCING -- THE RISK
TO LIFE PROPERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT -- WITH THAT THAT'S
THE CLOSE OF MY OPENING AND I AM.
YEAH.
BACK TO YOU OUR YOUNG.
THIS COMPUTERS WITH A L. A. L..
AND SO A AS YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF BILLS
LAST YEAR THE BUDGET INCLUDES AS
DOCTOR PORTER INDICATED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FRIEND
OF FOUR CAL FIRE.
IT ALSO INCLUDES ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION I'M FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FAN AS
REQUIRED BY S. B..
NINE OH ONE YOU CAN KIND OF
THINK ABOUT THAT AS YOUR YOUR
WHOLE PACKAGE OFFENDING I'M FOR
THIS ITEM.
AND THAT WE WE WOULD KNOW IS
THAT THE BUDGET PROPOSALS ARE
GENERALLY CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATION -- IT HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATION AS IT OFTEN DOES I'M
A YOU KNOW PROVIDES A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION -- TO SET UP AND
ESTABLISH ARE THESE NEW PROGRAMS
IN MANY CASES THESE ARE BRAND
NEW PROGRAMS.
AND SO AND THEN THERE'S
ADDITIONAL DETAILS AND ROOM FOR
OVERSIGHT WE THINK -- WITH THESE
BUDGET PROPOSALS BOTH AND YET
TODAY I KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE
AND YOU KNOW IT BUT THROUGH THIS
BUDGET PROCESS -- AS WELL AS ON
GOING AND SO WE DID HIGHLIGHT
SIMON WHAT WE THINK ARE SOME KEY
OVERSIGHT QUESTION SO.
IF I COULD JUST BRIEFLY GO
THROUGH THEM IN TERMS OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT APPROVING FOR THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
AND WE THINK THAT THERE'S
THERE'S SOME KEY QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THAT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR G. G. R. F. PIECE
HAS TWO COMPONENTS FIRST IS A
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION FOR
FOREST HEALTH.
AND FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS AND
THAT WE'VE HAD TO HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH CAL FIRE ABOUT
HOW THEY PLAN TO ALLOCATE THOSE
GRANT FRIENDS BETWEEN SORT OF
THREE DIFFERENT BUCKETS THERE'S
PROJECTS CAL FIRE IS GOING TO
UNDERTAKE THEMSELVES.
THERE IS -- GRANTS FOR FOREST
HEALTH PROJECTS THESE ARE SORT
OF LARGER AREAS OF LAND WERE
TRYING TO MAKE THE FIRST HEALTHY --
THROUGH A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
THINGS REPLANTING PRESCRIBED
BURNS -- PAST ABATEMENT THAT
SORT OF THING AND THEN THERE'S
THE FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS WHICH
TENDS TO BE MORE AND FUEL BREAKS
OR MAYBE SOME TARGETED I'M FUELS
REDUCTION AROUND COMMUNITIES AND
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS ALL OF THEM ARE
IMPORTANT.
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING HOW THEY'RE
SETTING THOSE PRIORITIES FOR A
HOW MUCH MONEY GOES INTO EACH OF
THOSE BUCKETS WITHIN THAT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
AS WELL AS HOW WITHIN THAT
THEY'RE PRIORITIZING HOUSE THERE --
INSURING THAT DIFFERENT PROJECTS
THAT THEY'RE DOING THROUGH
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ARE BEING
DONE IN A AND A COLLABORATIVE
MANNER TO GET THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK.
THAT'S ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WE
WE HAVE.
YOU HAVE.
NOW SUPERIMPOSES STATE OF
EMERGENCY THE SET CHANGE YOUR
ANALYSIS OF OF THESE THE
DIFFERENT.
CATEGORIES IN OVER SAME MEAN WE
NEED TO GO QUICKLY AND IT'S IN
THE SUMMER TO SEE HOW.
TODAY IS THE WORD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT THAT'S A QUESTION
THAT'S COME UP SINCE YOU KNOW WE
FIRST EVALUATED THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL IS WHERE IS THE FUNDING
GOING TO COME FROM TO TO HANDLE
THAT THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED IN -- WHAT'S BEEN
REFERRED TO AS THE FORTY FIVE
DAY REPORT.
AND AND WILL IT COME FROM.
THE FINDING HERE IT SOUNDS LIKE
SOME OF THEM IS POSSIBLY COMING
FROM FINDING THOSE PROVIDED IN
THE CURRENT YEAR -- WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT HOW THAT RELATES BACK
TO THE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PACKET?
I'M PROBABLY THE FIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS OR THE PROJECTS BEING
DIRECTLY UNDERTAKEN BY CAL FIRE
WOULD BE MORE.
IN LINE SINCE -- I ATE MY
UNDERSTANDING MOST THE PROJECTS
ARE FOCUSED ON ON PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES IN CONSTRUCTING FEEL
BREAKS AND THAT SORT OF THING.
BUT THAT'S CERTAINLY GOOD
QUESTION AS THIS IS SORT OF AN
EVOLVING SITUATION IS HOW HOW
DOES THE CHANGES IN THE CURRENT
YEAR IMPACT THE FINDING THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY AS WELL IS IS IT
REDIRECTING FUNDING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
AND IF SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
FOR A FOR THE FOR FINDING IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY IN NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET YEAR AND SO I
THINK THOSE ARE GOOD QUESTIONS
AND YOU KNOW OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
TO INSURE THAT YOU FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT ONE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CURRENT YEAR
INTO WHAT.
YOU'RE BEING ASKED TO APPROVE --
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY CONTINUE
WHAT YOU'RE.
YOUR THOUGHTS THANK YOU MR
RECORD THEM IS SO THAT THE
SECOND PIECE OF THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS REQUIRED BY
S. B. NINE I WENT IS FOR
PRESCRIBED BURN CRUISE.
SPECIFICALLY THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SO CURRENTLY CAL FIRE
HAS SIX I BELIEVE PRESCRIBED
BURN CRUISE THIS WOULD TAKE THEM
UP TO TEN THAT STARTING IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THESE
DEDICATED PRESCRIBER CREWS ARE
RELATIVELY NEW -- CAL FIRE IS
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
UP IN TRAINING THESE CREWS AND
SO GETTING A SENSE OF HOW THAT
PROCESS HAS GONE AND ARE THERE
LESSONS LEARNED AD AND HOW WHAT
CAN YOU EXPECT IN TERMS OF HOW
QUICKLY THESE CREWS ARE ACTUALLY
TO BE.
ON THE GROUND I'M GETTING WORK
DONE AND WHERE THEY'LL BE
LOCATED IN AND AND HOW THEY'LL
BE PRIORITIZED AND HOW THEY'LL
BE.
AND YOU KNOW HOW THE DEPARTMENT
CAN ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T GET
JUST PULLED INTO FIRE
SUPPRESSION WORK AND AND YOU
KNOW THAT THEY CAN PROTECT THE
MISSION OF THOSE CREWS -- AND SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS I HAVE
ANOTHER ONE FOR THE CURRENT THE
CURRENT.
BUDGET THAT YOU'RE LOOKING ON
THE NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR.
I'M ASKING I KNOW ONE REQUIRES
CAL FIRE TO ESTABLISH A WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PROGRAM SO THERE IS A
FINDING THAT IS INCLUDED AND IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE PROGRAM AND
AND AND BLINKING ON THE AMOUNT
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE.
AND BY PROGRAM BUT IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
SERVED.
PACIFIC STAFFING LEVELS THAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED AS WE THINK
THERE'S SOME SOME OVERSIGHT
QUESTIONS THERE JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT WHAT'S BEEN
APPROVED AND THE LEVEL AND THAT
THAT PROGRAM IS BEING INITIATED
THAT REALLY MATCHES WITH WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT WAS.
IN REQUIRING THEM TO CREATE THIS
PROGRAM AND THIS IS SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM THE PRESCRIBED
BURN OR THE HEALTHY -- FORCE
THIS IS THE RESILIENCE PIECE OF
CORRECT IN THIS PROGRAM IS
ESSENTIALLY I AM AT THE SET UP
AND I CAN LET THE MINISTRATION
SPEAK TO IT BETTER -- BUT TO TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
SMALLER LANDOWNERS -- AND HELP
THEM SORT OF THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS SO IT'S IT'S
ANOTHER PIECE OF SORT OF
SUPPORTING THAT BIGGER PICTURE
BUT IT IS A SEPARATE PEACE AND
AND SO THAT THE BUDGET INCLUDES
FUNDING AND STAFFING TO GET THIS
PROGRAM OFF THE GROUND BUT IT'S
A LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR WHY.
THAT LEVEL AND EXACTLY HOW MANY
LANDOWNERS DUE TO THE ENVISION
BEING ABLE TO HELP AND AND
WHAT'S THE MAGNITUDE OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THEY FEEL.
THEY CAN PROVIDE AND AND HOW
MIGHT THAT AFFECT OUTCOMES -- OF
THE PROGRAM AND SO THERE'S
PROBABLY SOME MORE ROOM THERE
FOR YOU TO GET INFORMATION ON
THAT AND MAKE SURE JUST LINES UP
WITH IS THIS WHAT YOU THOUGHT
YOU WERE PROVING WHEN YOU PASSED
AS BEING I KNOW.
ONE AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
NEAR TERM QUESTIONS WE HAVE SOME
THAT RELATE TO TO SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS TO AND AND
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES IN THE
UTILITY SIDE BUT I WON'T GO INTO
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT PART OF
THIS ITEM.
AND WE ALSO THINK THAT THIS AND
THIS TOPIC AND JUST OVERSIGHT OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE A LOT OF LONG TERM
OVERSIGHT.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IT
AS BEING I NO ONE IN PARTICULAR
IS YOU NOW IS FOCUSING ON FOREST
HEALTH FORSTER BECOME HEALTHY IN
ONE BUDGET YEAR THEY DON'T
BECOME HEALTHY FROM ONE
APPROPRIATION OF FINES OR WHEN
GRANT CYCLE.
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO TAKE --
A VERY LONG TIME AND SO I WE DO
HE WE DO HIGHLIGHT SAM SAM --
QUESTIONS OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
FOR YOU THERE AND HOW IS THE
ADMINISTRATION MEASURING
OUTCOMES.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR FORESTS
HEALTHIER AT HOW HOW DO YOU
DEFINE WHEN THEY'RE HEALTHY.
AND AND HOW RE MEASURING
OUTCOMES HARRY MEASURING
OUTCOMES OVER TIME IS -- WAITED
YOU KNOW LINK BACK TO MAKING OUR
FIRST HEALTHIER WITH WILD FIRES
BEING LESS SEVERE AND THESE ARE
NOT EASY THINGS AND TO BE ABLE
TO TRACK THE OUTCOME SIGNED
THERE'S NO OBVIOUS -- WAY TO DO
IT BUT THAT SOMETHING THAT OVER
TIME WE THINK YOU'RE GONNA WANT
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPRESS
ADMINISTRATION ON IN QUESTION.
HOW ARE WE DOING THIS TO ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDS ARE BEING USED
EFFECTIVELY -- THE SIMILAR LIVE
THERE BEING FUNDS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED TO THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY AREAS AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE HAVE SEVERE
VIRUS.
I'M NOT LOOKING INTO ARE THERE
BARRIERS TO CAMP. TO COMPETING
I'M SORRY TO COMPLETING ANY OF
THESE PROJECTS AND WE'VE HEARD.
ANECDOTALLY A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT WORK FORCE BEING
INSUFFICIENT THAT THERE'S NOT
EVEN WHEN YOU START GIVING OUT
THE GRANTS THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH AND YOU KNOW -- QUALIFIED
CONTRACTORS OUR LABORS TO
ACTUALLY DO THIS WORK I AND THAT
AT SOME POINT ARE WE GONNA RUN
INTO THAT AS A BEER YOU'RE INTO
THAT SORT OF AN ON GOING LONGER
TERM QUESTION.
I'M A FOUR FOUR WE THINK FOR YOU
TO ASK THE MINISTRATION.
I'M AND THEN OUT COMES FROM
TIMBER HARVESTING AND EXEMPTIONS
AND OUTCOMES FOR PRESCRIBED
BURNS AND AND WE HAVE WE HAVE
OTHER QUESTIONS HERE BUT THAT
JUST GIVES YOU KIND OF A FLAVOR
THAT.
REALLY YOU THERE'S A LOT OF
DETAIL THAT YOU MAY WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU APPROVE
THESE NINETEEN TWENTY PROPOSALS
AND THEN THAT'S SORT OF NOT THE
END OF IT THEY'RE STILL A WHOLE
LOT OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
I'M IN YOUR ONGOING OVERSIGHT OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PACKAGE.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
WORK FORCE THAT I KNOW PART OF
THE EMERGENCY ORDER WAS FIFTY
MILLION FOR PUBLIC OUT REGION
AND MODERNIZATION?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS
FEBRUARY I I THINK I KNOW WHAT
IT IS BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT.
SPECIFIC WOULD BE WITH IS THAT.
PART OF THE THE OVERSIGHT WE
SHOULD HAVE ALSO AS FAR AS WHAT
THAT WOULD BE A WITH THAT
MODERNIZATION.
AND SURE I MEAN I THINK TO THE
EXTENT THAT AS PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND IS PART OF
THE FORTY FIVE DAY REPORT.
I'M THE ADMINISTRATION IS EITHER
AND READ DIRECT STAYING UP FOR
AND MAYBE REFOCUSING FRIENDS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
AND THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY WANT TO
BE ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S HAPPENING
YOU KNOW THE THE THE FUNDS THAT
WERE PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET WERE PROVIDED FOR
SPECIFIC PURPOSE AND SO
UNDERSTANDING IF THERE'S CHANGES
THERE AND AND TO WHAT EXTENT
THOSE ARE BEING MADE AND AND
WHAT.
EXACTLY IS BEING DONE I THINK IS
AND ENTIRELY CLEAR AND SO THOSE
ARE DEFINITELY I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF QUESTIONS AND THAT STILL
REMAIN REGARDING THAT.
THE EMERGENCY ORDER AND THE
FORTY FIVE DAY REPORT AND
EXACTLY HOW THAT'S GOING TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED AND HOW THAT
AFFECTS BOTH YOUR CURRENT YOUR
BUDGET AND THAT.
NINETEEN TWENTY FINANCE GOOD
BEFORE WE GET BACK TO THE DOCTOR
A PORTER.
ALLISON YOUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT WANT TO JUST MAKE
ONE CLARIFICATION ON THE FIFTY
MILLION THAT.
AND I WANT TO ALSO DEFER TO MY
COUNTERPARTS ON THAT CAL O. YES
ASSIGNMENT OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES SO THAT THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS PROVIDED.
FOR HELLO YES PART OF THE AND
AND THEY'LL BE SOME
COLLABORATION WITH CALIFONE
TEARS AS WELL BUT SO THEY THEY
WOULD BE THE TRUE EXPERTS AND
WE'D BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THAT
BUT THERE WAS FUNDING ALLOCATED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
I'M FOR THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
DESCRIBED HOWEVER IN TERMS OF
ANY REDIRECTION OF RESOURCES I
DO WANT TO DEFER TO THEM -- I
CAN SPEAK MORE WE CAN SPEAK MORE
TO THE CAL FIRE PIECE OF THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL -- BUT DO YOU
WANT TO JUST SAY IN TERMS OF
THAT A SPECIFIC DOLLAR AMOUNTS --
AND THAT SORT OF STATEMENTS
AROUND THAT THAT WOULD BE IN FOR
OUR GUESTS THE DIRECTOR PORTER
WHERE WE'VE GOT A SUGGESTION
THAT THE WORK FORCE OF WE GIVE
WE GIVE MONEY TO WHICH I'VE BEEN.
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT GETTING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR INVOLVED IN DOING
SOME OF THE THE WORK ON THE IN
THE FORCE THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH.
LUMBERJACKS OUT THERE I DON'T
THINK IT'S CALLED LUMBERJACKS
NOW BUT WHATEVER THEY'RE CALLED --
AND RELATED TO THAT -- WE WE
HAVE NOT YET.
COME TO A POINT WHERE WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE THE FOREST WORKERS
WITH THE GRANT PROGRAMS THAT WE
CURRENTLY -- ARE ARE PUTTING OUT --
ON THE GROUND AND SO THAT WOULD
BE THE THE GREENHOUSE GAS AND
THEN PREVIOUS TO THAT THE S. R.
S. R. A. -- FOR FUND THAT YOU
WERE MENTIONING EARLIER -- THIS
MORNING -- IS SO SO THAT IS PART
OF THE THE THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS ROOM FOR ADDITIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN IN THIS
SECTOR THE FOREST -- WORKER
SECTOR OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THIS DON'T
SPECIFICALLY GO TO THAT TYPE OF
OF OPPORTUNITY BUT WE ARE
LOOKING AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY --
TO TO WORK WITH THE CONTRACTORS
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ON THESE PROJECTS -- AND HELP
THEM -- TO DEVELOP THOSE
WORKFORCES.
OKAY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
LET'S START MY RIGHT CENTER
STERN.
NAME IS SURE EACH REPORTER FOR
BEING HERE IN.
HOW TO MANAGE THIS?
HUGE STRATEGY GUIDE TO EXECUTE
ON BECAUSE I WANT TO DRILL DOWN
A LITTLE BIT ON THE POINTS THE
LA -- RAISE AND GET YOUR
REACTION TO IT.
SPECIFICALLY.
THE METRIC THAT I'M INTERESTED
IN [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
PEOPLE -- HOW SAFE?
ARE THE MOST NUMBER OF PEOPLE
GOING TO BE SO WHEN I THINK OF
LIKE I WE I WAS JUST TRYING TO
DO SOME ROUGH MATH A LOOKING AT
SORT OF THE AFFECTED POPULATION.
MATTHEW GUYS USED TO TO GO
THROUGH YOUR YOUR PRIORITY FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS FOR INSTANCE
AND LOOKING AT THAT.
FIRST CUT OF THE COMMUNITY
WILDFIRE IN MITIGATION REPORT.
AND I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT
WE KEEP THIS CALLING IT FOREST
WORK FORCE RESTORATION.
FORREST.
THE MANDATE IS ABOUT FIRE RISK
REDUCTION AND SO.
THE MOVIE IS NOT JUST IN THE
FOREST.
AND YOU LOOK AT CHAPARRAL AND
ALL THESE OTHER ECOSYSTEMS THAT.
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO.
ALL THE ALL THE SOUTH LAND
INLAND EMPIRE WE'VE HAD PLENTY
OF INCIDENTS ALL THROUGHOUT NON
FOREST AREAS WHERE.
BUT YOU KNOW IN THE WILL OF THE
WE JUST BURNED DOWN THERE ARE NO
FORCE.
OR WHAT I WOULD CALL FORCE IN
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS IN
THE SAME WAY SO.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHETHER YOU'RE WEDDED TO THE
EXISTING METRICS THAT YOU'RE
USING THAT SORT OF TAKE THAT
SORT OF MORE TRADITIONAL LOOK AT
SAY.
VALUING THE THE BIG THREE SIDE
OF THINGS AND SORT OF WAITING
THAT EQUAL TO PEOPLE AND YOU
KNOW I I RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF FORESTRY HEALTH TO
DRIVE ALL THIS BUT I GUESS.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THE THE THESE NEW
POPULATIONS AND MAYBE IN THE
PAST WE WOULDN'T I THOUGHT HAD
THAT INTERFACE BUT IT CAN YOU
COMMENT A LITTLE BIT ON THE
CURRENT METRICS YOU'RE USING AND
AND IS SORT OF WHAT THE DRIVING
STRATEGIES GONNA BE.
GOING FORWARD -- AROUND THIS OLD
SORT OF WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
PROGRAM.
SURE.
I THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THAT
QUESTION -- WE WE WE REALLY ARE
LOOKING AT THIS IN IN.
DIFFERENT WAYS AND I'M A I'M A
SPLIT THIS -- TO FORCED
RESILIENCE AND AND FOREST HEALTH --
AS ONE BASKET AND THEN THE OTHER
BASKET IS -- WILD FIRE
PREVENTION OR FIRE PREVENTION --
AND ON THE FIRE PREVENTION --
THAT PIECE OF THIS IS IS REALLY
GEARED TOWARD -- PROTECTING
LIVES AND PROPERTY.
AS THE FIRST.
ORDER OF BUSINESS NOW WITH THE
WORK THAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
IN THOSE AREAS AND THAT COULD BE
AND THANK YOU FOR POINTING OUT
THE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
CHAPARRAL LANDSCAPE AND THE AND
THE TRADITIONAL FOREST LANDSCAPE --
BECAUSE THEY ARE DIFFERENT AND
WE NEED -- TO ADDRESS THOSE
DIFFERENCES IN BOTH IN OUR LAND
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES BUT ALSO
IN THE THE COMMUNITY PROTECTION
ELEMENT.
SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOING -- OVER THE FIRE
PREVENTION TYPE OF WORK IN -- IN
A CHAPARRAL LANDSCAPE THAT
THAT'S GONNA INCLUDE NOT ONLY
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND THE
THE IMMEDIATE STRUCTURES IN
COMMUNITIES IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE INTENSITY OF FIRE AS IT
COMES TO A STRUCTURE -- AND IN
INCREASES THE SURVIVABILITY OF
THE STRUCTURE AND THE PEOPLE WHO
MAY BE INSIDE OF IT -- BUT ALSO
REDUCING THE INTENSITY OF FIRE
AS IT COMES ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE
FOR INSTANCE IN THE WALLS THE
FIRE WHERE IT BURNS IN SIX HOURS
FROM THE FREEWAY AND WON A ONE
TO THE BEACH -- AND ALL THE
HOMES THAT WERE IN BETWEEN THERE --
WE NEED TO REDUCE THE INTENSITY
AS IT GETS TO WHERE THE HOMES
ARE AND AND THAT -- THEN THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE IN THE HOME
HARDENING WILL HELP.
US TO PROTECT LIVES AND PROPERTY --
EVERY SINGLE LIFE.
AND EVERY SINGLE PROPERTY -- TO
US IS WORTH THE SAME.
IT'S IT MUST BE SAVED AT EVERY
WEEK WE WILL TAKE EVERY
PRECAUTION WE CAN TO DO THAT --
AND THEN THE MORE A FOREST --
FORCE MANAGEMENT AND AND FOR OUR
OUR TRULY ARE CARBON GOALS AND
PROTECTING THOSE LARGE TREES
THAT WE WANT TO PROTECT FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME -- THAT'S
WHERE WE GET INTO THE MORE THE
LANDSCAPE LEVEL -- PROGRAM WORK
AND THE AND THE THE THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE MORE TRADITIONAL
LUMBERJACK TYPE PROJECTS --
CHAIR WE DO STILL USE THAT ON
OCCASION.
DID YOU ACTUALLY YOU MENTION
HOME HARDENING DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THAT BEING PART OF THE SCOPE OF
WORK WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
FIRE PREVENTION SIDE DO YOU DO
YOU GO JUST TO THE EDGE OF THE
HOME OR IS SOME OF THIS WORK
FORCE IT'S GOING TO GO OUT AND
DO.
THIS YOU KNOW WE WENT THROUGH A
LOT -- OVERSIGHT HEARING AID
CENTER WIRE AND I HELD JOINTLY
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE SIMPLE
THINGS THAT HOMEOWNERS CAN BE
DOING TO PREVENT THEMSELVES AND
BURNING DOWN ANYTHING FROM
SCREENING ON YOUR EAVES OR THE
GAS GETTING ON YOUR YOU KNOW IN
YOUR GARAGE LIKE THOSE THOSE
STARTED.
PRETTY LOW COST BUT TOUGH
INTERVENTION SOMETIMES TO GET
PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS TO TO GO
THROUGH AS YOU AND JUST BEING
THAT WITHIN THE SCOPE WORD OR IS
THAT A IS THAT A SEPARATE.
BUCKET THAT THAT THAT'S THAT'S A
GREAT SEGUE SENATOR TO ARRIVE WE
ARE NOT PROPOSING MONEY FOR IN
IN THIS IN THIS PIECE OF THE
BUDGET WE'RE NOT PROPOSING ANY
GOOD MONEY FOR THOSE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES.
HOWEVER -- I DO WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND WE WILL
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION PORTIONS
OF THIS IN CONJUNCTION WITH --
CALLOW YES AND AND THAT PIECE --
THAT WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT A
FEW MINUTES AGO -- TO PROMOTE
OUR READY FOR A WILD FIRE HAPPEN
AS ONE OF THE PLACES THAT PEOPLE
CAN GO AND HAVE AN INTERACTIVE --
WAY OF OF DOING THEIR THEIR PART
OF THEIR HOME HARDENING -- AND
TRACKING.
YOU TWO REALLY I GET THEM OUT IN
THE THE PUBLIC REGULAR
VERNACULAR WHEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS IS JUST.
IT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH AND THIS IS
GOING TO GIVE US THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
SO THE THE HOME HARDENING AT
LEAST EDUCATION TO DOWNLOAD AN
APP ON THE OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION SIDE NOT SO MUCH IN
HERE.
BUT NO ACTUAL INCENTIVES FOR THE
OR INCENTIVES OR EVEN -- WORK
FORCE DEDICATED TO THAT ACTUAL
INTERACTION WITH THE HOMEOWNER
TO UNDERTAKE A PROJECT LIKE WHAT
WE'RE SHOULD THAT LEAVE LEAVE IF
NOT WITH YOU IS THAT IS THAT
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR SAY A GRANT.
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS YOU HAVE
THIS GRANT MAKING AUTHORITY IS
IS THERE THE FLEXIBILITY MAYBE
IN THAT POT TO BE ABLE.
TO BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO SAY
DOWNLOAD THE APP AND AND
RECOGNIZE THE RISK IT'S ANOTHER
TO SAY LIKE GO HIGHER CONTRACTOR
AND DO -- FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
PROJECT -- THOUSAND DOLLAR
PROJECT ON YOUR HOME WE HAVE I
DON'T KNOW.
LIKE TWO MILLION HOMES PROBABLY
TO COVER I YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A
BIG TASK AND SO.
ARE WE JUST WE GOT TO SEE
MOVEMENT ON IT THIS YEAR AND I I
THINK SETTING UP SOME METRICS.
THAT THAT WE'RE REALLY GING TO
DEDICATE OURSELVES PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA TO SAY YOU KNOW WE
ARE GOING TO TRY TO GET.
TO X. NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES ARE
EX NUMBER OF HOMES BY ECTASY --
TO NOT ONLY PROTECT IT WITH FUEL
BREAKS IN THE HABITAT AND ALL
THE SORT OF ISSUES AROUND SPEED
AND AND SORT OF INTENSITY.
BUT AT THAT HOME ITSELF THERE'S
ONLY I MEAN THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH
YOU CAN DO OUT IN THE FOREST.
RIGHT I MEAN WE KNOW THAT A LOT
OF THAT WORK ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
RIGHT AT THE HOME RIGHT AT THAT
WE WE INTERFACE SO WE'RE TALKING
TO THE WE THE WRONG AGENCY HERE
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THROUGH
YOUR EXPERTISE I MEAN WE WANT
YOU TO BE THE STRATEGIC PLANNER
WE REALLY WANT YOU. TO TO HELP
COORDINATE ALL THAT BUT I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T WANT TO FORCE A
ROUND PEG INTO A SQUARE HOLE BUT
THIS WORLD.
NEEDS TO BE FILLED IN.
THOSE ARE GREAT OWN -- IT
ACTUALLY -- DOES ALLOW US TO GET
INTO THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE ON OUR
LAND USE PLANNING -- AND CODE OF
KIND OF DEVELOPMENT PEACE
THROUGH THE FIRE MARSHAL'S
OFFICE DOES GET US TO HARDENING
OF STRUCTURES.
PRIMARILY.
STRUCTURES THAT DON'T EXIST
TODAY.
THOSE ARE THE STRUCTURES THAT
ARE BEING BUILT IN THE FUTURE --
WHEN WE GET -- TO IS THE THE
PIECE OF OF RETRO FITTING AND
AND CONVERTING -- COULD EXISTING
NON CONFORMING WE CALL THEM --
STRUCTURES -- THAN THOSE THOSE
ARE THE TIMES WHERE WE ARE IN A
A PLACE WHERE WE NEED TO WORK
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT LOCAL
PLANNING AGENCY TYPES -- AND
OTHERS TO HELP INCENTIVIZE --
THAT ACTIVITY.
YOU CAN DO THAT WITH THIS MONEY
CAN'T.
NOT WITH THE MONEY THAT'S
PROPOSED UNDER THIS P. IS THERE
ANY MONEY IN THE ENTIRE BUDGET
TO DO THAT.
THAT KIND OF WORK DO WE KNOW.
YEAH THEY ARE YOU IN IN IN MY
BUDGET NO NO.
DID YOU TELL YOU I MISS HER TO
GO OUTSIDE OF THIS PART DO YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
WHERE I'M NOT NO I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE AND NOT TO
OUR KNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THAT REALLY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
OUT THE FUNDING -- TO ADDRESS
WILDFIRES IT'S IN THE BUDGET YOU
HAVE AND THIS PIECE WHICH IS
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION MOST DIVIDING CAL
FIRE WHICH IS REALLY IT'S
FOCUSED.
SOLELY ON IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
NINE A ONE AND THE OTHER PACKAGE
OF BILLS AND REALLY JUST A
SETTING UP THE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE REQUIRED THERE THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THAT WAS REQUIRED BY
SB NINE I WENT AND SO.
REALLY FOCUSED ON ON JUST
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE BILLS IT
DOESN'T GO OUT SIDE THAT --
WHERE THE GVERNOR DOES ADD
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN IS THAT
NINETY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT I THINK
LAST WEEK OR TWO WEEKS AGO --
FOR THE ENHANCED AND FIRE
RESPONSE CAPACITY AND SO THAT'S
FIRE TRUCKS AND THEY SEE -- ONE
THIRTY TANKERS SO THAT'S REALLY
WHERE THE GOVERNOR IS TAKING
SOMETHING ABOVE AND BEYOND
EXISTING LAW AND ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AND SO I THINK AS WE TALKED
ABOUT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO YOUR I
THINK JUST YOU KNOW FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE AND WHEN
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT WHERE YOU
WANT TO ADD RESOURCES. TO
ADDRESS WILDFIRE ISSUES AND THAT
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT'S
REQUIRED IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE DO YOU WANT THAT ALL ON
THE FIRE IS SUPPRESSION RESPONSE
SIDE WITH -- EQUIPMENT AND STAFF
THAT CERTAINLY IMPORTANT -- DO
YOU WANT SOME FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL THINGS I'M TO ADDRESS
YOU KNOW HOME HARDENING.
OR OTHER ISSUES AND HOW DO YOU
STRUCTURE THAT HOW DO YOU CREATE
INCENTIVES AND AND HOW DO YOU
SET THAT THE BUDGET DOESN'T GO
THERE RIGHT NOW BUT CERTAINLY AS
YOU THINK ABOUT PUTTING TOGETHER
THIS PACKAGE AND WHERE YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU YOU CAN MOVE
THINGS AROUND FROM FROM WHERE AT
THE GOVERNOR'S PLACE STATE YOU
CAN YOU KNOW.
DO MORE OR LESS YOU CAN IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP.
WE WANTED ALL.
CENTER MONEY YOU HAD A QUESTION.
THANK YOU YEAH MAYBE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MAY FIRST TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
WE LIVE IN A RURAL AREA.
CYPRESS FIRE DISTRICT SERVED BY
CAL FIRE EVERY YEAR THEY COME BY
THEY DO A DIAGNOSTIC ON THE
HOUSE WHEN THEY'RE NOT OUT
FIGHTING FIRES.
IN THEY GIVE YOU A CHECKLIST
BASED ON THEIR OBSERVATIONS SO
UNDER EXISTING BUDGETS THERE
SOME.
HOME SURVEILLANCE IN THIS
INTERFACE -- THAT DOES LEAD TO
MY QUESTION AND I THINK YOU
PARTIALLY ANSWER THIS.
I LIKE THE MANTRA THAT EVERY
LIFE IN EVERY PROPERTY IS VALUED
EQUALLY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT MANTRA IN COMMITMENT.
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE RISK
WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
STATE MAP?
IN YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
DEPLOYMENT OF RESOURCES UNDER.
THESE BUDGET ITEMS AN EXISTING.
BUDGETS.
DO YOU HAVE A PRIORITIZATION OF
HIGH RISK AREAS WHERE YOU ARE.
PUTTING RESOURCES IN
ANTICIPATION [inaudible]
OF ARE COMING FIRE SEASON.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONEY -- SO IF
THE ANSWER IS IS YES AND NO TO
THAT -- BECAUSE CERTAIN PIECES
OF OF OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
OTHERS -- THAT YOU'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS BUDGET CYCLE --
OUR STATEWIDE IN NATURE OR
REGIONAL IN NATURE -- AND THEY
WILL BE COMING AND GOING TO
THOSE PLACES THAT NEED THE WORK
OR NEED THE THE ANALYSIS --
SPECIFICALLY -- THE ANSWER THE
THE YES PART OF THAT ANSWER IS --
WHERE WE GET -- TO DEPLOYMENT OF
LET'S SAY THE THIRTEEN ENGINES
THAT WERE WERE WORKING THROUGH --
SO IT SO -- A A AN APPARATUS OR
SOMETHING THAT IS YOU NEED TO
HAVE A HOME -- WE VERY MUCH ARE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THE ITEMS THAT
WERE CONSIDERED IN THE FORTY
FIVE DAY REPORT -- RELATED TO
VULNERABLE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND THE ELEMENTS OF
THAT AS WELL AS THE NUMBER OF
FIRE STARTS THAT WE'RE HAVING --
SO KIND OF THE DIAGNOSTICS OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF OF
KIND OF THE HOT BED AREAS OF OF
OF WHERE THE ACTIVITY IS -- AND
THEN ALSO -- OUR OUR RISK MAPS --
THAT SHOW WHERE -- OUR WILD FIRE
RISK IS -- HIGHEST THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ALL OF THOSE ELEMENTS
ARE BEING UTILIZED TO IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC POINTS ON THE GROUND
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO PLACE THE
INVESTMENTS AND THEN OF COURSE
WE HAVE THOSE.
THOSE BROADER -- INVESTMENTS AND
MY MY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
STRATEGIC PLAN -- WILL HAVE US --
DEVELOPING AN ANALYSIS -- THAT
GOES BEYOND THE THIRTEEN ENGINES
GOES BEYOND THE THE BULLDOZER
OPERATORS AND HELICOPTERS AND
AND AND AIRCRAFT AND AND SHOWS
US WHERE WE NEED TO LOOK AT
DEPLOYING MORE RESOURCES OR
MOVING RESOURCES AROUND THE
STATE TO BETTER.
SUIT THE NEEDS OF THE S. ALL
RIGHT.
THANK YOU JUST A FINAL QUESTION
FAMILY.
I RECENTLY VISITED THE CAL POLY
FIRE INSTITUTE IN DEVELOPMENT IN
LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT
RESIDENTIAL INTERFACE WITH WILD
FIRE AREAS.
IN DEVELOPMENT THERE OF A
PROTECTIVE FIRE RETARDANT NOT
SPRAYED FROM PLANES BUT APPLIED
ON ROAD SIGNS OF THE QUEST TO
GRADE WAS GIVEN AS AN EXAMPLE
ELEVEN FIRES.
STARTED BY VEHICLE TRAFFIC IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS ONE OF THOSE
FIRES COST ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
TO SUPPRESS.
THE PROPOSAL YOU TREAT IT WITH
THIS.
NEW.
ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE FIRE
RETARDANT -- IT LASTS ALL SEASON.
NO NO BY -- IMPACTS.
IN YOU SAVE THAT RESPONSE TO
ELEVEN FIRES CAUSED BY TAR
CIGARETTES ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH
THAT TECHNOLOGY -- INTERESTING
NO I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
SPECIFIC -- I GUESS I WOULD CALL
IT A FIRE RETARDANT IT'S IMPLIED
YOUR ROAD SIDE -- BUT ALL ALL
APPLICATIONS LIKE THAT ARE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT AND WE HAVE A
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
THAT.
I'D LIKE TO YOU FINAL THAT INTO
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THANK
YOU AND AGAIN.
AND JUST TO PITCH IN MY DISTRICT
THIS RESEARCH THIS GOING ON BUT
IT SOUNDED INNOVATIVE AND COULD
BE A GOOD PREVENTION INVESTMENT
THANK YOU.
EXXONMOBIL WIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO MAKE A
QUICK -- MISTER CHAIR -- CHIEF
HE SAID A COUPLE OF QUICK ITEMS
REGARDS CONTROLLED BURNS.
SAAD.
UNDER -- PROVIDING AIR RESOURCES
BOARD SOME ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
OUT WITH IN THIS -- TO BE ABLE
TO FOCUS BOTH ON AND REPORTING A
MODELING -- IS WELL AS A LINE
[inaudible]
EFFORTS ANTICIPATED.
SO SHOULD WITH A PRESCRIBED
BURNS PUNCTURE SHORT OF ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHANGES WE'VE HAD
ACROSS THE STATE IS.
LOCAL AIR AGENCIES IN -- THEM
NOT ALLOWING PRESCRIBED BURNS
BECAUSE A SMOKE SO IS THAT CAN
HELP THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S STILL SOME DISCONNECT
WITH THAT SO IF YOU ALL CAN.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
AND SENATOR THANKS FOR BRINGING
UP THE THE AIR QUALITY ISSUES
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST -- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE MOVED A LONG WAY --
JUST THROUGH -- DISCUSSIONS AND
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER BETTER --
BUT WHAT THIS WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
DOES IS THAT IT ALLOWS US TO GET
TO A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE TRUE.
HEIR IMPACTS ARE RELATED TO
PRESCRIBE FIRE BUT THEN ALSO TO
BE ABLE TO QUIT THAT BACK TO
WHAT THE DIFFERENCE IN THAT
BETWEEN BETWEEN THAT PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND WILDFIRE IS BECAUSE
WILDFIRE -- ISN'T.
THEN AND IT IS -- AROUND
STRUCTURES ARE MUCH MORE TALKS
IT'S BURNING A WHOLE LOT MORE
STUFF THAN THAN JUST THE
VEGETATION THAT WE ARE HAVE
UNDER PRESCRIPTION.
I GUESS.
QUESTIONS OF SENTENCES.
DO YOU BELIEVE IS GOING TO CLOSE
THE GAP BECAUSE AGAIN OF THE SAY
IN OUR NECK OF THE WOODS WHEN
THE BIG SEAN'S WE'VE HAD IS WITH
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS.
IN THE ABILITY TO ADVANCE
CONTROLLED BURNS -- AND SO.
IS THIS GOING.
TO ACT MADE GREAT PROGRESS.
I'M JUST BEING HONEST WE DID NOT
SEE THIS YEAR AT LEAST WITHIN
THE GREATER BAY AREA REGION
[inaudible]
SO WHAT.
SO IS SO RELATED TO CLOSING THE
GAP I THINK THIS IS GONNA WORK
TOWARD CLOSING THE GAP AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY CLOSE THE GAP OR NOT
UNTIL WE UNTIL WE GET THROUGH
THIS.
LET'S HEAR FROM FINANCE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ARE JUST ON THIS
CONTROLLED BURN I JUST HONESTLY
TO THE RESOURCES THAT ARE IN THE
BUDGET SO THERE ARE RESOURCES
BOTH FOR CAL FIRE AND FOR THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF US. THREE
TWELVE SIXTY TWO AS WE TOLD
SIXTY REQUIRES THAT THERE BE A
SMOKE -- MONITORING INNER
QUALITY PROGRAM AND SO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THOSE RESOURCES
THAT ARE THERE BECAUSE AGAIN I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT.
IN ORDER TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
ESPECIALLY TOWARDS SOME
AMBITIOUS TREATMENT GOALS
PRESCRIBE INCREASING USE A
PRESCRIBED FIRE IS GOING TO BE A
KEY TOOL -- IN ACHIEVING THAT I
DID ACTUALLY JUST WANT TO GO
BACK I AM TO ADDRESS SOME
COMMENTS FROM SENATOR STERN'S
THEY DIDN'T GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HOP AND I DIDN'T NO PROBLEM I
DID -- JUST WANTED TO SAY A
THING.
TO IS THIS A A FANTASTIC
CONVERSATION IT'S IT'S SOMETHING
I'M DEFINITELY -- TO THINK ABOUT
I THINK FOR THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE IN THE BUDGET I JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT -- THAT REALLY THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE IN THAT
PARTICULARLY THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION A REALLY FOCUSED AND
SORT OF THE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED IN THAT
COMMUNITY WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND MITIGATION REPORT -- ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON COMMUNITY
LEVEL PROTECTIONS I THINK THERE
WILL ALWAYS BE AN INTERPLAY
BETWEEN WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR
THESE LARGER ACREAGE TREATMENT
GOALS.
SOME OF WHICH WILL HAVE THAT WE
WE IN INTERMIX -- BALZER IMPACT
THOSE AREAS AS WELL SO JUST WANT
TO FOCUS ON SORT OF THAT THAT
THINKING AROUND COMMUNITY LEVEL
FIRE PROTECTION WHICH IS REALLY --
YOU KNOW WITHIN THE SCOPE OF COW
FIRES MISSION.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION
SENDER -- CHOIR.
BUT I WILL KICK THE DOG ONE MORE
TIME MANY THIS TABLE -- IN
REGARDS CONTROL BURN SO.
UNDER WHICH PROPOSED WITH THE S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY IT'S FOR SMOKE
PUNCHING FOR CANCER FORECASTING
REPORTING A MODELING TWO OTHER
ITEMS IN THERE [inaudible]
AND THERE ARE STILL CHALLENGES
ON THE GROUND WITH BEING ABLE TO
GET THESE BURNS PERMITTED --
THAT REMAINS WHETHER IT'S WITH
CAL FIRE OR WITH A FIRE DISTRICT
FOR EXAMPLE -- IT'S GREAT THAT
WE'RE DOING THE MONITORING FOR
CASH REPORTING AGAIN IS GONNA BE
A LARGER DISCUSSION BUT THERE
THERE ARE.
SOME CHALLENGES WITH GETTING THE
PERMITTED SURE AND I THINK THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS HERE AS WELL
AS MY COUNTERPART TO THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD ASSIGNMENT THAT
CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE.
IN DEPTH TO THE ACTUAL SORT OF
MY SMOKE MONETARY AND OUR
QUALITY PIECE -- AS WELL AS SOME
OF THAT INTERACTION WITH THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IN ADDITION
TO SORT OF LIKE HOW FAR WE HAVE
TO OFFER BUT CERTAINLY THE GOAL
IS.
INCREASING USE A PRESCRIBED FIRE
MEDIAN SORT OF THE GOALS WITHIN
THE FORCE CARBON PLAN AND AND WE
HAVE A LINE STAFF RESOURCES --
IN ORDER TO DO THAT -- YOU.
THIS BRIEFLY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR MCGUIRE THAT IT
THAT THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR CARB ON AND THE SMOKE
MONITORING INCLUDES TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY -- EACH YEAR
FOR THREE YEARS FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE
AIR BE UP HERE IN A COUPLE OF
DISCUSSION ITEMS THAT WOULD BE A
GREAT QUESTION TO ASK THEM
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS.
HOW FAR THEY THINK THAT'S GONNA
GO -- TO ADDRESSING THESE
CONCERNS I THINK THE SENATOR CAN
PUT WORDS IN HIS MOUTH BUT IT'S
NOT.
NO IT'S IT'S DON'T BURN ON
TUESDAY BURN ON THURSDAY BECAUSE
THE WIND AND ALL THIS OTHER
STUFF THAT'S IT THERE'S A
THERE'S A FLEXIBILITY VERSUS
NOTHING'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT. ONE AND NOT
ATTAINMENT AREA.
THIS REALLY QUICKLY AND THE
FIFTY MILLION I THINK THE FIFTY
MILLION SWEET VERY TARGETED I
DON'T EVER WANT THAT WORDS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MATH --
IN REGARDS TO THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER BUT IT'S GONNA BE FOCUSED
MOSTLY ON I THINK FIVE OR SIX
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE HI
FIRAS COUNTIES OF LAKE SHASTA
PRESIDENTIAL.
RIVERSIDE.
THERE'S ONE ADDITIONAL ON A
APOLOGIZE IN.
IN ADDITION TO THE OP I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH NON
PROFITS -- WITHIN THESE COUNTIES
AS WELL BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING
INFORMATION OUT THERE -- FOR
THESE HIGH FIRAS CANCER CARRIES
HAD BEEN IMPACTED I I BELIEVE AS
WELL WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE
FOLKS NEED TO BECOME PREPARED
AND ESPECIALLY ON RECEIVE
ACTUATION ROOTS AND WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO.
WHEN IN A FIRE STARTED IN THEM
AND I?
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON
THAT.
LAST PIECE IN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ANDERSON IS THAT WITHIN
THIS TODAY BUT THE TWENTY
MILLION.
IN FORCE MANAGEMENT GRANTED I
MEAN MOVING FORWARD.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO ANGKOR?
CORPORATE WITH WHAT YOU HAVE
MOVING WITHIN THE ACTUAL BUDGET
ITSELF.
IS IT THERE'S TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A TEN MILLION.
SO -- I'M DISORDER HOW THAT'S
ALL WE'RE NOT AID YOU MEAN THAT
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE RECENTLY
WITH GREAT EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
THERE'S TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN FORCE MANAGEMENT GRANTS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE MOVED IN
EXPEDITED MANNER.
AND SO THAT IS CURRENTLY IN IT
IN THIS YEAR'S CURRENT BUDGET.
AND THEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
BE MOVING SO I'M SORRY HOW
THEY'RE ALL RELATED IN IN
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAT YOU'RE
DOING.
IN THE EXECUTIVE ORDER VERSUS
WHAT IS GONNA BE COMING THROUGH
WITH THE BUDGET THIS YEAR SO I I
DON'T.
SO WITH THE PRIORITY PROJECTS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE FOUR
IN THE SO CALED FORTY FIVE DAY
REPORT THOSE WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD AND AND CAL FIRE HAS
IDENTIFIED THAT THOSE WOULD BE
IMMEDIATE TERM.
PROJECTS MEETING THOSE WOULD BE
DONE IN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS AND
SO THAT BOTH OF THOSE PROJECTS
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE INTEND WITH
THOSE PROJECTS ARE ALIGNED WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED.
FOR THOSE PURPOSES AN ANSWER I
PRAYED AND ASKED QUICKLY SO THE
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE THEN IS JUST
TIME LINE RIGHT SO LIKE BROOKE
TRAILS IN WILLITS IS BEING
EXPEDITED.
UP IT'S ONE WAY AND ONE WAY OUT --
THE AND THAT'S BEEN ON THE LIST
BUT IT WHAT IS HAPPENED PLEASE
STOP ME IF I'M WRONG WITHIN THE
TWENTY MILLION YOU'RE EXPEDITING
THE PROJECTS -- THROUGH IN THEN
YOU'RE ABLE TO SPEND ON THE THE
TWENTY MILLION ON THOSE
EXPEDITED PROJECTS I WANT TO BE
SURE TO DEFER TO CAL FIRE IN
TERMS OF THE METHODOLOGY FOR THE
IDENTIFICATION OF THOSE PROJECTS --
AND AND SORT OF THE PLANT THERE.
THIS IS OKAY AND THANK YOU AGAIN
CENTER FOR THE QUESTION ON A
RELATED TO THE THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS IN THE FORTY FIVE DAY
REPORT -- WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
FUNDS TO DO TO DO THAT OUT OF
THIS YEAR'S -- GREENHOUSE GAS
FIVE SO THE THOUGH THAT IS --
TAKING CARE OF RELATED TO HOW
THOSE ARE PRIORITIZED AND AND
THIS MAY OR MAY NOT GET TO THE
MEAT OF YOUR QUESTION BUT THEY
ARE PRIORITIZED TODAY THAT EACH
ONE OF THOSE ON THE THIRTY FIVE
IS EQUAL PRIORITY THEIR NUMBER
ONE IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY WILL ALL BE -- TAKEN ON
AT THE SAME TIME AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
I'M SORRY MR JUST BUT THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE IS YOU'RE
ABLE TO MOVE QUICKER.
ON THOSE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS
OTHERWISE YOU'D GET TORN.
BUT THEY'RE GONNA GO TO THE
TRADITIONAL PERMITTINGRIGHT AND
SO DO YOU.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE
THAT WERE SEEN WITH WHAT DOLLARS
WOULD IT HOW DOLLARS WE SPEND
THAT ARE IN THE BUDGET WE'RE
CURRENTLY DISCUSSING WITH THAT
IS ACCURATE.
THAT IS ACCURATE THESE THIRTY
FIVE PROJECTS WENT TO THE FRONT
OF THE LINE OF ALL PROJECTS --
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FUN TO
OTHERS AND THAT'S CHRISTMAS TO
CHAIR DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AGAIN ON THE
SECOND LAYER I JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY PROJECTS ON THE
LIST -- THAT HAVE PRIORITY IT
AND THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO --
WHAT WE HAVE UNDER THIS IS A
GENERAL -- SEQUEL -- EXEMPTION
THAT WE THAT WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE
AREN'T LOOKING AND LOOKING AT
AND PROTECTING THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE ON THOSE SITES.
HOWEVER -- BEYOND THIS -- THIRTY
FIVE IT'S OUR ANTICIPATION THAT.
OBJECTS THAT ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR GOING FORWARD -- WILL
FOLLOW A SEQUEL PROCESS UNDER
THE THE CAL VTP THIS WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAMMATIC DIR.
THAT IS IN DEVELOPMENT.
AND CERTAINLY WHEN THAT ITEM IS
PRESENTED AND IT'S PROPERLY GET
JAN DIES WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
FULL DISCUSSION OF IT -- BUT
WILL RETURN BACK TO THE ISSUE
BEFORE US AND OPEN IT UP FOR A
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS IT THIS
IS A TEN MILLION DOLLARS ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION RECOVERY
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
THAT WILL GET A HOLD OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL MAY SO
IT'S IN THE FOREST TRUST.
AND OTHERS SAY OFF THE TOP I IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT ARE YOU'RE DEALING WITH
HERE APART SEE IF YOUR AGENDA
INCLUDING THE CONSERVATION CORPS
IN A R. B. PIECES THAT I WON'T
BE ABLE TO STAY -- FOR BY DOING
A COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS ON
WHICH WERE DRIVEN BY THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD -- ALL
OF THE S. B. NINE A ONE
IMPLEMENTATION AROUND THE FUELS
REDUCTION AND IT'S BEEN SPREAD
ACROSS ACROSS A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT HEARINGS AND SUB -- TO
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF HAVING THE
AGENCIES HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
THE MONITORING LOOK AT THE
IMPACTS TO THE PLANNING. ONE
THING THAT I THINK YOU WANT --
TO JUST.
BECAUSE IN ALL OF US TO MOVE
FORWARD TO BE UNAVAILABLE
LANGUAGE OR WHATEVER IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE REALLY GETTING
THAT INTERAGENCY COORDINATION.
SO THAT THIS.
I MEAN COLLECTIVELY THIS IS
AMONGST THE BIGGEST INVESTMENTS
THE STATE HAS MADE AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND FOREST IN
WATERSHEDS THAT WE HAVE SEEN I
MEAN THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT.
AMOUNT OF FUNDING OF STAFF LET'S
MAKE SURE ALSO DOING SOME
PLANNING SO AS WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING FORCE CARBON PLAN
GOALS OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES A YEAR OF YOU KNOW
FUELS MANAGEMENT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT HABITAT MODIFICATION.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY ACHIEVING
IMPROVE WATERSHED RESILIENCE
GOING FORWARD AND GETTING THAT --
INTERAGENCY COORDINATION LET'S
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE BEING
PROACTIVE AND NOT JUST LOOKING
AT THE IMPACTS OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY HAPPENED.
I THINK THAT THAT'S TO SOMETHING
TO BE AWARE OF GOING BACK TO
SOMETHING THIS ANGER STERN HAD
RAISED IN TERMS OF THE
PRIORITIZATION OF HOW TO UTILIZE
THE FUNDING THAT CAL FIRE IS
USING.
YOU KNOW WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF LEAVING THAT TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE DEPARTMENT TO
SORT OF ADAPT TO THE SITUATION
OF THE YEAR -- SOMETIMES THAT'S
GOING TO BE WEIGHTED MORE
HEAVILY TOWARDS SPECIFIC AROUND
THE COMMUNITY.
ACTIVITIES WE ALSO NEED TO BE
MAKING INVESTMENTS AND WATERS
AND RESILIENCE AND WE HAD A
CONVERSATION IN THIS VERY ROOM
TWO DAYS AGO ON A BOND TO GET
THERE.
THIS IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
SOURCE OF FUNDING TO BE MOVING
FORWARD ON SORT OF WATERSHED
RESILIENCE IN KEY AREAS THAT WE
HAVE SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN THAT
LATITUDE.
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE OTHER
HOME INSPECTIONS IN THOSE THINGS.
THERE'S ANY OTHER VEHICLES FOR
THAT AND I'M LOOKING AT THE THE
BILL THAT SOMEONE MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD IS
CARRYING A B. THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
HAS BOTH -- MORE ROBUST
INSPECTION PROCESS EASIER TRYING
GET AFTER THAT LOW -- LOW
INTEREST LOAN PROGRAM FOR
RETROFIT SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
I WOULD URGE US TO MAINTAIN
STABILITY IN THESE PROGRAMS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE PARTICULARLY IN
THE GRANT PROGRAM TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT OF BUILDING WORK
FORCE.
HAVING THE STABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY YEAR OVER YEAR
FOR THAT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
IF WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW BUILD THE ARMY OF
PEOPLE THEY WERE GOING TO NEED
TO GET AFTER THESE ISSUES AT
SCALE AND SO PIVOTING THESE
PROGRAMS TO DIFFERENT -- FOCI
YEAR OVER YEAR IS ACTUALLY KIND
OF COUNTER PRODUCTIVE THAT WAY
AND IT IS FREE TO WHICH WE CAN
MAKE AN ONGOING COMMITMENT THAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE
FUNDING HERE I THINK YOU SPOKE
TO THIS EARLIER IN THE AGENDA.
REALLY HELPS -- FOR
PREDICTABILITY [inaudible]
SO -- AND IT'S FINALLY ON THE ON
THE AIR MONITORING -- DISCUSSION
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT ITEM
THEY'LL COME UP HERE SHORTLY I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD HAS COME AN AWFUL LONG WAY
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND RECOGNIZING THAT THERE IS NO
NO SMOKE OPTION JUST A MATTER OF
HOW WE MANAGE THOSE HEALTH
IMPACTS MOST EFFECTIVELY.
AND HAVING BETTER MONITORING --
AND MODELING CAPABILITIES LETS
US DO MORE WITH LESS IMPACT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NECKS.
MR KERRY MEMBERS HE'S AVAILABLE
IN SILENCE I WOULD ALLY IN ALL
OF OF MONTH PAUL'S COMMENTS WITH
THE VIEW OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE WILDFIRE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
AND WE ALSO THINK SENATOR
CERTAIN FOR HIS COMMENTS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF HOME HARDENING --
THAT BILL THAT PAUL REFERENCE
WAS A B. THIRTY EIGHT AND WOULD
CREATE THE FIRE HARDENED HOMES
REVOLVING LOAN FUND AND WE THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
I WILL GO TO CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING WILL KEEP THIS MATTER --
OPEN AND THAT.
THE FORCED AND FIRE PROTECTION --
CAL FIRE IS WE'RE DONE.
I'M GOING TO TAKE SOME THINGS
OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE I AM GOING
TO BE LOSING MEMBERS SO I WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO CALL UP THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD AND GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MILE STANDARD AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THIS IS S. B.. TEN
FOURTEEN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET [inaudible]
THIS IS.
YOU CAN SAY.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GANG MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ET CHANG.
I'M A DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
AT THEIR RESOURCES BOARD AND I'M
WE'VE GOT FOUR PROPOSALS TODAY
WERE HEARING ONE OF THEM TESE
ARE ALL LET JUST THESE ARE ALL
IN RESPONSE TO LEGISLATION.
I'M SENATE BILL TEN FOURTEEN
REQUIRES THERE BE TO ESTABLISH A
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BASELINE FOR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES SO THIS IS
LIKE UBER AND LEFT.
THE LEGISLATION ALSO REQUIRES US
TO SET ANNUAL TARGETS FOR
REDUCTIONS IN GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSIONS PER MILE DRIVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEEN SEEDS WERE
REQUESTING ONE P. Y. FOR TWO
YEARS. TO DEVELOP AND BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION NOW RIDE SHARING
IS CURRENTLY A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE MILES DRIVEN
BUT IT IS GROWING RAPIDLY AND
THIS IS A BIG DEAL FOR US AS THE
SENATOR SAID.
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS ARE
GOING UP WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR
GREENHOUSE GASES. FOR AN AVERAGE
TEEN C. FOR EVERY THREE MILES
THAT YOU ARE WRITING IN THAT
LEFT THAT CARS DRIVEN TWO MILES.
TO COME GET YOU ARE JUST DRIVING
AROUND LOOKING FOR A RIDE SO
THAT'S A LOT OF EXTRA MILES OUT
THERE.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST REGULATION
OF ITS KIND IN THE WORLD SO WE
HAVE NO EXACT BLUEPRINTS TO
FOLLOW.
AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HAVE TO
BE LOOKING AT ASSESSING
DRIVERLESS AUTOMATED VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT'S WHERE THE TEA AND SEES
ARE GONNA BE GOING IN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS -- WE ARE GOING TO
LEVERAGE RELATED EXPERIENCES
FROM OTHER TYPES OF VEHICLE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE THE
ADVANCE CLEAN CAR PROGRAM.
BUT MUCH OF THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO HERE IS UNIQUE ANNA
CAMP ABSORBED ELSEWHERE.
SO WE APPRECIATE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION -- TO APPROVE AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT HELLO.
THE CONCERNED MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE.
IT'S OPEN UP A PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR CLEAN.
S. B. TEN FOURTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S A
MOTION BY SINISTER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
WE CASKEY HI.
JONES REQUIRE.
MORNING NIGHT STARING AT THAT
MATTER PASSES FOR ZERO THE
POLICE BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS YOUR
INCREASING YOUR TRUCK LOAN
PROGRAM GRANTS.
THIS IS A STAFF APPROVAL -- HAS
BUDGETED.
SO THE TRUCK ONE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO HELP
SMALL FLEETS COMPLY WITH THE AIR
BASE IN USE TRUCK AND BUS ROLE.
CITY IN USE TRUCK AND BUS REAL
BASICALLY REQUIRES AN ON ROAD
VEHICLES BECOME CLEAN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
OF OUR MOVE TO CLEAN UP -- TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS THAT AFFECT
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES AT OR NEAR BUT HE'S
BUSY ROADWAYS AND FREIGHT HUBS.
THIS PROGRAM USES AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM FUNDS TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESS FLEET OWNERS
AFFECTED BY THIS RULE GET
FINANCING FOR UPGRADING THEIR
FLEETS WITH NEWER TRACKS.
WE IMPLEMENT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
FINANCING AUTHORITY THROUGH
THEIR CAL CAP PROGRAM.
WE'RE BASICALLY LEVERAGING
PUBLIC FUNDING WITH PRIVATE
FUNDING FOR PARTICIPATING
LENDING INSTITUTIONS SO WHAT
THIS MEANS IS THAT FLEET OWNERS
THAT CAN'T MEET CONVENTIONAL
LENDING CRITERIA CAN QUALIFY FOR
TRADITIONAL FINANCING.
GETTING WITH LOANS THAT ARE
BACKED BY THE STATE.
THE LENDERS USER TRADITIONAL
UNDERWRITING STANDARDS TO
ESTABLISH LOAN TERMS WITHIN THE
PROGRAM GUIDELINES.
NOW THE CONNECTION HERE IS THAT --
SP ONE HAS REQUIREMENT THAT
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY DMV
HAS TO VERIFY COMPLIANCE WITH
THE TRUCK AND BUS RULE BEFORE
THE ISSUE REGISTRATION FOR
TRUCKS.
SO WHAT THIS MEANS IS WE KNOW
THAT THIS PROGRAM AS WE LEAD UP
TO TWENTY TWENTY IS GOING TO
BECOME EVEN MORE POPULAR -- IT
WITH THE FORECAST THE DEMAND IS
EXPECTED TO EVEN EXCEED
AVAILABLE FUNDS.
THERE'S CURRENTLY A BALANCE IN
THIS FUND AND WHAT THIS BCP
REQUEST IS AN INCREASE OF
NINETEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT WOULD BRING
THE TOTAL LOCAL ASSISTANCE FOR
THIS PROGRAM TO FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS FISCAL
YEAR AND THAT COVERS LOANS FOR
ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND TRUCKS.
ON THIS PROGRAM IS A KEY
COMPONENT OF HOW HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES COMPLY WITH THE TRUCK
AND BUS RULE AND HAVING A SMOOTH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS SP ONE
REQUIREMENT.
SO I HAVE MY TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
TRUCK.
JUDGMENT DAY IS COMING NEXT
JANUARY YES THERE'S FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS HERE IS THE
CALCULATION THAT.
THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS.
FINANCING.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE HAPPY WITH
THEIR NEW FOR TRUCK THAT THEY
GET FINANCE AND NOT POLLUTING OR
THERE COULD BE SOME UNHAPPY
PEOPLE HERE.
ON JANUARY SECOND THAT DIDN'T
GET THE PROGRAM AND THEY'RE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE OFF FIRST OF ALL THAT
THIS REQUIREMENT IS COMING.
AND THAT ALSO THAT THE FOR THE
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM INCLUDING THIS FINANCING
PROGRAM.
SO THIS FINANCING PROGRAM HAS
BEEN OVERSUBSCRIBED AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROVIDING MORE
FUNDING INTO IT AS MUCH FUNDING
AS WE CAN.
ELIA.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS PROVE HIS
BUDGET TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
THIS IS THE ENGINE TRUCK ONE
PROGRAM NOW JUST.
THE CITRIC ONE PROGRAM CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S A MOTION
BY SENATE STERN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CASKEY HI JONES THE CHOIR.
MORNING.
STERN.
THE CLOSER ROLE THE BUDGET
REQUEST IS APPROVED [inaudible]
FOR ZERO HI -- LET'S DISCUSS
THIS ISSUE NUMBER SIX AND WE'LL
GO BACK UP TO ONE ANOTHER. ONE
OF THIS IS THE TRUCK IN.
THE OLD.
BEFORE I GET TO THIS I WAS AN
AUTHOR OF A LETTER WHICH SOME
OTHER MEMBERS THAT WE SENT A
MARCH FIRST REGARDING -- CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM ACHIEVING THE S.
B..
THIRTY TWO HAVE ANY IDEA WHEN WE
MAKE AN ANSWER ON THAT WE
THOUGHT YOU MIGHT ASK ABOUT THIS
ON HER -- WE ARE WORKING ON THAT
RESPONSE AND I THINK WE'RE
PRETTY CLOSE ARE HOPING TO GET
YOU GET YOU A RESPONSE VERY VERY
SOON THANK YOU FOR ATTENTION
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX YOUR TRUCK AND BUS
REGULATION COMPLIANCE OKAY SO AS
I MENTIONED -- SP ONE HAS A
PROVISION THAT -- REQUIRES A DMV
VERIFY TRACKS I HAVE MET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR REGULATION
BEFORE THEY ISSUE REGISTRATION
THERE'S ALSO TWO OTHER --
ELEMENTS OF SB ONE THAT AFFECT
YOUR RESOURCES BOARD WINE IS
WERE REQUIRED TO DO IN A MISSION
ANALYSIS OF THE IMPACT OF THE
TRUCK AND BUS PROVISIONS OF SB.
ONE AND THEN WE'RE ALSO REQUIRED
TO CONSULT WITH CAL TRANS AND
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION ON PLANNING
GUIDELINES.
SAID THIS BCP REQUESTS FIFTEEN
POSITIONS ON TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROVISIONS FOURTEEN OF THESE
POSITIONS ARE THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM AND ONE WOULD BE PERMANENT.
SO I'M JUST KIND OF TALK THROUGH
REAL QUICKLY WHAT THESE THREE
PIECES ARE THE LARGEST REQUEST
IS FOR THIRTEEN THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO HELP
US MOVE BILLY INFANT IMPLEMENT
THIS DMV VERIFICATION PORTION --
FORMAL CURRENTLY WORKING CLOSELY
WITH DMV TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMPUTER SYSTEM WORKS WELL WITH
THEIR COMPUTER SYSTEM.
AND WE'RE ALSO MAKING PROACTIVE
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT TRUCKING
COMPANIES KNOW ABOUT THESE
UPCOMING REQUIREMENTS AND THEY
KNOW ABOUT THE COMPLAINTS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS LIKE THE
TRUCK LINE -- AS THIS DATE AS
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
APPROACHES WE ANTICIPATE A LARGE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF FLEETS
ARE GONNA BE HAUNTING CONTACTING
US TO SEEK GUIDANCE ON WHAT ARE
THESE REQUIREMENTS.
I'M SUBMITTING INFORMATION TO
SEE WHETHER THEIR FLEETS ARE IN
COMPLIANCE TO LEARN ABOUT
FUNDING ASSISTANCE AND SO WE
WANT TO RAMP UP OUR STAFF SO
THAT WE CAN -- MEET THAT NEED.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE ALSO
MAKING CONCERTED EFFORT TO
CONTACT TRUCK AND BUS OWNERS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY NON COMPLIANT SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT SURPRISED WHEN
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY COME
AROUND.
ENFORCEMENT IS ALSO REALLY
CRITICAL BECAUSE WE WANT TO
ENSURE EQUITY FOR THE TRUCK
OWNERS WHO HAVE INVESTED AND
COMPLY WITH THE REGULATION WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT
DISADVANTAGED.
SO -- WE'RE CURRENTLY ANALYZING --
OWNERS FLEETS ADDRESSING
PENALTIES DEVELOPING SETTLEMENT
OPTIONS AT THESE COMPLAINTS
DEADLINES ARE COMING UP AND
THESE ARE THIS WORKLOAD IS GOING
TO CONTINUE THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AS A COMPLIANCE --
PHASES AND THE SECOND PART OF SP
ONE THAT AFFECTS US AS I
MENTIONED AS WERE SUPPOSED TO
EVALUATE.
THE EMISSIONS OF THIS AUTOMATIC
ENFORCEMENT PROVISION AS WELL AS
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT RELATES
TO THE USEFUL LIFE OF TRUCKS.
SO THE ARM OUR REPORT TO REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ON THE IMPACT
AND WE'RE ASKING FOR ONE LIMITED
TERM POSITION TO BEGIN THAT
ANALYSIS NOW.
AND THEN LASTLY WERE REQUESTING
ONE PERMANENT POSITION TO
PROVIDE CONSULTATION TO CAL
TRANS NCTC ON DEVELOPING GRANT
GUIDELINES -- S. UNDER SP ONE
CALTRANS RECEIVED FUNDS FOR
LOCAL PLANNING GRANTS AND THE
LEGISLATION ALSO DIRECTS CARB TO
PROVIDE THE LINKAGES BETWEEN
THESE GRANTS AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
YOU'RE NOT ASKING FOR ANYBODY TO
HELP ESTABLISH THIS DATABASE
WITH DMV.
SO THERE ARE WE HAVE RECEIVED
FUNDING IN LAST YEAR'S BDGET ON
TO DO A PORTION OF THAT WORK AND
THEN THERE WAS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT UNDER -- A IT WAS A
SORT OF A OMNIBUS CALLIE PA
TECHNICAL PIECE THAT WAIVERS
ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE PEOPLE TOLD.
APRIL ELEVENTH SO [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
NO COMMENT.
THIS IS THE HOLD OPEN MATTER SO
I'LL.
HAVE THE PUBLIC HEARING WHEN I
HAVE ALL THE OTHER HOLD OF
MANNERS.
WITH THAT NO QUESTION SCOTT
ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE THIS IS THE SO THIS IS -- SP
TWELVE SIXTY WHICH SENATOR
REQUIRE HAD A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS FOR CAL FIRE AND SO I
CAN HOPE I HOPE THAT I CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE HERE.
I'M WHAT THIS BCP IS INTENDED TO
DO IS TO HELP US IMPLEMENT A
BETTER SMOKE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
I'M SO THAT INCLUDES AIR
MONITORING SMOKE MODELING AND
INCREASE PUBLIC OUTREACH WE'RE
REQESTING THREE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND THEN ONGOING FUNDING
I'VE TWO POINT NINE MILLION.
DOLLARS A WE'VE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEIR
DISTRICTS ARE THE ONES WHO
ACTUALLY MAKE THE ON THE GROUND
DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH BURNS ARE
AUTHORIZED.
AND SO THIS FUNDING REQUESTS
INCLUDES TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP BUILD THE CAPACITY OF LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS SO THAT WE CAN BE
MORE EXPEDITIOUS AND MORE
COMPLETE AS WE MAKE THESE.
DECISIONS.
THIS REQUEST IS BUILT ON A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WE DID WITH CAL
FIRE AND DISTRICTS LAST YEAR AND
WHAT WE DID IN THIS PILOT
PROGRAM IS WE PUT MONITORS OUT
AND SO WE COULD MONITOR AIR
QUALITY AND METEOROLOGICAL
CONDITIONS.
OUT AROUND PRESCRIBED FIRES AND
OUR GOAL WAS TO SEE COULD WE
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
ACREAGE AND THE NUMBER OF DAYS
THAT PEOPLE COULD BURN SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION HERE AND LOOK AT HOW
CAN WE DO BETTER TO THE TEAM.
PART OF THE TEAM RIGHT WE WANT
TO PROTECT THEIR QUALITY PROTECT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH IN THESE AREAS
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING MORE
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
THIS PILOT WAS SUCCESSFUL
THEY'RE ACTUALLY CASES WHERE YOU
KNOW WE COULD CALL UP CAL FIRE
AND SAY HEY BEER QUALITY LOOKS
GOOD OUT THERE YOU CAN CONTINUE
TO BURN.
AND SO THESE REQUESTED RESOURCES
ARE GOING TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
AIR MONITORING FOR AN INCREASED
NUMBER PRESCRIBED FIRES.
ON IT ALSO HAS A COMPONENT OF
IMPROVE SMOKE MODELING THAT'S
GONNA HELP US REFINE.
AND SORT OF THE IMPACTS OF FIRE
THAT INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
USE AN ONLINE TOOL THAT WE
CALLED P. FURS.
AND THAT BASICALLY IS THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE APPROVAL IT'S
LIKE AN ELECTRONIC SYSTEM US
FOREST SERVICE CAL FIRE AND
OTHER FOLKS USE IT.
AND IT'S THE ELECTRONIC SYSTEM
WE USE THAT FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE
APPROVAL AND REPORTING.
THAT SYSTEM WILL ALSO ALLOW US
TO TRACK WHETHER WE'RE ACTUALLY
SEEING INCREASES AND PRESCRIBED
FIRE SO THAT'S KIND OF A IT'S A
WAY THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THOSE
METRICS.
ON FINALLY THESE REQUESTED
RESOURCES ARE ALSO GOING TO
ENABLE US TO EXPAND OUR PUBLIC
OUTREACH EFFORTS AND TO
COORDINATE MORE COMMON MESSAGING
WITH OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE
WORKING ON OUTREACH.
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THIS MODELING
THAT AGAIN THIS IS?
MAYBE I'M SHOWING MY AGE IVETE
WE'RE IN A WE'RE IN MARCH IT
RAINS.
IT STRUCK IT'S CLEAR IT RAINS
IT'S CLEAR IT RAIN SIX CLEVER
SORT OF GO THROUGH THIS THIS.
GOOD AIR QUALITY TIME IS IT IS
IT IS THE MODELING WHEN WE HAVE
SPRING WE HAVE THIS OFF AND ON
RAIN THAT YOU WOULD BE DOING
THOSE BURNS.
AFTER THE RAINS YOU KNOW BEFORE
WE KNOW ANOTHER STORM SYSTEMS
COMING IN YOU SAY OKAY.
DO YOUR BURNED AND THEN.
IS THAT ONE OF THESE MODELS I
GUESS IS MY QUESTION SO WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS BOLD WEATHER.
AND SMOKE SO WHAT WE WANT TO
KNOW IS IS THE SMOKE GOING TO BE
STUCK CLOSE TO THE GROUND AND
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NEAR
WHERE THIS PRESCRIBED FIRES
COMING ARE THEY GOING TO BE.
INUNDATED WITH THE SMOKE OR IS
IT A SITUATION WHERE YOUR
INVERSION LAYERS HIRED YOUR
SMOKE IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SORT OF DISSIPATE AND MOVE
AROUND -- SO WHAT WORDS SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
IMPROVED INFORMATION TO LOOK AT
IN MY UNDERSTANDING AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THE CHIEF IS STILL HERE.
NO PRESCRIBED FIRE SEASON IS
STARTING TO COME UP WE'RE
LOOKING AT SORT OF LATE SPRING.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE A QUICK
MEANT THAT WE HAVE PURCHASED
USING LAST YEAR'S MONEY LAST
FISCAL YEARS FINDING.
THAT WE ARE AND PLANNING TO HAVE
READY FOR THIS PRESCRIBED FIRE
SEASON SO THAT WE CAN START
MAKING THESE IMPROVEMENTS AND
START BEING A LITTLE BIT MORE --
PRECISE I GUESS THE YOU KNOW I
AGAIN I'M GONNA BE.
INELEGANT HERE IS THAT IS THAT
WE KNOW THAT IF THERE'S BURNS IT
THE IT MAY BE A NUISANCE FOR FOR
THAT THAT THE PEOPLE THERE IT
MAY BE.
IT MAY GO IF WE'RE FOR SAYING
THE TOLERANCE LEVEL IS ONE
HUNDRED MAKE A 1-001-100-2100
FOUR ONE HUNDRED FIVE BUT BUT
THE DEATH ZONE IS SO INUNDATED
WITH.
TIMBER AND WITH WITH -- FUEL
THAT AND IT'S ONE OF THE
IDENTIFIED HOT SPOTS THAT WE
THINK THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
THIS COULD BE A FIRE SO EVEN IF
IT.
EVEN IF IT DOESN'T MEET.
THE GUIDELINES THAT WE HAVE FOR
THE ERROR -- CALL AIR QUALITY.
WHO MAKES THAT DECISION TO SAY?
HEY BEEN ESPECIALLY AS WE GET
CLOSE TO THE FIRE SEASON YOU
KNOW THERE'S A THERE'S A IT'S A
JUDGMENT CALL ON THESE THINGS
WERE.
BLOCKED OFF STIPULATED IT'S A
NEW SENSE AT ALL STIPULATED THAT
IT EXCEEDS THE TECHNICAL LIMITS
THAT YOU HAVE I THINK THAT THE
END OF THE THE PUBLIC ONCE SAID
INSURANCE.
THAT WERE PART OF THE TEAM AND
THOUGH A BIT AND IN THE IT MAY
EXCEED THE AIR QUALITY NUMBER
FOR THIS DAY AT THIS HOUR.
THE BIG PICTURE WITH THE FIRE OR
THE POTENTIAL FIRES IS GONNA BE
CATASTROPHIC A GUIDE YES IT IS --
I I KNOW I THINK THAT THIS IS
IT'S A IT'S A REALLY CHALLENGING
AREA AND YOU KNOW I I WAS ON A
PANEL A COUPLE MONTHS AGO NOW
WITH THE GENTLEMAN WHO'S.
KIND OF A HE'S A FIRE EXPERT AND
HE LIVES OUTSIDE SEQUOIA
NATIONAL PARK AND HE TOLD THE
ANECDOTE WHEN HE WAS ON THE
PANEL HE SAYS YOU KNOW HE'S A
FIRE EXPERT HE UNDERSTANDS THE
ROLE OF FIRE THE NEED FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRE THE ACCESS
LOADING THAT WE HAVE IN.
OUR FORESTS HIS TOWN IS ONE OF
THE TOWNS THAT IS IMPACTED WHEN
THERE IS PRESCRIBED FIRE BECAUSE
THEY GET SMOKE WHEN THERE'S
PRESCRIBED FIRE EVEN WHEN WE
MAKE A GOOD BURN CALL THEY GET
SMOKE.
AND HE SAID HE SAYS YOU KNOW.
IT IRRITATES ME I DON'T LIKE IT
WHEN THERE'S FIRE THEIR
INTELLECTUALLY I KNOW.
THAT THIS IS THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND HE'S SORT OF AN
EXPERT IN THIS AREA.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE IS THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE AND YET THAT'S SORT
OF AN IRRITATION FACTOR BUT I
THINK THE OTHER THING THAT WE
HAVE TO CONSIDER IS THAT SMOKE
REALLY IS A HEALTH RISK. FOR
SOME PEOPLE YOU KNOW FOR THE
YOUNG FOR THE AGE FOR THE FOR
THE ILL.
AND SO -- STATE LAW SAYS THAT
THE WAY THAT WE MAKE THESE BIRD
CALLS HIS DISTRICTS HAVE THE
ULTIMATE -- SAY ON WHO'S GONNA
BURN HOW MANY ACRES THEY'RE
GONNA BURN AND WHERE THEY CAN
BURN IN THESE AREAS.
SYSTEM AS PROVIDE THEM WITH AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE GOOD DECISIONS
AND WE CAN BE AS EXPANSIVE AS
POSSIBLE WHEN WE MAKE THESE
DECISIONS?
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND I THINK IT IS
IT'S IS REALLY TOUGH BALANCE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
BETWEEN PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WHEN WE ARE IN NO THAT
WE'RE SETTING A FIRE.
VERSES THE HUGE VOLUME OF WORK
THAT WE NEED TO DO TO MANAGE OUR
FORCING AND RESTORE FIRE INTO
THE INTO THE MAR OUR WILD LANDS.
DOWN MATES.
LIKE TO ADD SOMETHING BRIEFLY IF
I MAY LIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
INCLUDING IN THIS PROPOSAL THE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING WE
THINK IT'S VERY KEY TO HELP
BUILD CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS AND START
TO WORK THROUGH THESE VERY
ISSUES OF HOW DO WE BETTER
COORDINATE THIS TO MEET OUR
GOALS AND ALSO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH [inaudible]
YEAH YOU.
I MEAN I'M IN THE PUBLIC I'M
CHAIRING THIS HEARING ANYONE TO
GET PEOPLE THAT ARE UPSET ABOUT
SOMETHING THEY ALWAYS SHOW UP AT
THE MEETINGS AND GO TO YOUR
LOCAL CITY COUNCIL BUT IT'S IT'S
THE THE PEOPLE THAT WILL SAY.
BACK.
AGAIN AND THIS IS THE THIS IS
TRICKY.
THAT PRESCRIBED BURN WHEN THE
BIG FIRE CAME.
REALLY.
CREATE A TOLERABLE -- CONDITIONS
EVEN THOUGH IT EXCEEDED THE AIR
QUALITY NUMBER FOR THAT TIME AND
WE'RE IT'S OUR CHARGE I JUST I'M
CONCERNED THAT.
THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER TEN DAYS OR
TWELVE DAYS LIKE WE HAD LAST
YEAR IN THE THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
QUEUING UP TO SPEAK TO THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE HOW -- TO
STREAMLINE.
THE PROCESS SO THAT THIS WORK TO
GET DONE IS JUST IS JUST.
THE THING YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT REQUIRES YOU REALLY QUICK.
I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK ON
THAT.
I THINK THE PERFECT GET IN THE
WAY THE GOOD -- IS CRITICAL FOR
THIS CONVERSATION -- AND PLEASE
WHERE I LIVE WHEN YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT PRESCRIBED FIRES
DONE FIRE BREAKS.
IN THESE MASSIVE WILDFIRES HAVE
HOT HOW FAST.
THEY BEEN BURNING.
IT STOPS THEM IN THEIR TRACKS AS
FAR AS SLOAN IT DOWN.
AND CAN'T LET THE PERFECT IN THE
WAY THE GOOD IN WELL JUST SAY IS
ONE CHALLENGE AND NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO THROW STONES.
WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
DOING THE SAME JOB.
AND CANDIDLY STOPPING.
THE PRACTICE THAT WERE SAYING WE
NEED TO KNOW SPEED UP. FOR THEIR
ENTIRE CAREER.
IN IT'S THEIR JOB RIGHT.
THAT COULD BE ON THE ISSUES OF
AGRICULTURAL BURNING OR THE
ISSUES A PRESCRIBED BURNING --
SO.
I JUST I'M CONCERNED.
THAT IT IS GOING TO TAKE LONGER
TO MAKE THE CONTROL SHIFT THEN
WHAT WE MAY ANTICIPATE.
I'M AND COMPLETELY WHERE A LOT
OF IT IS ULTIMATELY UP TO THE
AIR DISTRICT AND I'LL SHARE WITH
YOU.
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
LOCALLY AND I GET IT BECAUSE
THAT'S THEIR JOB -- IN WE CAN
THROW AS MUCH MONEY AS WE WANT
ADD IT.
BUT IT'S THE CULTURE IT'S GOING
TO HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE.
THAT IS WHY ONE OF THE POSITIONS
WERE INCLUDING IN THIS PROPOSAL
IS A PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICER
TO START HELPING TO ADDRESS THAT
CULTURAL CHANGE.
IS THAT WHAT THIS IS IT IS SEVEN
THE AIRPORT STAFF FOR THE PUBLIC
YEAH I THINK HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THE BOARD.
STAFF I MEAN IT'S SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE PUBLIC I THINK
THE PUBLIC IS ON OUR SIDE -- ON
THIS ISSUE BUT WHAT I'LL SAY
WITH YOU IT'S IN MORE IN.
AGAIN. ELEVEN THEY DO A GREAT
JOB AND ON THIS ISSUE -- WE ARE
ASKING THE CHANGE THEY'VE ALWAYS
STOPPED.
SO -- OR HAD SERIOUS CONCERNS
OVER.
LEGITIMATE BY THE WAY RIGHT SO I
I I'M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INTERNAL -- BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THE PUBLIC.
CAN SEE THE BIG PICTURE MOST
CASES NOT ALWAYS BUT SEE THE BIG
PICTURE OF THE GREATER GOOD.
NO I I APPRECIATE THAT AND YOU
KNOW WE DO WANT TO USE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE WOULD GET IN
THIS BCP TO LOOK AT THOSE
FRICTION POINTS AND SOME OF
THOSE FRICTION POINTS MAY BE --
SORT OF I'M GONNA SAY SORT OF
BEING IN A RIGHT FROM THE WAY
THAT YOU'VE DONE THINGS BEFORE
AND SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
THEIR LAND MANAGERS ON TO TRY TO
SOLVE THOSE ISSUES.
IN THROUGH THE CHAIR IN ONE OF
THE ITEMS THAT WOULD LOVE TO BE
A C. AS WE MOVE FORWARD IS HOW
DO WE EVALUATE.
THE INTERNAL BECAUSE I I I HEAR
YOU IN REGARDS TO EXTERNAL BUT
WHAT DOES SUCCESS LOOK LIKE I
COULD SET.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IN THE END
AGAIN NOT AT ALL TRYING TO BE
CRITICAL BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING
THEIR JOBS MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
HOW DO WE MOVE THE SHIP.
HI TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL ACRES NO IT'S A
BALANCE IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER THREE BEFORE THE
RESOURCES BOARD AND WE HAVE
ISSUE NUMBER SIX LIKE TO OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING.
ANYBODY A PUBLIC -- HAS ANY
INPUT ON IMPLEMENTATION OF A I
GUESS THE JACKSON WAS IT
LEGISLATION ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND THE LISTEN.
THE BELTS SP ONE ISSUE NUMBER
SIX AND TRUCK AND BUS
REGULATIONS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE'LL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
AND WILL HOLD THOSE MATTERS OPEN
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS IN
THANK YOU CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS FOR WAITING
WE HAVE. ONE ONE MORE FIRE
PREVENTION AND RECOVERY --
PACKET THIS IS -- FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
AND FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR TWO
POSITIONS THREE CC CRUZ IN ONE
GROOVY A LOCAL COURT
[inaudible] TWO THIRTY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU
GOOD EVENING SURE ARE BECAUSE HE
AND NUMBER MCGUIRE -- THANKS.
BRUCE SITE -- TO DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO IN SECTION SEE OF THIS
AGENDA -- THE GOVERNORS OF
BUDGET PROPOSES FOUR MILLION
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO ESTABLISH THE
FORESTRY CORE -- AT FOUR SITES
IN A IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THE FIRST SITE WOULD BE AT
IMPART THE CC IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LOCAL -- GREATER VALID
CONSERVATION CORPS IN STOCKTON.
THE SECOND SITE WOULD BE AT A R.
FOR ST.
CHAPARRAL CREW IN INLAND EMPIRE
NURSE EVER YOU KNOW -- CENTER
CCC CENTER AND THE THIRD AND
FOURTH CREWS -- ARE STILL --
SITES ARE STILL TO BE DETERMINED
BUT THEY WILL BE IN HIGH FIRE.
HAZARD AREAS -- THAT IS THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE IT.
LOVE IS IN THE ROOM.
SUPPOSE THAT WE CAME UP WITH
TWICE AS MUCH MONEY.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO CREATE SIX
UNITS OF CCC TO DO.
THIS FIRE PREVENTION I KNOW THE
ADMIN LEGISLATION ONLY REQUIRES
YOU HAVE FOUR UNITS BUT IF IF
YOU'VE GOT ADDITIONAL -- FUNDS
WOULD YOU BE OVER WOUND OR WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO CREATE COURSE
THAT WOULD ASSIST IN THE
PREVENTION RECOVERY WORK.
YES WOULD WOULD BE CHALLENGED
BUT IF IT WERE -- PROJECTED OUT
OVER THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO WE
WOULD ABSOLUTELY -- OUR ADDRESS
THAT CHALLENGE AND AND RESPOND
ACCORDINGLY.
L. A. L. DO YOU HAVE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY EFFECTIVE
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
NO CONCERT.
I WOULD SAY JUST TO THE CHAIR IN
TERMS OF HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
IS THINKING ABOUT WORK FOR SOME
AND REALLY THE LEGISLATURE BE IN
THEM.
AT THE AT PARTNER HI THIS IS A
PART OF THE WELFARE PACKAGE THIS
IS WOULDN'T BE ANOTHER SORT OF
KEY COMPONENT IN TERMS OF HOW --
WE ENVISION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE FORESTRY
SECTOR NINE WOULD BE SUPPORTED
BY I GUESS GIVEN THE COMMENTS I
MADE BEFORE I MAKE A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN.
THE CCC'S ACTUALLY IN THE FORCE
DOING PREVENTION AND LEARNING
ABOUT IT VERSUS BEING IN THE
CLASSROOM IN SAN DIEGO LEARNING
ABOUT.
JOB TRAINING AND AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP BEFORE THEY GOT
INTO THE PRESSURE PROGRAM THIS
IS THIS IS WELL IT MAY BE AND
SKILLED PEOPLE THEY'RE ACTUALLY.
IN.
THE FIRST IN IN THE FOREST.
DOING AT WHATEVER LEVEL THAT THE%
THIRD ABILITY IS.
FIRE PREVENTION THAT'S OKAY
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
I'VE BEEN ABANDONED BY ALL MY
MEMBERS ANYBODY.
ANYBODY HERE EDITION NUMBER TWO
ON THE FOUR SCORE.
OKAY E'RE GONNA KEEP THE MATTER
OPEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE.
I SEE ONE SECOND OF CAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS STAFF
INFORMERS BOTH.
ASIN PRESENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
THANK YOU AND WE ARE ADJOURNED